thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Mike Shaq was going all around how he's
doing on this glorious Sunday the return
of the Lords what's going on y'all this
world calls going on in the realm
serious Flack what's going on man what's
going on popping up I see you early let
me know how the levels the sun let me
know how he's doing out there Zach Riley
was going on Lydia master was sup the
home track what's up what's up the
hooded Canuck oh he outside he's not
gonna be in the chat no more because he
he's so hyped for stuff okay
what's going on Timmy version two what's
going on Lydia Mass what's up uh hustle
my brother appreciate you bro appreciate
you bro you got kitten coming in hot
messing things up
he helped me a head hot while I'm
talking to the real he about to play
music soon
okay you know how you do
violated she kicking the building what's
going on X coin what's up daily passion
official just in case the other Danny
pack this is the official daily passion
you know
[Music]
net representation love to see it was
going on kind of what's up what's up
can't stop watching that smooth video
yeah yeah yeah yeah no we're gonna talk
about it West Colin coming on we
probably could call it back on figure it
out pop nothing on that all right yo one
calling them
what's up what's going on that don't
want calling on what what you trying to
do
oh
we're talking about
[Music]
they got bad juju with or without me
data if nothing I'm doing is affected
what's good I think I I think I sold my
soul for 86. I think that's what I did I
think I gave it all 86 that one time and
God said no more that's it you had one
you you prayed for that and now you will
live in eternal
oh
we will talk
anyway oh yeah we're gonna talk about
that that's the topic um
no question yeah so look we're gonna get
my man hard deep and everybody else up
in the room listen to some good bars for
my man Dallas
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still in my Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
titty but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable
[Applause]
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got it
[Music]
thank you
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard a boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better Uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on Friday Kruger
that's who
let's do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all the
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
arson up into your apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but a man
talk social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the flame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you with messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still in
my Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal
it's house in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
vendor I gotta be Neato I know it's my
destiny work to carnido who cares if he
flies he's still a mosquito you swear he
ain't something but really be Stevo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if he really was
that joke King David still be the king
of the statue sister juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hate it we'll meet in The Crucible
wasn't it nothing is cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this and you're cubicle on the
Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can live here all
right there we'll spin the block and run
it back okay and stop blaming the series
that's one of the interest
foreign
[Music]
today
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
all right bike check yo y'all some
Savages fat epic fail let's go for split
screen
spin the block back this this is the
remix
we are back mike check next to the
levels is good right quick okay here we
go get that glorious voice right quick I
say that voice real quick so to make
sure everything is good now that we spun
the block back at it are you kidding a
little mic checks here
we go all right there we go there we go
back to back there we go that's what I'm
talking about kick and solve I mean just
let's see the levels right there we be
good news the nipple King is in the
building
we saw them yesterday
Cox Security in the building's calling
you security you did have that yo you
protected the target kind of energy yeah
you know what is the thing I don't know
about me right like I I'm kind of the
Pretty Boy
watch out joystick is out here I don't I
don't do it in that I don't I don't like
do sports gear and stuff like that yeah
come to the game Fly like I always just
kids like this man is dressing like he
going to the club like he's going out
yeah I've never I never did sports gear
I only wore jerseys but I played Sports
yeah
you need to wear this jersey when you
play do I have to I have this nice Polo
I could wear instead what action fair is
it energy
hear ye and finally we are live welcome
to the Ohio Lawrence podcast LLC and
also live on lordsofgaming.net episode
number 317. it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's day very excited about our
special guest and we've got Baldur's gay
versus Developers
Red Dead Redemption Part
PlayStation 5 USB ports
like it's coming in hot oh really oh
really that's what we're doing at PS
plus subscribers to discuss so that
sounds like they're losing steam
I can't so he took over half the show
yeah yeah clearly we have the perfect
guest for these types oh my God it
couldn't have blinded any better but
I'll keep somewhere in there the
PlayStation 5 Slim too oh yeah yeah
we'll put that up a day though you
already know and are we going to talk
about sorry we're gonna talk about some
rumors that I I just happened to cross
my timeline right now we could talk
about that or what we want to discuss
before we enjoy but we'll get into it
the natural course of things
I got to ship you the the Chainsaw for
your kneecaps oh God I think I know what
this is I I want to give like some uh
like inside on what I want to do I was
telling King about it I want us all to
make a trophy that's like like
representing like uh like a trophy for
knees or something like oh yeah like the
need counts
like you know when I won when I win the
Spider-Man and Wolverine thing King will
ship me hit so I'll have his and mine
what's happening imagine like King's
knees are a little too confident yeah
we just folded her keys and trees like
this man really been patient on all this
time here we go
anyway so so we're gonna get right into
it
I want to introduce a very patient love
only been a true friend to the realm of
the IOP but it was pure passion for the
games industry is only man by his
informative takes sense of humor and
commitment to the events that celebrate
the culture
introducing a panelist of the RDX and
game on daily podcast plus co-host of
the zealots of gaming podcast
the Lord of podcast community and messy
super chats
recently survived the one chip challenge
and will always be our packs and summer
game fast Brethren live from Boston by
way of India and finally making his long
awaited debut into the realm of the
Lords my man Lord hargit should me how
we doing sir I'm doing great thanks for
that awesome intro as usual the Lord of
intross uh yeah it's uh it's been a
while I've been on a couple of times but
uh maybe the final actual you know yeah
brother we had to get you the Royal
Treatment officially you've been patient
and I love to do the intros that kind of
stuff first of all how you been what
you've been playing has been going with
you busy with work uh and you know but
outside of that I've been uh in Hogwarts
like I say I finally caved it and you
know started to really get into it yes
um I I started playing on the Xbox and
then for some reason I don't feel like
patches or whatever I moved off to
something else and then never went back
back and now I have a pretty high-end PC
it's like I'm just going to start again
on there and try it
again
let me pocket watch what you doing over
here
yeah so I'm doing the uh AMD 7800x3d for
the processor and then the 4090 for the
GPU
I have a PC that can actually play games
that I'm on right now but I'm like I I
hate sitting in a chair there you go I
want to be on my you know my normal big
77 inch you know right [__]
I do have it
did you go back going back to it but
that's pretty much it so as far as your
gaming is concerned yeah I started edge
of Eternity which is like leaving Game
Pass and uh it seemed okay I don't know
I'm gonna actually finish that one but
uh but usually that's what I do whatever
is leaving I try to go play that before
it heads out yeah yeah you get that
little notification like yeah yeah like
one one more week yeah no that was doing
that with Marvel events pretty much it
I've been trying to get grounded going
with uh we have that last they added
some content they added an infected rude
mother for those who have played
grounded yes absolutely and that boss is
crazy easy hard to beat so we're trying
to like get a whole bunch of resources
so we can have enough healing potions
and get a third person to help him so
yeah that's another one that's in the
background we played a little halo last
night okay I heard things are looking
really good so as far as maps and stuff
it's good as far as like me being good
at it right totally lost
we've had it to get back into getting
the feel right especially when you're
playing against Real humans it's real
out there salute you always like jumping
up yeah they had a lot of good times
playing that yeah IOP Community streams
yeah those are always fun those are
hilarious
yeah we need to have combat night like
the boxing night get back no not boxing
night but you know Fight Night get back
to our um our cool games yeah and get
back to the the Halos on The Saturdays
yes get the community involved we got to
run these things we got things cooking
we got like I said Lord Lord Ty Lord
attic cooking in the background trust me
this one we got things cooking don't you
worry about it I'm kind of letting
someone else do all that you're good
with that yeah
and of course we got the Four Horsemen
of gaming those original Lords of the
rum here at the round table my co-host
Nicole Mouse my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf Lord addict of the attic show
back to back how are we doing sir doing
pretty good uh you know I played a well
one game I can't talk about a play this
way he's on some NBA stuff like an
Indian yeah I love the Indians
so I've also been playing a lot of
xenonauts too I don't know if like I've
talked about it a little bit like
xenonats is like the spiritual successor
of the old x-cons
very very old ex-conish not like you
know this new XCOM took a lot of modern
takes but that one took some Modern
takes but it's more in the vein of the
older x-coms and it's it's been a really
fun time time possible playing like an
absurd amount of Boulders gay three I
think I played it to like two or three
in the morning DJ got to get our new
character uh Quest going we gotta figure
that out I played like six different
characters at this point I am yeah
because every time I join another like
group right you gotta make another
character yeah yeah that sounds like
that's not cool
well it is what it is all right because
here's the thing like it wasn't at a
floor but if they how would you fix that
are they going to take overpowered
characters into other groups yeah
oh you want them to level it up I mean
because listen when Addie came over and
helped me in Eldon ring he brought his
op doodle here we go we and I'm asking
you I'm not telling you to show up for
some weak dude we gonna start over with
no what the hell is that oh we all gonna
fun have fun together no I'm bringing my
big homie jump me and I want my big
homie to come through so I mean I think
that's like equivalent of bringing a big
brother to the bully crowd
you could just see King pointing at get
him get it right there no didn't I do
that too Eric I was like that's him
right there
snitching a lot of Cooperative stitching
continue
sit down right here let me kill him and
I want to point out the people in the
comment section keep interrupting me so
stop acting like it's just me
interrupting people
he's hilarious continue I mean Boulder's
gay three you know we actually uh you
know talking about the developer Panic
here in a minute so it's going to be
interesting I I think uh you know people
I don't know I think I'm gonna make a
lot of people
it's gonna be a fun topic I can't wait
for you I'm gonna get some messages on
Twitter after this I know it is what it
is we're gonna talk we're gonna talk and
of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord the solo gaming list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the Lord of clarity
and location of the iron bank PC Master
race his own just saw him last night
Lord Sovereign are we doing sir I'm
doing well they're doing better than New
York Mets
I'm doing good I'm doing good um yeah
not too much gaming this week I actually
all I did was kind of throw on like I
told you guys last week I was trying to
get into Alan Wake remastered to get
ready for Allen wake 2 and uh yeah that
PC Port is not not the move so I moved
over to we got the announcement of Quake
too I said let me downloaded both Quakes
onto the the Rog and obviously the Rock
runs it beautifully or whatever yo those
games man yeah
when you talk about Doom you talk about
Wolfenstein you talk about Quake one and
two you talk about unreal the real
granddaddies of this man those games
still in terms of moment to moment
gameplay they're simplified right but
the fun factor is still there yeah this
idea that you know this unheard of idea
that hey I can look up and down in this
this first person shooter with such like
a revolutionary thing back then to see
them running you know like nothing on
this little tiny handheld and it can
probably run very well and something
even less powerful which is cool to see
so if you haven't played one and two uh
get them in Game Pass they're beautiful
but yeah that's a hangout last night
Cog with our boy Sean Mason
astral parrot King himself Jonathan
Roberts at the Mets game right there
whole lot of fun man just hanging out
there wasn't a whole lot of baseball
game watching
it's all about the friends you make
along the way when you're watching
camaraderie
worry about the skies and I couldn't get
left out of the conversation because I
get a phone call last night at 10
o'clock and I'm like what's going on
Brian
what's going on what's up my phone up at
10 o'clock I'm I'm panicking now he
knows that if I he doesn't like me call
him
yeah it's true when you call I actually
get nervous yeah and then it's 10
o'clock and I'm asleep and I look at my
phone I say oh my God I said oh
something really bad happened yeah a
football game broke up
because I asked [__] I was like no wait
a minute does he have does he does he
doing uh what's boxing tonight he should
be up so like I call him he's like hello
yeah you're the deaf voice yeah I messed
up I thought I thought he's doing combat
too so oh yeah so it was just to give
him a message that we forgot to give him
earlier in the week
um but yeah yeah so it was a good time
no you doing it too easy see I wasn't
going to run I had closed my mic he
calls right let's listen guys this is
this is the conversation yo king
um and then he just says um
it's quiet and then oh oh I'm like oh my
God
I'm like they got him they got him I'm
like I'm trying to get them where you at
where's the location
let's call it Scott let's call it goes
where are you at that was the moment
that was the moment we we the Mets
almost hit a hole right yeah and then he
goes oh I'm at the Met game
you must have been disgusting
yo my heart
have you ever had your fields of your
fears up yeah yeah so first of all I'm
scared with picking up the phone of
course because it's soft because he
don't call us often we call him or he
messages us but but soft calls you
there's a natural fear like yo this is
important with y'all what's going on I
agree I always get that internal fear
with something yeah
I'm like my wife looks over she's like
oh what's going on
he's not dying anyway
my apologies
so it was a great time hanging out with
those two we might just wound up mostly
eating and talking games man chilling
talking games back great guys to hang
out with that was amazing so thanks to
Sean Happy Birthday to someone
it's tomorrow I think it is yeah
actually so happy birthday to the homie
at your parakeet yeah yeah he's a cool
dude very very good we talked a little
bit afterwards when we kind of broke off
this is very intelligent man oh
absolutely I mean like
yeah
he's doing his thing he's doing his
thing so uh great hanging out also one
thing I forgot to mention last week uh
big shout out to Lord Lord Petty Lord
Petey TV ah what's up oh Lord yeah
playing watching holding down IOP
holding down Lords of gaming at play NYC
last week like obviously Cog was the way
King had things that he needed to do and
I was just under the table so cool thank
you guys for holding it down going out
there showing Facebook for IOP and for
long net you know that was great great
to see you so you see those videos up
from um last week check them out there
please retweet there's a lot of content
they just put out some really cool beat
em ups I saw yeah they cover some really
good independent games in the New York
scene shout out to um I believe all
what's the homie um why am I forget his
name Dan from Mexico yeah he didn't host
he didn't do it this year but he showed
up you know what I'm saying so yeah
salute to them that's one of our regular
Styles and good to see the Lord's
gaming.net represent Hold Us Down
no doubt and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer the prophet of Xbox Swami King of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the whole the line movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
okay we're doing a whole lot better than
Oscar Valdez Oscar Valdez for uh
narotech yesterday and um got really
beat up all right so that was the fight
for last night and that was gonna I was
gonna do that fight in conjunction with
the AJ versus helenius fight not fought
someone yeah AJ you was out there yeah
let me let me say his real name Anthony
Joshua oh Dad he wanted to get the agent
yeah yeah Anthony Joshua he fights in
London sorry guys by the time I got back
from the beach uh it was like around
five o'clock sounds like rich people
probably
is for everybody I got back from my
villa oh my God yo I was at probably the
worst Beach
yeah
oh no it's Alex hitting uh 50k
subscribers
everybody around the flaws 50k
subscribers thighs have been slapped
absolutely I would love to hit that
number 50k shout out to him
fantastic so you know got back from the
beach and I'm like okay let me set up
everything you know for tonight at 10
o'clock I get some rest and I'm setting
up the stream and everything and then I
look and they're like yeah they're
getting ready to walk to the ring right
now
right now
yeah so I forgot it's London time you
know and that's the problem when we have
uh International boxes that fight
overseas mainly
um the times is off so they have a real
fan base that's overseas but don't
really have a fan base here because the
timings don't work out for us right so
AJ went and he fought hellenius and he
got The Knockout I think it was like and
um
but the problem is you know while the
Deontay Wilder knocked the guy out in 30
seconds oh yeah yeah oh it was a
lose-lose situation because the guy that
he was supposed to fight popped dirty
for steroids uh oh so hunanius was a one
week replacement the last time he uh
Joshua had a hat yeah the dude's name
helenius that's a dope fighting like
yeah that sounds like in the realm of
dominance what sounds like it's part of
that he's six nine damn yeah he's six
nine he's crazy big strong dude
um but his chin ain't all that anyway
um so he got knocked out but this was a
lose-lose for AJ because it was no way
that he was going to beat 30 second
Knockouts of course and he didn't look
fantastic now this is what I fear for
for Derek James his trainer Derek James
is the trainer of aerospence is the
trainer of Jamel Charlo and is the
trainer of AJ remember the name at the
end of this year AJ is going to fight
Deontay Wilder I think that's going to
be the KO loss for AJ I think Deonte is
going to blast him out of that
um Errol Spence lost this year so far
and
um Jamel he could possibly lose
yeah yeah you need to stop touching
Caleb play no no that's no that's small
I got the wrong Channel somebody got
slapped
into the mix so Jamel is they're twin
brothers this is the reason why I caught
uh you know confused it yeah I was
confused he's gonna fight uh Canelo in
September that's a possible loss Derrick
James has had fighter uh I mean a
trainer of the year and it's a train of
the Year occurs every time somebody gets
trained of the year they go on a losing
run damn and I think this year is going
to be his run so shout out to him for
doing that
um I played the Revenant two
oh wow
I am not gonna lie if this is the
closest that you're gonna get to the
last of us all over the place right it
feels like Last of Us light but then it
has other aspects to it that's you know
way better than the last of us like you
know branching trees and stuff like that
when you get to the hub part the game
runs perfectly I'm talking about they
have a performance mode they have a
balanced mode and they have a quality
mode it's gonna give you three different
modes uh it's procedurally generated uh
World stuff and what I was explaining to
attic is being because of that beat this
is the reason why it's like Last of Us
light
is because in the last of us the world
is set so when the world is set you can
populate the world and craft the world
make it more beautiful in certain spots
when it's procedurally generated these
textures are generated by the AI and
then that means it's going to be a
little bit Bland in some areas you don't
know what the areas is going to look
like because of the set pieces are being
generated so that's the reason why it
can't exceed Last of Us quality it can
exceed it in certain areas but it won't
beat it in absolute visuals but the
performance is fantastic the game is
good wait two drop inside Game Pass I
lost my everything that was one of the
games like Saul was saying when we was
growing up to look up and down it's like
what and then these dudes this polygon
and it still was moving fast and furious
in the secret areas
it was like doom on steroids it's it's
so much and wifey walked in she was like
why are you playing this old game
I'm like if you don't get out of here
with your hate for the Ole Miss that's a
that was dope um and I played a couple
of games on my rug
yeah I'm rocked to the beach but I saw a
video where a pelican took somebody's um
not a pelican uh somebody I'm about to
say it got Pelicans that's taking
Portables off the beach no they took
their laptop on their laptop and it took
the laptop away I had a just a bad
vision of one grabbing my rug
so I don't know what Pelicans they got
over there yeah I wonder what's
happening over there saying I don't
wanna know no Pelicans keep that away
from me shout out to Rockaway Beach yeah
the lifeguards had drones flying in the
air checking for the Sharks and water
um my super paranoia I'm scared of
sharks so I'm super paranoia I was out
there looking for sharks too and um they
had a little quarantine Beach it was
nice it was cool it was not too many
people using the water looking for the
Sharks yes sir yes I think I think once
the shark show up it's a little too late
at that point I don't know they give you
some distance that you see
it pop up at the top and win a dude and
you know you I'm not that far away from
the beach bro yeah I'm not like you bro
you gotta punch the shark that's all
just punch
hand on his head
you sound like the dude who being the
full ride gear talk about this is how
you disarm the gun yeah
yeah
from the Riverboat
I never see this he took the chair away
from the dude he plays into it now it's
just common yeah
and he's shoots him with a taser did you
see the one where people were making fun
of him and it said some dude come up
he's like this is how you disarm with
someone with a gun but he's not gonna
shoot you and he throws a hundred dollar
bill on the ground
yeah that dude is wild funny
yeah that's about it I'm waiting for a
couple of games to drop in Game Pass I
got some good news from um uh Nick oh
it's a special dick yeah
that's some stuff for me so you know I
got the ships all about the hacksaw
all of y'all y'all love y'all love just
going crazy with Speck
after all these games coming today in
the game pass and a lot of these games
coming to Xbox in general now I think
car game yeah
I'm confused kid what happened
it was just wild news because I woke up
to the to the chat now look then it was
like the sign of six really what's going
on with that because it's becoming an
Xbox
wow that's amazing you know if that
would never happen you know that
innocent man we can't trust with that
stupid [__] with that ship is all Nick
be talking about I don't know
shout out to Xbox
the best dreams are made from
speculation yeah like funny speculation
shout out to me
did you see the uh apparently
final Final Fantasy VII like a picture
is put up on Xbox Brazil or something
like that oh wow
someone in the Super Chat said Canon
update Xbox teased on fire on Twitter
Final Fantasy 7 remake
all right so I just want to say one
thing right there because
yeah this this this this week everybody
got a chance to see uh how uh Ben uh put
out and gave coins oh yes so should we
show the coins
relax I mean everyone else has seen the
coin yeah yeah everybody so everybody
was hitting me up and they was like yo
King yo what's going on man dude did you
say [__] this man because we we ride we
will shut him down and I was like uh now
Ben has been an ally and a friend of the
realm from Way Beyond ass you know he he
dropped the patch for free for y'all
guys he sent that over he worked hard
overtime with Cog to get that ready for
our show
that out so we talked in the background
and I knew about this way before then
the only problem is that the people
supposed to wait until the deal was open
oh so there's a little premature okay
yeah
closes okay yeah so some some dudes bust
too early and you know a little too
overzealous
and I understand maybe the the the the
initial rules wasn't uh how can we say
because the budget call communicated to
the to the people who probably just get
past the part in the text the day he was
like oh wait please okay but uh again
you got it so it's it's like the Tom
thing where he was reading the infinite
poster and on the back it said don't
show no one classified exactly so you
know um it's funny how everybody gets a
chance to show up but the guy who
started to hold the line right
um
they was there so Carl could show you if
you haven't seen it these These are
glorious these glorious right now you
got a CDS perfect then we got that take
them out of that because that thing's
green yeah the green the gray so you
know what I'm saying we got that we got
yeah sure and then on the back it's
crazy it's crazy it's got the got to
hold the line on the back you know what
I'm saying yeah
but yeah
no no those are dope um yeah keep
looking out for the realm for other
stuff that we're doing so it was a great
collabo a lot of people kids move get
back in line
um
he said I can't believe I received one
yeah yeah
shout out to Paris in the chat he said
now we official Xbox Illuminati it's
official yeah so those people that did
got that uh shout out to you guys
holding on shout out to being a part of
the Great Community now there is a
sweepstakes that is online and if you go
to uh Ben Kenobi's page you can check it
out and you have to uh follow him follow
the lord and follow iron Lord's podcast
and retweet and 30 lucky people will get
a coin
um good luck to you guys and it's it's
something that is going to commemorate
and immortalize a moment in time facts
you know so so definitely look forward
to that and then look forward to uh us
pushing out some new information later
on forward yeah some real premium stuff
that you're gonna get but it's it's this
passion of this community that is
fantastic so whenever somebody comes
with a concept and comes up with an idea
you don't get to control that idea an
idea is for the community to be inspired
to be pushed to be shown uh different
things different levels and this is what
it's made for so listen guys he didn't
violate he didn't overstep none of that
stuff happened Ben has always been a
supporter expect everything that he does
no doubt hold on we got to get past he
said wait a minute my message didn't say
hold the hold until after ABK King try
to make me think I'm broken no no didn't
mention you
[Laughter]
so I feel all that good stuff shout out
to the last word he bought this tie got
Travis the whole means reunited giving
some tough love to bungee a little tough
love you know you got to get your little
you gotta get your little brother around
and throw them in the headlock sometimes
when he acting up so he had to have
those real talks it was a must watch I
highly Destiny haters you will love this
show I would highly advise you to watch
the last word that we just recorded it's
currently up right now on boxes Channel
go check that out as far as me it's been
a lot of um a little Ally man I got I
gotta shout out to Ally but really
rocking and rolling ever since um I came
back from Orlando gcx and was doing um
actually Baldur's Gate shout out the
attic for putting me on to because I
wasn't gonna get it because I got
starfield's company makes no sense and
then I'll just wait for that spot
version whatever whatever but then he
really put me on as far as the cross
save cross progression and then I'm like
okay then they had full controller
support on the Rock it's 1080 30 solved
it is really a looker on the device and
I spent like three hours in the
Character Creator and probably got
nothing done but it's I got the illest
wolf my dwarf is crazy shout out to DJ
you know what I'm saying we got all the
dwarf gang that's the first game I've
ever made a dwarf and I'm like yo the
boss is lit out here they're real beefy
by the way anyway so we got that and
then all the playing a lot of uh ghost
wire Tokyo dude we're back on that for
some reason just wanted to again runs
really well I want to finish it up I'm
getting very close to the end game has
its floors but there's a lot of that
hand movement stuff in the match I
really want Tango to continue with it I
think it has a lot of foundation
obviously some performance issues but I
do think there's a lot going on there
and did a couple Destiny rage out to
Sinister and the crew you already know
but um yeah that's what I got pretty
much it also I'm gonna get the super
chats before we uh get this going yes
sir I'll do this roll back okay all
right we got a lord Star Killer Xbox
series XO one member for six months uh
load bronze those PS5 USB ports are five
we will discuss it will not be able to
catch IOP live taking care of some
family businesses
clearly smoke and fire I'm gonna hit the
crest of the chapel Lords talk killing
himself Xbox series XO one he gifted
five IOP memberships
hustle and motivate member for 20 months
Lord bronze hope all is well which are
you as well my brother hope everything
is doing yeah well
then we got Mr bro yes across the homie
Danny passion official two dollar Super
Chat Cog make sure we all know Danny is
the officer I love it it's because he
got the official part it's like he's
been having impersonation problems so
you want to let everybody know this is
the real right here this is not that
other dude that's running around with my
name you know you gotta put that TM
right there yeah yeah it's the official
that makes it
[Music]
let me play with King's Hershey's Kisses
yeah
let's read this what do you want to do I
wish I could have went on vacate with my
baby kid
all Natty in the flex
statue y'all up
hey hey hey hey hey
you know you have that what he's doing
right well oh that beat oh yeah I got a
program about yeah that's default yeah I
got it I got it so the default to a b c
and d yes I just press one of those all
right we gotta touch that I need my feet
I need music for this that's crazy
program mine for like that uh you
triggered my trap card that's what's up
so King was all natural everybody's
liking that okay yeah this is ridiculous
um and yes uh I have uh
proved a couple of these said uh these
releasement beaches
somebody said you had the New York style
pepperonis
it feels more natural look at it it was
outside
oh okay okay we're going back to the old
days you will not be talked about
mingle amongst yourselves down there
yeah it wasn't it yeah no no no no New
York style pepperonis
I just want to make sure I acknowledge
the realm I want to acknowledge them we
will not acknowledge anything
there's a mix amongst theirselves kicked
over and see that in color continue
I gotta boot this guy out of here
you doing pepperoni pizza that's the
Hobie that's knob don't get it that's my
bed everybody going everybody
time out everybody
all he tried to silence the realm
seize him I posted on my uh Community
page on at gamiatic I said that you know
I'm not going to make a video until
Sunday or Monday well I said Sunday but
uh it actually turned out to be Monday
because I didn't do nothing today either
but uh
someone said some off the walls super
loose
it was um it was definitely whoever runs
that I play through joystick he took on
like on a mind of its own like he posted
on my thing it said take the break daddy
matter of fact let me come through and
make it extra special one whoa whoa whoa
that's crazy they had joystick cheap I
just left that there because I ain't
even acknowledging Nothing
by seeing it saying yeah you definitely
acknowledged it definitely Dodge it down
we gonna continue wow wow that's crazy
Robert Kelly five dollar super chat if
you don't have one the M classic is
great for switch upscales it to 1440p
and makes it look less stinky
crazy yeah I'm classic it does that job
it's a hundred dollars though but
um and we got Robert kellett two dollar
Super Chat devs need that joystick to be
on the bg3 level
it is uh like a little like it looks
like an HDMI sort of uh dongle thing
that you attach and you put the switch
through it to the TV and it does 1440p
and it cleans up the aliasing and what
oh King needs that yeah
there's like a hundred dollars it looks
like it's it's a it's a it looks like a
USB stick with an m on the end oh okay
okay
um iron bank
it has already been ordered it's already
oh hell the gods have answered me how'd
you go get it now yo somebody call it
the Vaseline remover this
the gods have answered me oh God yes
thank you guys I appreciate everyone
and we have Robin Kelly Two Dollars in
the chat broke star with that all right
Red Dead Redemption one conversion being
uh in the bushes yeah yeah Dead on
Arrival yeah definitely pushes it we
will discuss then we have Pat F two
dollar Super Chat blessed morning to the
Lords and everyone here you as well
thank you salute
then we have Craig hole again gifted one
IOP membership that's right forcing
people into the realm
that's right and we got hectored about
your man five dollar Super Chat oh hell
the incredible Lords General King
operation death to ps6 is going
according to plan I can confirm that the
psvr 2 has been eliminated yo
it was a hit yo yo what you got to do
with your point
yes yes uh continue continue
everything is going again since I order
a long time ago the payment must have
just went through
y'all heard they they wow with Lord
Robert Cafe they bad with low arrival
Cafe right now that's what I heard all
right like is Sony's problem
look he's like I he was the biggest
proponent of the psvr 2 and he had a
picture and it had a lot of dust on the
thing and he was just like I just don't
feel the commitment and I think he said
he was getting ready I'm not sure if he
said he was getting ready yeah but he
just yeah so it really was an uproar for
obviously a lot of uh piano two
enthusiasts and stuff like that so yeah
it created created a little thing but
King is out here Kings Dominion's out
here claiming what I did was I retweeted
and I was like next time listen to K
news brother oh so you guys something
happened cause yeah so you quote tweeted
all that right okay
I did that okay yeah executing okay
continue yeah we have necromancers
they'll gifted five IOP memberships as
well so let's put the crust in the chat
for Necromancer sale then we got a
Cedric H member for 37 months Lord
silver we don't have no comment thank
you Cedric appreciate your brother
absolute then we got a zip this five
dollar Super Chat Crystal Dynamics
should change their name to beefy
Dynamics or B beefy D for sure whoa whoa
there we go Robert Kelly Two Dollars
which had the Pelicans one in that beefy
rigs there
Pelicans out here
that we have project Aries five dollars
Super Chat gonna need to hold the line
camo spandex speedos for next summer oh
we hope so we do it kid
so we do got the slides we're going to
put the slides back in you know for the
summer we're gonna start working out
with merch to fit the seasons there's
gonna be some great stuff you can get
some slides you know some house stuff
trying to work with Crocs Crocs
did you see the shirt that I got on and
you see the Crocs you know oh my Lord
continue
then we have hold on a moment we have
project Aries no I got that hope that
okay I can finish that hold the line
camo spandex speedos for next summer
salute to the iron Lords and all of the
realm hope everyone is winning
Robert Kellen two dollar Super Chat k n
update Xbox teased on Twitter Twitter
ff7 remake
then we got stay high FFF at two dollar
Super Chat shout out to the realm and
chat shout out to you sir
salute to him then we have King is
overrated five dollars
SOB it's more the fact that it looks way
more possible now that about P6 than
ever before just let it happen Saab
don't fight it
whoa don't fight it I will fight tooth
and Nails
until that game is on my desktop I'm not
gonna absolutely not admit defeat uh
then we have Corey Tidwell five dollars
breaking k n reports Elon and Zucker
playable characters and Killer Instinct
update back to you
K news oh God
now we have Dragonheart Yobe member for
25 months Lord gold just wanted to share
with the realm hashtag peace love life
by the way I got employee of the month
for the seventh time at my job blessings
man absolutely that's what's up man keep
doing your thing plus I'll be having
lunch with the owners as well a lot to
learn hard work pays off at six
I feel like yeah do your thing bro do
your thing then we have oh we got jumped
crazy what else we got hold on a second
we have the death trap with the
40.
Ruby or rubles I think it's Ruby uh uh
Super Chat Cognito I would love to feed
on that meat whoa whoa music please
[Laughter]
they got a lot of cyberpunk energy yeah
if you know what I mean in this
character correct the Creator yeah
there's a lot of reasons people beefy
out here for reasons
[Laughter]
Nathan 09
Bungie really needs to sit down with the
community and talk their future projects
won't get the same support as Destiny
did without communication oh yeah yeah
Fairfax and I will say this I low-key
think that game's dead
I I do really well what I will say is um
shout out to them for actually pulling
up to gcx I didn't expect that
especially after the state of the game
that didn't what was it received well
and they they definitely seem to want to
fix their communication between
developers content creators and stuff
like that so we'll see we'll see we got
the Showcase coming after after the
final shape I don't think there's a game
left yeah we'll see I disagree
[Laughter]
then we need we had General Mack member
for 13 months Lord silver all hell the
ILP salute the Lord salute the gray
beards and we them boys we outside yeah
that's the OG
Mac what's going on
a area what's up
we got Grand wizard RDX intern member
for one month
[Laughter]
hashtag hold the LIE hashtag Freon again
minutes away facts there we got Daddy
passionate official once again five
dollar Super Chat there are too many
Dandy passions out there the Rog Ally
make sure I'm not bored while I'm in
line waiting to pick up my daughter from
school
yeah we have face 23b cam why 20 Super
Chat since I don't see you bringing this
up uh the upcoming Forza Motorsport will
be missing three major fan favorite
features at launch looks like a pattern
is forming oh King what you think okay
first no split screen a little bit of
the problem that's it first you had
enough uh oh what you make all the words
that you could have put exactly what
they were missing I saw that they put
split screen or something like that I
don't know who's doing couch Co-op I
don't care about that okay uh so those
are one of the features that you're
talking about yeah that's a nothing
Burger so cut it out you don't want the
AI move for The Spectators and the race
okay well you know these are certain
things that later on we will be talking
about things at some point in time
hopefully
um and we can dig into a lot of things
there's a lot of people with NDA dudes
too so
um maybe what you're talking about is a
nothing burger and I think so so when
you hear from K N news
so right now before the game comes out I
think you should pump your brakes you
know calm down a little bit yeah this
place okay in that news to give you the
real uh give you the real okay
all right that we have Robert Kelly five
dollars to chat make sure you have a 4K
HDMI cable when using the M classic mk8
uh smash the kirbys and even tears of
the Kingdom look a lot better with it
yeah that's true you don't get rid of
that stinky cable they give you with
that switch
HDMI 2.1 yeah
welcome to the iron Lords beef Market
podcast they should be doing the most
then we have Craig hooligan once again
he quote unquote gifted and IOP
membership we know how he gives those
membership though
the tail end of a barrel
Goonies then we got Corey Tidwell two by
two laws of a chat ban that dude for
that medo comment hashtag
I'm telling you that it's getting real
aggressive out here
then we have four as a legend member for
43 months Lord bronze hey just wanted to
say check out that Remnant 2. it's
amazing especially on the series X on uh
on God and them
[Laughter]
beautifully
and we are caught up Sir all right
finally all right no of course I always
of course
uh the death trap with the 100 rupees in
the chat I was talking about a famous
dish called Cognito don't take this
otherwise
delicious delicious yeah I know what
you're doing you think you slick what
you doing
um
no okay we have a Craig holy okay once
again remember for 11 months Lord bronze
is Bayern mutant worth 35 dollars
it's good again wait for 19.99 it's cool
it's very cool drop in price yeah yeah
get it for 20.
um Robert kellett two dollars Super Chat
I thought it was an open beef marketing
what are we doing bro what are we doing
cheerful anyway when we try to attract
the biggest names in the industry this
is what they're gonna see this is what
they see this is what the queen is gonna
see listen let me turn it down is gonna
see
Lord Cognito being accosted by the road
they still going on right now yeah we
uh Black Road in three five seven ten
dollars we chat don't no one care about
split screen in our online generation
stay worried about what Xbox do it and
should worry about their own game
happening that's not like a shot I mean
still that's not like a shot at face 23
BK
has been as he shouldn't because I
didn't say what it says Pony stay I
didn't see what that what that emoji was
it was a pony pony like he going at
somebody that's crazy anyway
um
all right we're moving on let's go all
right look so very patient I'm sorry yes
so uh I guess business King is Midway
okay and I'm two-thirds of the way okay
cool no doubt no doubt so we're ready to
go all right yes that we have gotten
well those are playing Super chats all
that good stuff we got to ship our Focus
back to our guest Lord hargit you don't
say we gotta talk about his video game
system history his journeys passion for
Tech and of course what led him to be in
the paneling some of our favorite
podcasts so well let's start from the
very beginning man what was some of the
first video game systems you had what
kind of got you into gaming sir yeah so
um when I was growing up I you know like
this started with all of us right we got
into this whole gaming world as as we
were you know coming up you know as
children
um and so the first thing I got I think
was like a little Tron there was like a
single game little thing and you know
what those were but like it was in the
arcade and then they brought this little
like one game only box yes I think that
was the first thing I had the trolls
what was that I said I don't know what
you're talking about I know is that yeah
yeah like I had that one and then like I
took a Hiatus back to to India right so
I was born here and then like about like
eight years old went to India for three
years no gaming done
so then I came back and the first thing
I just was get in in Atari 2600 because
that's what I remembered when I left
right this was 86. that's all G Talk
let's go adequate wake up so so I
finally uh got sorry 2600 uh and then
like the normal games like asteroids and
like track and field I remember like
but your forums had to be crazy
like so those you know those those
classic Atari games and then uh but of
course Nintendo was making its waves
right and so I'm like this looks kind of
cool so I pick up the the Nintendo with
the the light zapper gun oh yeah the
zapper see the combo
yes wow is that thing awesome
um and it came with Mario and duck hunt
the same you know the Dual cartridge
right shout out to the Laughing Dog what
we missed remember the little laughing
hey it was fun it was just a stupid
little
crate but
it would uh you know and uh Nintendo
always tried these quirky things right
it had that little robot thingy and I
didn't bother with that but you know uh
that was an interesting option I suppose
but I'm like whatever I just like the
light zap gun seems cool and then Mario
oh my God that game I spent so much time
you didn't even try Rob once I mean I
tried I've never tried it never never
gotta try it everywhere
it did not work very well
you you probably got robbed to work once
or twice yeah when he holds the
gyroscope and it's spinning and he puts
it over it was an entertaining concept
you know for kids because it was a cute
boy you know to have an actual robot
that interact with the video game it was
cool but everybody I know probably used
it at least once just refreshing my
memory gyro Mike was the packet or you
had to buy that additionally too Rob no
gyro Mike came with it okay had to right
because that was the game okay got you
continue that was the Lincoln yeah you
know what's funny I never had raw never
seen Rob it took it out the box because
when you brought it it was 200 with that
with Rob the robot in general right and
then they took it out the box and he
sold it for 150. got it then you have
you know um then they had the light the
the light gun only box that came with
duck hunt because they saw that duck
hunt was being played more than uh gyro
Mike right you had the cartridge that
had duck hunt and Gyro Mike really and
you had the ability to play either one
or the other right you know I only
remember the one hard geet's talking
about which is the Mario yeah Mario came
after if I remember right now
it wasn't a lunch it wasn't a launch
game yeah it was it was weird it was it
was packaged differently at the start
yeah
I was just saying because I came in late
so all I remember them is for the Mario
duck hunt combo right okay yeah got you
okay interesting for none of this thank
you thank you
for your two cents
yeah so so the Nintendo which is where I
did a lot of like like that's where it
started for me like it's really getting
into gaming right so uh you got Zelda
with the gold cartridge
oh man I spent so much time like and you
didn't have internet right so I don't
know if like people who are growing up
now they probably don't even understand
what it was like to try to find every
nook and cranny go to magazines and like
you know because you have to like search
first it was actually like it was really
hard like to learn you had to like
figure everything out yourself or you
have to go find like Nintendo used to
have is it right and then they had like
these maps
and so you you like you have to go find
everything yourself it was it was just a
totally different thing now of course
there's guides for everything I'm stuck
uh let me just go to YouTube right that
did not exist
I found everything in that game I like
played the heck out of it I played some
of the sports games like bases loaded
and like Blades of Steel and solved we
approved
right there like things like that and uh
you know I I played um Metroid I did not
actually you know get into it rygar like
oh chill the Rye God that's my heart
yeah that was an arcade accurate though
true but for us at the time yeah okay so
and that's something that's interesting
I never went to the arcade for some
reason I just got wow interesting I've
never been an arcade person but yeah go
ahead no no it was just like like
leaning into what you're talking about
right and they had a Nintendo would get
these licenses for these good games
that's in the arcade but when they did
come home they weren't arcade accurate
and for for me like I was a frequent
arcade dude
I will go play rygard all the time and
then when it came out to the Nintendo
the the regular Nintendo saw the
difference yeah I ran out of God and
that's when your your level of
disappointment happened yes this
appointment happened way back in Atari
2600 with Pac-Man a year yeah yeah
so those those things like that you know
we had to disconnect very early on you
guys got a good you know hard geek is
telling us how it really was so it was
yeah and rygard so you purchased rygar
and what was the other one that you said
you purchased
um I had Metroid which I didn't exactly
go into it was okay
um but there were a whole bunch of those
kind of games right but I like the the
mainline Nintendo ones Mario Mario 2. I
loved Mario too Mario too yeah it was so
good he loves Mario too and it's like an
oddball one right but it was so good and
then Mario 3 which added all these extra
Powers so let me ask you a question when
couch Co-op was a thing
um because this this this Mario Brothers
did you was you like stuck because I was
stuck in Maryland was my boy Calvin uh
and uh we would play uh uh Mario this is
where that Calvin character yeah that's
it Kevin yeah Calvin always messing
something up
about that brother
um so yeah so we would play Mario
Brothers now there's a difference
there's a Super Mario correct we got the
mushroom and he grew big and he grew up
and and then that was Mario Brothers
with him and Luigi on the board and it
was like a never-ending Loop did you get
wrapped up into that um it was Super
Mario it was Super Mario Brothers Super
Mario two and three
um I did play a lot with friends though
and what we would do is just swap right
so if I die next
so we would do that a lot and there were
plenty of games where you could play
together right so you did the infinite
trick
when you catch the coin um the turtle at
the end and you just bounce on it I did
do that yeah
let me give you a little bit of context
you would talk about the Mario Brothers
right the original Mario Brothers which
was the the platformer thing it wasn't I
had that game right for the 2600. oh
2600 version because I played a new
arcade it's crazy hard in the arcade you
playing choice so I just decided this
quickly when you mentioned it
so a water rated 9.0 a plus inbox Mario
Brothers yeah they're trying to sell it
on eBay for thirty thousand dollars wow
want to know if you played Baseball
Stars I don't remember that one I
remember Bases Loaded I think that was
the one where if you had bases loaded
and struck out and said you bums
um yeah I think that was the one I
played but uh yeah I mean I I don't
remember every one of the games they
played them but Contra I remember that
one with the oven
up down down left right left right b a
start yeah select start yeah yeah select
start correct thank you for correcting
it who was one of your um your favorite
third-party Publishers mine was Capcom
um at the time
no you know I'll go with Konami because
they had gradius and they had uh
Castlevania attack castle base yeah
remember Russian attaches that was the
first one you used running with the
knife
I mean he looked like flip from G.I Joe
yeah yeah we used to go to that little
spot on um you remember that little spot
it was like a Spanish restaurant that
had it a song
all these kids it was the restaurant
spot across the street from the um where
we played Double Dragon yeah right
across yes how was this an attack they
had operation wolf and they had some
facts that that was the era when you
identified a particular location for the
arcades that they had and I remember
Russian attacked this stick it was a
hard game continue
yeah I don't know actually because I'd
never paid attention to like how how
many games I picked from a specific
publisher the majority of my my favorite
games are actually from Nintendo because
they just have these awesome like like
Mario and Zelda alone are so
unbelievably awesome yes and that took
up so much of my time
I gotta interrupt because I'm I'm
feeling away
um so I don't hear any Sega talk there
hard to eat I mean I mean I don't get me
wrong no we don't want to disrespect
greatness that is yeah but I see this
void what what happened there though
just you just were in the ecosystem did
you know anybody would say
so I did I did so and you know but as
far as Sega I never went into it uh
because as as we all know gaming was
kind of expensive and yes I didn't
exactly have an infinite amount of money
at the time anyway to keep buying
whatever I wanted so I I stuck to my
platform I did eventually get friends
that had the Sega side so I played those
games so we would just go back and forth
right okay
they'd come to mind to play it uh
Nintendo
um and then I also got other consoles
like turbo graphics and stuff like that
but
you ain't you ain't going yeah I'm never
good this is a turbo graphic 16 podcast
um low-key do you got any any standouts
from the terrible people don't realize
it was crazy
and yeah it was trying to get into
something outside of what I already had
with the Nintendo so I I played Bonks
and slaughterhouse
there's another one that was kind of
like you called what was it the hu call
yeah
um
Chief courage and uh
let's not even front the sound quality
that was coming out of that turbo
Graphics yeah
above because he wanted to he said he
wanted to step outside his comfort zone
yeah Paul Sagan was like nah yeah he he
went turbo yeah he went turbo you went
above and beyond
um yo they was the first controller and
it's the reason why I thought they
called the turbo Graphics because in the
in the orient it was called the PC
engine
um on the controller you had a dongle
that you can push it up yeah from one to
two to three that would rapidly press
the button yes yep you can save your
buttons from being like mingled so uh
from rapidly pressing your buttons
um did you ever get the attachment the
CD attachment no I did not no
um at that point I think I went to the
Super Nintendo timing of Super Nintendo
versus turbo I think it was turbo first
and then I got this message the reason I
got it was actually uh you know it was a
neighbor who got it uh and and he's like
oh hey you want to just trade some games
like no I'm on turbo Graphics you can
just take these I don't need to borrow
any address because I won't do it cool
so like what the heck is Turbo I'm gonna
check that out and uh that's how I ended
up getting it
um right and but this is how things were
like buzz was created by word of mouth
because again we didn't have the
internet and like it just you know there
wasn't this this open Community thing so
we that's how I found out about it was
somebody else got it and like and I
guess you guys had King right king would
go oh yeah we had kids good I was
freeloading like crazy pocket watches
free loading
that one and then you know all this time
of course I also did PC so for some
reason when we came back my dad decided
to work with he's a building architect
right he's a design and architect right
and he decided to get with these
software guys and start some company
that went nowhere but they ended up
buying a PC and it was sitting in our
family room and I'm like this thing
isn't being used can I play with it like
literally and they're like yeah sure
they gave me a couple of pointers says
dos time right so and then I had to go
again research on my own learn on my own
how to use this thing and my main
purpose of course was to play video
games
I love the vision I love the vision
let's go I started getting those PC
games and I don't know if you guys
remember Sierra online right
and if I don't know if you if you ever
bought one and actually sent in the
registration I still I just figured what
the heck I'm going to send in the
registration it put you in a raffle
where you could win all the games I won
oh oh you won all the games
of all their games but did you get in
trouble because you was out here gaming
on PC when you was
what was that the data rates because
Okay so
remember back then we used to pay for on
oh you talk about 14-4 modem and all
that right the data rates that will come
through your phone bill will get crazy
and I and I noticed that the phone bill
got crazy when I was playing
um uh what was that uh x-band data rates
went up but I was giving my mother the
the money for the bill so that's further
that's further that was further down
yeah
I'm talking dogs and yeah but I was
doing dogs too this is what I'm saying
yeah
bulletin boards and stuff like that
right there are some servers yeah I did
do that I started getting I got a mode
of a 2400 but I had a 1200 then 2400
then 90 seconds like we started that
right like at the beginning of that
Journey right now was you getting the PC
magazines to get the free minutes
because this is how I'm remembering you
know you got to put in your AOL online
to get the free minutes I didn't get to
AOL for a while I I didn't do AOL at all
I didn't even do internet for a while I
just did all the freebie stuff anything
so that's how I did stuff right and you
can get bulletin boards that actually
gave you hints and stuff like that so a
lot of that but yeah I there was no like
issue I bought a game I registered at no
issues I got about four 45 games or
something like that whatever and so like
I just kept going through all those
games it was great
um so I've been playing PC the whole
time I love those games as well and then
uh you know I I one of my friends where
I was uh went to the arcade and played
this game called Street Fighter 2.
and he's like oh we gotta go play Street
Fighter too and and let's go Street
Fighter 2 was like one of those moments
in my life because it wasn't just about
uh just the game it was the
socialization absolutely right so right
so so like that friend met somebody else
who was insanely good at the game right
and so they would go and then I came
with them and then like mine now friend
circle is like 90 because of that oh
that's dope
so like all those folks like they
introduced me to their world and so now
I I've began with them and we're still
very you know they like they're here uh
um yeah yeah yesterday so that that's
how like that's how much street value
just like change everything so so
etiquette right yeah
right so all right so all right
um all right young hargit walks in yep
and then he sees his friends that
already know arcade etiquette and they
put their quarter up your mind is
processing what's happening did they
tell you ahead of time to put your court
up or did you just see it in real time
happening no I just thought in real time
and we just played and you know and the
friend that uh that is insanely good
we're still really good friends and he
uh he was just demolish people I don't
know if you had one of those in your
group but it was like you put in the
quarter and then we would be there for
hours and like you know
because he nobody could kill him nobody
could beat him right it was just crazy
and we're like okay dude we need to go
okay somebody want to give me a quarter
like and people will be rushing please
that's dope that's dope so is he
cheating people no no I mean Define
cheating and everything was within the
game legit so he just could do the moves
and he could just do them very well and
he could do them at the right time what
was his main character uh anything oh
dude he mastered a lot of them so he
could do guile he could do um
obviously Ken Ryu right like he could
pretty much do any of them I think he
picked up Dawson pretty well as well
right he just kept going so uh but but
that was good for me too because that
meant I had to learn yeah right be good
right and so I got good with all of it
as well and then then that game came
to the console it came to the Super
Nintendo and that was when I jumped to
Super Nintendo I'm getting that I don't
care we gotta have Street Fighters so
facts and to your point getting like not
being an exact copy it wasn't an exact
copy but it was closer it was close it
was close so this is really cool almost
getting his friend killed yeah my friend
Matt almost messed that up for me
because
you had the the import right before yeah
bro I brought the famicom and um
at the community center and I paid 250
for this game hargit yes 250 before a
year before it came out and I'm playing
and everybody that saw was like oh my
God it's like that okay but you know in
your heart is a little things that's
missing and he brought this ponytail
around here shout out to my geek friend
for that with the 42. Ryan Morales
that's what I've ever said this is the
reason why I hate it he's still alive
um and he he came in there and he stood
in the door and Cog is blowing he's yo
we got it yo you know me and him we
style energy is going crazy and he goes
it doesn't look like the arcade
I told Cog I see your car man I love you
get your friend out of here don't ever
bring this dude because I was bragging
like you gotta say like kid was a source
of me being able to flex so dudes didn't
believe me I'm like yo my cousin he got
Street Fighter right now no we don't
it's none of this though I'm like he's
got it right now we're gonna go to the
center you know what I'm saying and I'm
gonna take you there where he at and he
got it so I I grabbed you so he was
already coming in with the trepidation
like I'm lying right so then you know
that friend that just don't want to
admit like oh it's real wow he's got the
Japanese import super famicom playing
Street Fighter 2 port and I could tell
you if he was at all but he was still
hated
because it was real I was like yeah see
it's like I got my cousin what's up
looks you know it doesn't it
but you almost got beat up that day and
I saved you from getting beat up in in
the project so you're lucky that I'm a
nice guy but continue
[Laughter]
on yourself so yeah so um so Street
Fighter that brought in the Super
Nintendo and then of course Super Mario
World and uh was it linked to the past I
think that was the Zelda that came out
in that one right what about the audio
chip and that Super Nintendo when you
first heard the echo when you went down
in the tunnel with Mario and you heard
the echo like if you jump on a turtle or
something
sure right the little things that we
used to get like you know even on PC
right getting audio out of it right you
had to get special cards to do anything
to do anything of value facts right and
like so you had to get like the Roland
midi card if you really wanted to have
orchestral audio and you know the Sound
Blaster Blaster Sound Blaster car and
all the stuff that you had to do right
nowadays we just take it all for granted
because like everything's all voiced and
everything it's just so totally
different we have to like look at every
little bit we're like oh my God this
sounds so much better like dude this is
still like infinitely useless it's just
like a little known fact the the
partnership was oh with Nintendo and
Sony started with that Super Nintendo
because the sound chip was provided by
Sony
and that's what made it sound makes it
Genesis joint with I think was Hitachi
yeah it's a little crunchy orange
but when when Street Fighter said who
are you kidding yeah oh Nintendo and
then the sound
man they're the most simplistic basic
ass things
razors
see the game I know you you would have
lived you would have loved it he would
have loved it you would have loved it
yeah and look the the beauty and it's an
interesting thing right like growing up
with a new thing that's starting the
appreciation we have for every
incremental step is far better right I
and you know I think Gamers today would
say well hey that's a retro game that's
cool whatever right and they don't
understand like what it was like for us
this was a revolution when you could do
like Super Mario Brothers where the
character can go back and forth yes you
can go on the level like dude like a
little bit you don't even think about
like
I would tell you it was it's always been
to need a Nintendo on like Nintendo with
power was scary yeah because as a Sega
kid I remember we I've told this story
about the f-zero both seven pilot wings
pilot Wings was transformative I'm like
genesis is not doing it this is 3D space
where and then if you remember hoggy
you're talking now you're talking some
real Super Nintendo talk we're talking
music remember Super Castlevania right
and I remember just holding the Whip and
manipulating it and then you could
rotate the board like you could remember
that board you go in the tunnel yeah oh
yeah and I'm like and I'm sitting there
looking at my Genesis like you're done
y'all not doing that like you saw the
the the the game with shade they went up
in the ante and I was like damn Super
Nintendo came through I cannot front so
I respect what you said about Super
Nintendo that's that's for real but one
of the things I learned about that was
like gaming is gaming right so even when
my PC rig was not like very good I still
enjoyed the game it didn't end the
enjoyment of the game so I've always cut
slack to those kind of things so if if
you can't make that's fine if your
graphics aren't that that's fine is the
game compelling right right I'll I'll
give I'll just give you the time anyway
right so uh so I've never really said oh
hey you know the performance level here
is 50 more than I that's okay I don't
care the games are good I'm there that's
what I want to do is just play the games
so I kind of formed that while I was
like while that was happening because
I've had to deal with the incremental
like I don't have the money to buy this
I can't I can only afford this much and
that's what I'm gonna do on my PC and
that that's a performance level I'll
have ultimately it was awesome when I
could right not now my PC is ridiculous
but uh at the time that I couldn't I was
on a little XT machine with like a 20
meg hard drive
so at this time were you um looking at
the magazines coming out game pro Game
Fan egm uh you know Nintendo when I
could yes yes when I could yeah I can't
get all of them but yeah when I could I
would you know get things here and there
and and yeah and read what is new and
interesting and what what can I get out
of it all right so it sounds like using
Nintendo dude all the way up let's let's
let's so so let's skip to 16 bit because
we had 16 bit right now what 32 did you
go into
so I totally skipped the PlayStation I
actually had a hatred for PlayStation
what they what they did is they sort of
took the market and said hey we're going
to take like the established people Sega
turbo Graphics you know Nintendo all
these folks that are doing their thing
we had a vibrant market right we had Neo
Geo and 3DO and you could go on and on
Atari jaguar and all that so we had all
these players and suddenly Sony comes in
and says we're going to undercut
everybody
so you know it was it was normal for the
the console to not have margin like in
in the price so they would they would
take away the margin hit and but still
sell the console at a profit right so
the parts that go into it the shipping
and all that stuff that they're still
making money on but they would take a
hit on the margin margin would be like
the design cost the you know the the
licensing whatever right but they would
say Hey you know we're licensing the
products that go into it so you know
there's a cost for the cartridge and we
get our money back there right and so
but they would take care of the margin
Sony said we're gonna take a hit on the
cost we're gonna take a hit on the
actual parts right and that was just
something that the others couldn't
sustain because Sony came in with Sony
money right right like Microsoft now
it's like yeah
with Microsoft money that's what Sony
did
this this sounds this sounds a lot kind
of like the you know the accusations
that are being levied against I guess I
guess a certain company like their
generationally Sony was operating the
way Microsoft is operating system
it wasn't a small
small scale relative to what they are
now no Okay so they had Walkman money
right
numbers Sony Vega money they had Sony
Vaio money they had that money the Sony
cameras Sony was what Microsoft is now
kinda like that
they were that all right so and because
the only big players against them was
Hitachi and Panasonic right so Itachi
Japan I love me my Sony TV
listen a Sony TV back then that was a
thing right that's for sure
is that equivalent to have like a like a
Samsung now yeah like Amazon LG yeah the
luxury quality brand and they had the
Mind share the way the iPod was like the
Walkman yeah back like the Walkman was a
thing yeah I would say it's like that
it's like the iPod when it came out it
came the device fast that's what the
Sony TVs were and Sony TVs now
quality wise they're there the so last
year Sony TV was the best goal at TV it
was just it's priced ring its price
range is like a thousand more than the
Samsung or the LG I remember spending 37
600 whatever on my Sony 36 inch Vega
I don't think they've changed I think
they still are that but I think you have
LG and Samsung who come in and said uh
yes right well because they make the
screens they make this one yeah you pay
for it yeah
for your screenings and yeah exactly
things it's different but okay so hargit
we're at the point right now where
you're hating Sony because they can't
yeah
so yeah somebody comes in and says all
right we're gonna take our massive bank
and we're gonna come into this market
right they were actually working with
Nintendo as you said right and they were
trying to make Nintendo better yeah yeah
Nintendo Nintendo said
um yeah you want to do this CD thing yep
we're not convinced right because we get
so much on the cartridge and uh we want
to go with that the CD will be slow but
they went with Phillips though so well
did Nintendo yeah Nintendo went with
Philips remember what they did was they
had to deal with Sony in place at the E3
and at the last minute
yeah they left Sony at the office
and some of the stuff to Phillips and
then somebody said hey let's just take
this Tech and put it together right and
make it right it came in at a lower
price right uh making it very difficult
for their competitors to actually
compete with that and that's fine okay
to a point right but they uh their power
levels were significantly lower than
their competition the N64 was four times
more power whatever it is right plus you
didn't have this whole load time thing
right but all that's fine right the
problem is that when they did that and
with the PS2 they made it impossible for
the rest of them to stay in the market
right so and and that literally is
anti-competitive Right coming in with
your money and putting in a product that
nobody else can afford to do because
they don't have the hundreds of millions
and billions to back that so what could
they do everybody died literally
everybody died including Nintendo know
which we we just assume hey they're
still here they survive because they're
they're portable they did not survive
because of their game board the Game Boy
kept them afloat Sega had the problem
yeah the sega's uh uh portable didn't
sell as well and they just they kept
trying to compete with them but it just
it was too much and the other part that
Sony did was came in and said hey we
need content and they went to everybody
and said we want to take your content
away from them and put it here
okay so okay let's learn a little bit of
context to that right the biggest cools
that they did get was when they went to
square and square they knew the the
deficiencies of the cartridge the
cartridge would have to be a larger mega
size larger ramps
to get the game out and they did have a
Final Fantasy VII that was on cartridge
for the ultra 64 that was going to be
coming out what Sony did was show them
the disc
they put Final Fantasy on what was it
two discs or four this was it was I
can't remember that Final Fantasy 7
original yeah Final Fantasy 7 was on
either two discs or for this and they
they gave that to square and square was
able to put a real quality audio Yeah
rendered graphic backgrounds and
polygons and everything that was done
beautiful so
um all right so I I always believe that
the strong should survive I believe I
believe that uh in this market who disc
came two days no one never mind
I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry it took me to
the Remake oh I see this right okay so
chat Scene Three all right so it was
three discs and I I believe in the
Strong Survive yeah and also I believe
that you know Doggy Dog fine this is
business
you do what you can to win Sony did
everything that they could do to win
being jilted Nintendo started this fight
oh we played with attendance right yeah
I mean that's the thing Nintendo was
Sony before Sony like this Nintendo was
doing the same thing yeah that you know
that Nintendo didn't start all the
Nintendo was charging people for
cartridges yeah Nintendo was was uh
monopolizing the market Nintendo
marginalized and ostracized Sega sega's
fighting for their lives against
Nintendo Sony just ended them right so
it was wounded Sony came in hit him in
the back of their head get him out of
here you out of here turbo Graphics
young great over there but we're gonna
wound you we're gonna get you out there
because there's fighting for their life
over in Japan Sony came through finished
off any seat so Sony really was the
finishing blow Nintendo was the setup
Sony was the finisher but when Nintendo
gave birth to Sony by jilting Sony at
the uh
right so okay
no I'm just saying they're using their
power and influence right now and and to
your to your credit they did get a lot
of these licensing deals and block off
people but they were forced to do this
to get into a market that was really
dominated by The Big Three yeah yeah
well and there's fairness to that but so
they like said something like 250
Publishers and developers they went
after right to go get all their content
something along those lines
um and this is a video you can actually
find they actually said this publicly to
like a newscast right that they went and
did that and I'm like okay at that time
how many Publishers and developers were
there uh so they probably went to like
half or more and took the content and
this content does matter and to your
point yes Nintendo did a lot of that
could they have done it to the point
that Sony could no that's the difference
right so Sony and this is what people
fear with Microsoft to say well hey they
could just buy everybody that's right
and you should be afraid of that that's
not what we want right and that is
literally what Sony did everything
and that that kind of thing uh you know
basically tanked the market which took
my enthusiasm for the market away right
it became like it's just Sony and then
everybody else can go away and then in
Comes This weirdo Xbox which by the way
I was in the camp that they were talking
about in their uh
documentary of like why the heck are you
getting into this like true true true
that was the feeling yeah wait okay wait
I'm gonna take your Windows shut up
I'm confused come on right you didn't
partake in any uh song I was on N64 no
no I did not until uh PS2 is at the end
of its life at the end of that
generation so PS1 that made you get it
it was a bunch of the exclusives and I'm
like okay at this point I'll just buy it
just to play the exclusives right I was
never impressed by any of it
unfortunately but but I gotta be fair at
that time I had an Xbox okay okay so so
at that point I'm like uh you don't
Xbox was more powerful and you know by
the time I'm getting the PS2 the PS3 is
coming out right right so you're looking
at 360 is my current box oh yeah that
was Golden That's Golden Era 360. okay
all right and so anyway so income so I
had the N64 and the N64 was fantastic I
love it Mario 64. Ocarina of Time the
best game of all time right
um and then you had a slew of other ones
like golden eye and stuff like that like
plenty of cool games there it failed it
failed for for Nintendo commercially
right but it was a great console and
then you you go go I I did get the
GameCube once uh I got the the that was
the Xbox OG plus GameCube plus uh PS2
right right yeah so PS1 I totally
skipped PS2 I got at the end of its uh
of its generation but I did get the game
queue as as Nintendo fan I just kept
going with Nintendo right but I kind of
want more to PC oh at that point you go
to PC okay I get you so and and then you
know so the GameCube was great and then
like you know just from my personal life
right as far as like going through
college and all that stuff I started to
go to college and then I hated the loans
then I found out you could just work and
people will pay for a school I'm like
why the heck am I paying for stuff right
so screw that crap so I just went to
work and you know by the time it was
coming around to uh the the Xbox coming
out at that point I was done with all my
school and whatever right I was my loans
are all paid and I was writing that.com
like I was supposed to be a doctor I'm
Indian no choice I'm supposed to go to
Harvard go to be a doctor I did the
Harvard I didn't do the doctor but what
I ended up doing was uh you know going
into it and it joined the.com boom
straight out lit
he just skipped pass well I went to
Harvard yeah yes
these are things I'm not I was not given
a choice by the time I'm two but that's
right yeah
like so so the reason this is right my
dad grew up he he was actually well off
when he was born but he was in what is
now Pakistan and Pakistan was created
after he was born so they were kicked
out so they were wealthy because of the
land that land is gone so he struggled
but he struggled and and you know made a
life out of it right so he went to
school part-time got through that when
he went through through his college and
this is a time when India didn't have a
lot of universities right so even the
National College was ridiculous right so
he got in uh and he couldn't do the
full-time deal to go to college because
he had to work so he had to work and do
part-time he did that one of his
professors said you should go to Harvard
right and so he got that bug in his head
to go to Harvard so he emigrated here
just to go to heart
so he went to Harvard Masters and did
that full-time while working full-time
which is supposed to do but he did it
anyway and so and I'm around by the way
he I'm born I'm watching him do this
he's probably slept seven eight hours a
week it was ridiculous because I if you
haven't gone to a master's program alone
it's annoying Harvard is even more
annoying and at the time there's again
no internet you have to go get all this
information from their Library copy it
bring it home do your homework so his
day was ridiculous right and I'm looking
at this and I'm like yeah I have no
excuse I can't
you go ahead
I can't say no right so he's like you
you are required to go to Harvard you're
quiet to be a doctor right that's just
the way it is right and this is just the
way it is right so so like whatever
right and I didn't need any of it to do
my work why because remember that back
to when I was like playing with that PC
yes yes I learned computers right I
learned computers to play games but I
learned computers I did my work based on
the fact that I already knew how to do
computers right I learned windows I
wouldn't learn dos I I learned inner
mechanics of the whole back end of
Windows and and the back office stuff I
did that on my own that's impressive I
did not need any college right but so I
did pre-med until I went and did some
night so some um uh summer work and
during one of those I'm like you guys
paid for school I'm just gonna stay full
time because I was just managing a lab
of computers I'm like this is a joke for
me I don't know right now I'll just keep
doing that and and so that became my
career right and thankfully with the.com
boom that
became.com
right and and I did not limit myself to
one area so I was one of those and you I
think you're probably getting this area
right so I would do Unix Linux Windows
storage networking you can I all of it
right I would not limit myself and I was
good at all of it so on top of doing my
job I'm like yo I can go to school and I
have extra time on the weekends I went
and did extra work so oh this guy bro
this is super impressive so I just kept
doing all that right and so that's how I
paid off my loans immediately I like
because that's what gets people it's
those loans yeah
right and so now I'm making enough and
I'm like so I'm just gonna go in every
weekend you know Friday night after work
and check out what's out there movies
games whatever right I walk you know how
to say okay it was Circuit City no maybe
something one of those old ones that's
dead wow the Xbox came out right and
again I have I have no idea about
anything Xbox except the fact that
they're making a stupid console and I
don't know why the hell and and we paint
the picture because you you set it up
beautifully this is the area where they
really try and establish themselves like
Hey we're making a system sentiment was
just like you said hoggy which is like
Microsoft you why you do windows what
are you doing right it was a very and
and there was a campaign push if I
remember at like the circus cities and
stuff like that where they would have
kiosks to try to get people to say no
there's the Xbox this is what we do
continue the story I think I know where
you're going yeah and for those that
aren't of that era right here's why
Microsoft with Windows never really had
at that point a very stable system yes
right and so we as PC Gamers we dealt
with it but it would crash and you'd
have to deal with you guys complain
about oh my God I have to drive her
update dude dude you have no idea how
much worse it was troubleshoot gave it
an effect troubleshooting every little
stupid thing we're like I don't want
that on my console when I plug in my
Nintendo cartridges for decades that's a
great point they had that stigma you're
right continue and that's why we're like
no I don't want no windows on my feet no
get out of here even though Dreamcast
was wrong with her but that does that
doesn't matter but you know so like I'm
like why are you even anyway so I go in
and they just happen to have one that
week at Friday they happen to have an
Xbox sitting there I'm like
um
fine
did you play the kiosk
so so I I picked that up an extra
controller I pick up the games that I
think we're gonna be good like Project
Gotham Racing I think it was one of the
launched ones and it's a condemned I
don't know there was a couple yeah once
you get dead or alive I love condemned I
think I did get General I solve tease me
all the time I picked up the Xbox for
dead or alive and they were like Halo
y'all Halo I'm telling you and I'm just
yeah and this is what happened like and
nobody was there this is just me looking
at it they had like maybe three copies
of this game four copies that had like
30 copies of Halo yes and I'm like what
the heck is this Halo what is this I
literally had no idea what it was I pick
it up I look at the thing I'm like this
is gonna stink but obviously they want
me to pick it up right right and my
mindset going in literally is this I'm
gonna buy this play it 10 minutes and
throw it away that's what I'm going in
with I threw it in the car into my you
know carriage and took it all home and I
like to get the crap out of the way so
the first thing I do first yeah I put I
put Halo in and I'm like playing it oh
oh I can invert the okay that's cool
this is this is actually pretty pretty
good what's going on here
so I get to the ring and I'm looking
around I'm like yo hits I pause I call
one of my videos
exactly what you just did I call him up
like dude I got the Xbox there's this
game called Halo you need to come here
now
and he comes right over dude this is
Friday night right we we play that game
we did not sleep we went all the way to
Sunday morning and we're like yo we have
to go to work
don't blame sassy was in effect dude
Halo it was one of those moments that
game did not come out it was so good
like yo and and that just the entire
like my friend Circle everybody's like
we have to get Xbox on that's the way it
is yeah I did the land parties too oh
hell yeah I used to set those up bro
did you use your I.T Acumen how did you
set up I had I had projectors dude oh my
god oh wow I would have the projector
set up with an Xbox I have Lan cables
hooked up to a switch we would be going
16 players boom
you was doing your own wiring with the
camera system link I was doing like the
whole thing dude with projectors going
like 80 inch 90 inch screens for
everybody right it was
that was the time Halo one and two oh my
God split screen was lit a hargit's
house was lit dude so we we oh that that
thing was crazy that was like the
Resurgence for me of gaming on console
and and since then I've been on the Xbox
it's been great and again my PlayStation
has been uh hey you have these like four
five six seven eight games that are
sound like exclusive I see why you would
kick your brothers now I get it now I'll
go get your console play those games and
then whatever right so and it's the same
with PS3 I did the same thing with them
on PS3 now Xbox OG obviously a little
bit different with me Cog okay I'm not
gonna lie go ahead um it was a point in
time when I was a Sony head we was all
Saudi heads yeah you know absolutely
you're right you're right accept solve
because I betrayed Sega for Saturday I
love my I love the play and I was never
hating again but you hated PlayStation
once off no no I didn't I didn't hate it
at all but I wasn't all in like yeah I
was like that's it I'm not messing with
anything else no I didn't I didn't say
that see that's the thing that's the
difference right to be honest with you
okay I wasn't I'm just a lover of video
games yeah like an honest lover of power
power come on and Empower facts Sony was
doing things facts the others could not
do like when when I had my Super
Nintendo and it was doing most seven and
I looked over at Sega and I brought
everything for them to catch up I
brought the 32x I brought the the CD
fast everything I brought the Saturn I
bought the Dreamcast I brought
everything for them to to please take
over and win right but it was they were
just getting hit from too many angles so
he came in they had the sound they had
the licensees Mortal Kombat on Mortal
Kombat Trilogy oh yeah that Sony console
it was was ridiculous it was arcade
perfect so doing that stuff and and yeah
you had the load times Nintendo beat
them with the load times Super Nintendo
64 was incredible yes
um when they went to CD and they went to
uh GameCube GameCube was incredible the
Xbox came out when The Rock was on stage
and you had Bill Gates that was
incredible Madison Square I mean um in
in Times Square that was incredible it
was periods of times in our life that
was fantastic Sony uh Nintendo uh Xbox
they all have their place and I was I
was a fan of all of them and then but
when I got older I started getting Jaded
by the practices and I think hard geek
is more Jaded by the practices yeah that
forced his consoles out of position
because when I'm listening to him talk
you know Sony came in with big bucks
you're gonna stay there and getting
licensees and locking down companies and
developers to produce games only on your
console that probably jaded him towards
that box and I will mess with you when
y'all release y'all exclusive I'm fine
with that but
the the fact that you did cross over to
go get those games showed that inside of
you it was just about gaming it was all
all yeah it's always been about the
gaming obviously right but and so I
would I would not eliminate PlayStation
from my world but it would you know it
would be like a secondary console
tertiary because Nintendo is my primary
yeah Nintendo is your primary yeah now
I'm learning Nintendo was your primary I
love Nintendo's and it's because
franchises those franchises are so good
and they still are like they come out
their mid 90s better they're very very
good for sure right and so uh I've
always had that and so that becomes the
Nintendo exclusives box that I always
get and the majority of my gaming now
ends up being on Xbox
um or on PC and the PC thing it's like
it's off and on where I'm like do I want
to deal with this because I'm in it it's
like I don't want to fix things I
already do that for work
so that's usually been my you know my
mode for for uh for the gaming so but
anyway so I got the GameCube just for
again and they had some pretty good
third-party games as well but they had
to Star Wars the ones that they had uh
which were great and almost look at
Rogue Squadron or something
um on that you know I played Ari four I
think that was on GameCube but that was
where I first played that Etc there's a
whole bunch of those kind of games
that's when we first saw the Sherilyn
and the Kyla movie oh
with that Jackie look crazy but yeah so
so Halo I get that and of course at this
point I'm solidified like there's a
bunch of games that came out on the
original um XBox that were pretty good
but uh 360. which is the best console
ever yeah you already answered the
question and I already answered that
question okay damn and so I get the 360
and you know it launches like cod two
right and let's make no mistakes Call of
Duty made itself
because of the 360s back end yes because
of the 360s Xbox Live Chat let's go the
dude bro shooter box I already had that
stigma with Halo 60fps Halo was in
trouble Cod became a thing because of
Xbox and you know like that was a launch
time almost sounds organic continuing it
almost sounds organic the way you talk
it to me it totally is organic that is
coming home but anyway so
um so Cod like on that with and they had
uh like something Richard fog oh I
remember all of it okay
now that the internet is expanding
everything's expanding when did you
first learn about E3
uh we learned about E3 very early on we
was getting the tapes right we was
getting to see uh the VHS tape so it was
like three four months after the fact we
got it in September and you know um E3
was in June it was closed off to the
public when did you start really taking
notice to the upcoming stuff and being
part of the industry like it was the 360
era yeah
um so that was when it was and Peter
Moore my God
that man was a showman
that era and why I think the 360 is the
best is because we didn't have this like
need to make games so ridiculously high
fidelity but they were high enough
Fidelity and that you could get the
games out in a few years so you had a
Trilogy of games for a lot of things
that's just never gonna happen again you
had Oblivion Skyrim and Fallout 3 from
Bethesda is that ever gonna happen again
no no you got Halo 3 Halo 4 reach ODS
like gears one two three and judgment
you got Mass Effect Mass Effect was in
that era Bioshock one two three
Borderlands play the sound I could go on
it his flowers right and like even on
the PlayStation side you had Uncharted
one two three Last of Us all in the same
gen right the stuff that you could pull
off is just it's not not something like
the entire Assassin's Creed yes
one two three four on on 360 right and
uh
we're all talking about this era is the
the hour probably from what you're
saying is our platinum and golden golden
era it is
taking notice of who is the CEOs and
starting to to lock down names like uh
uh uh
Peter Moore starting something to
understand exactly what positions in
these companies when did you start
taking advantage of that aspect of it
like when I saw them right when they
were presenting then I could tell okay
oh this is somebody who's doing this and
you could tell what Peter was Peter was
like just I want everything he basically
took the Sony you know thing and said
wait I got that that big bag now yeah he
got the back because they killed
yeah he just took it all like it was
great he was aggressive so and
unfortunately he left and then it sort
of yeah
[Laughter]
I don't think he was off on some of the
things he was doing because look the
Netflix partnership yeah was something
that expanded that right so Netflix was
going to start maybe taking off but
having it on the console just be there
gave it a foothold and now you got it
right so a lot of people had the 360
they just say hey I can just download
stuff and I can just watch these things
this is cool I can start streaming stuff
um and that is a Visionary future thing
that unfortunately did not resonate it
correctly and that was a failure of
messaging yes but to have that now look
that eventually was going to meander
into the TV itself thankfully it did
write the TV itself now handles all that
but your consoles can do it as well but
that was not the wrong Vision to have
like your your getting your media games
and streams right right so that wasn't a
bad idea it's just the implementation
the problem is they you know when when
looking at Microsoft Microsoft did this
because Sony was becoming too big yeah
Sony was you know telling them we're
taking over the living room
Xbox got in the game because of that
yeah yeah that's how they convinced Bill
Gates to get in because they were like
Windows yeah and it turned out and it
turned out that they couldn't do it and
build something to do he was so pissed
off because they were like you lied to
me yeah and then he went and he went
ahead with it anyway but yeah
um but yeah so like and they went with
Xbox and did that and that's all cool
but it never turned out to be an issue
right so I think it's never going to
take over windows but what did happen
the big thing that they did Miss was
Apple came out and created the iPhone
yes yes and and Microsoft decided to be
stupid about it even though they had
smartphones they had Windows CE
smartphones they just didn't think it
was something that was going to go
anywhere because their implementation
sucked and you know uh you know Apple in
typical Apple fashion like they do the
the little things right right so make
sure that the interface is good enough
that the average person understands
what's going on and and that is the part
that Microsoft totally failed to do and
continues to fail to do right and that
inflection point happened mid 360. yeah
and that's when the funding went to we
got to go back to this like forget you
know Xbox that didn't happen to be an
issue right but window you know the
Windows CE to mobile that needs to
happen right we need to shift and so
money as you yeah I'm sure you saw right
they went and bought Nokia they spent
the money there they they started spend
the money here here and went over there
question red ring of death
the heartbreaking failure of your
favorite console because this is your
favorite right now did your baby die
inside your room so now for me at this
point I don't have a money restriction
so I put Xboxes in around
but we probably watch it we pocket
watches we have multiple
case of failure
[Music]
problems yeah so every TV had an Xbox
and it continues to have an Xbox and so
in case of failure the Swap and I can
play because even a guest TV has an Xbox
so I'm like
I guess it did happen to me but I don't
care because you know and Microsoft was
so awesome with their back end
again
yeah I need somebody to clip that it
died
next TV next TV
next Xbox bring it over log in and all
my stuff's back right yeah
right and friends that see the red ring
never happened to me personally
but my friend Joe did like the towel
trick like every week for like
he had to swaddle the baby yeah he did
that for like every week and eventually
he had a Bible because like I I never
had I remember one time my cousin and I
our friend Tyler he'll never forgive my
cousin but he had the issue and it was
at the time where the detachable hard
drive at the top yes my cousin his red
ring and he switched it with my friend
Tyler oh that's cool
it was like a decade before before my
cousin came clean I let him know he was
having a torturous tonight
so you just rocking the 360s okay okay
I also buy all the special editions
right so I got like the X the Star Wars
edition and like you know what a Halo
edition so I had plenty of the newer
ones yes so and those you know they
fixed all that so
it wasn't as big a deal I think I had
one or two that failed ultimately I just
it didn't really bother me that much it
was good so it was good so Flex yeah the
RO D it was a massive deal and
thankfully you know that was a Peter
more error and he went in yo I need to
have this we need to cover the moment
yeah
I did yeah
so he said he was like I thought I was
getting fired yeah yeah so now that we
got past one of the greatest times one
of the most Immaculate time one of the
most electrifier times in Xbox
even even in gaming I don't think
there'll ever be another generation like
the three people more put some respect
or more it's like just like how what I
mean it's not 100.
I'm talking about just the online
connectivity because that's when it
really took it to the next level you're
playing the old uh you know Call of Duty
who's playing the you know the Halo
games like like so Peter came up with
the online infrastructure Xbox Live yeah
you had to go through him but but when
it came to the blade no no you're right
you're right no you're right live
existed before him because that was oh
Jesus
shout out to Peter Moore we got this
conversation
I just stay with Xbox Live with
everything else you know I agree but
continue finished all right so getting
to the part where all right we already
established that this 360 is incredible
and one's most electrical Whoever has
ever lived it was incredible now let's
get to the dime and let's get to this
Xbox one all right let's get let's get
to TV TV TV hard geek you already know
away live you gotta Xbox every room you
was planning to put an Xbox One in every
room tell me what happened when that E3
press came through and TV TV TV and they
ripped the rug from under your legs what
happened
the opposite so this is an interesting
one right because in my world I'm like
this is great you're excited that you
have to choose like right now it's
either the TV has it or it doesn't have
the streaming apps and then every TV has
their own freaking interface right if I
go get Roku here or whatever there then
everybody has to learn new things and
with parents in the house it's like
technology is too difficult for them to
learn every time so I'm like you know
what this idea is fantastic yeah cable
runs through it all your streaming apps
are right there I can set them up with
the same bloody interface everywhere
well I got an Xbox in every room okay so
the Xbox one was resonating with me okay
it was not resonating with everybody
else the online thing where because look
I buy a lot of games but my friends and
my family maybe they don't buy as many
but they would like to play them and
they're like yo you own it they play it
right so the whole sharing the digital
future who is it on it he was like this
one this is the greatest thing ever so I
buy the game which I learned I love this
and suddenly my cousins can just play it
yo that's fantastic
what about connect how did that resonate
connect to not really I didn't think I
cared about the connect but when I used
it I liked it and the reason I liked it
was the voice commands yes okay telling
my TV to mute telling my the thing to
pause yeah just like simple things on
the phone no yeah Xbox One okay I can
just do this now right and that was very
convenient right and it was like the
progenitor to what we know you didn't
have any fears because you had it in
every room you didn't have any fears of
the Illuminati watches
I'm in it and that problem if you if you
worried about the Xbox you're you're
mistaken it's everything else your
bloody phone right is connected
permanently right and it has a camera
and a mic and it will pick up whatever
you want your your laptop like forget
you have a level that we wasn't
privilege too because you know yeah that
their XBox was watching you know what's
happening like even because I I saw a
video where someone took a took
identical phones put one on airplane
mode and put and took one completely
power to completely down and still knew
exactly where you were going yeah you
could do it's it's never off that's the
thing right anyway so
so yeah like for me it sort of Switched
as far as the games that's where I find
things have changed about mid 360
onwards games started to like the third
party stuff was still cooking right the
first party stuff was kind of stolen
yeah right and then we had a a bunch of
them come out of the Xbox One start
right um which was good they were pretty
good lineup yeah um and then you know
the PlayStation side again they didn't
seem to have as good a lineup it was
okay but it wasn't Xbox One launch was
definitely better so I like the launch
and the Xbox side better
um and then but but of course as usual I
chose that and then and all this time
remember the Wii right right
it was there and then the Wii U I had
that oh yeah all right and so so I
always have everyone right and then the
switch when that was available so
question is did you have a Wii U in
every room
yeah no they don't have that feature and
oddly enough I have more switches than I
did ever a Wii or so we did end up
getting a couple of whee's because
people like in the family just want to
play like the simple Esports stuff is oh
yeah it was so fun with catfish yeah
people would just play that like fine
cool whatever I'll do that uh the Wii U
know it was only one of them and then
the switch we have a couple of them just
because of like my sister likes to play
some movies which she has one right I
have one so whatever so
um but yeah so but the Xbox is yeah I
put them everywhere uh and and that time
I don't know why I just decided to be
extra magnanimous and I bought like 15
of them out of my friends and family as
well Xbox have an Xbox so like everybody
around me already had the Xbox
you see what's going on this sound like
Brett Dave talk I love I love how he
reacts late to this
it's not like a brain freeze
processing stop stop
I'm out all right so all you dudes is
out there talking numbers
so me I I go into that purchase like
five right I purchased five but I'm
purchasing myself
all right so um full disclosure I am a
capitalist
philanthropist here see the difference
capital is philanthropist he goes out he
purchases 15 friends and family you get
it yep um this is what I talk about when
you guys go and you purchase one and
you're yelling oh Sony so 20 million how
are you talking about you brought one go
sit down and go shut up
allowed a louder guy who went and
brought 15. could you know the
commission the dude that saw him come in
hoggy was like yo what's up this is God
you got let me get 15. you got that's
all you got in Stockton so you got well
we got two more let me get them back
hoggy goes to the back of the restaurant
the whole it's a different it's a
different talk yeah for sure geek to the
car
all right
he's the person that
old iPhone and he just goes to this
phrase I'll buy you they let him know
they message him to let him know when
things are coming ahead of time it's a
different energy y'all it gets a
different email yes they're available
yeah
um I just I just needed to take a moment
out
for you sir yeah yeah they respect your
greatness it was definitely great this
is that was the most bizarre thing that
I've heard I've been doing this right
Flex 10 Xbox is at least one of the
racers that was for you okay
have a happy holidays thank you for
being serious anyway continue
yeah I I loved everything that was
saying and then they pulled it all back
and they took away the the sharing and
all that God damn it you know and they
had that nice moment at uh E3 with
PlayStation this is how you share it I'm
like you missed a couple of steps guys
because if I'm in the same house I don't
need to ask you I'll just take the dance
it's the step where you gotta get in
your car and drive three states over and
then give the Disco and then come back
and pay for all the gas you missed a few
steps whereas digitally I could say uh
share that person yo Dunn and and you
got it yo have fun right now like they
missed a few but anyways it was a funny
little skit but I I took it other way
like let's screw off anyway
so Sony vitrios it's crazy and so I I
watched both of those back you know back
to back the back to back back to back
the Sony one versus the Xbox One and the
Xbox One excited me a lot more than the
Sony one did oh okay and so and
everybody else seemed to have the
opposite and I think a lot of it was
just cost and remember I don't care yeah
I bought 15 I don't care 100 bucks more
is not something
I don't care like the 100 difference did
not it didn't matter to me at all I
understand if others it's a thing but
it's like whatever I don't care this is
a different energy y'all so like I'm
looking at it and the ecosystem like all
the things they're giving me I'm like yo
this is great
and the other side's giving me here's
all the stuff that 360 did we finally
caught up here it is wow so that's how
you look that's nice oh so you're
looking at them they finally had Party
Chat and the thing and the right and
then they're finally doing that and
they're paid online right and then like
the cloud saves but you have to pay for
and like like these things that I'm just
like oh okay so you're catching up to
what 360 did that's nice but that's not
giving me new stuff the only thing they
had I think they have the share button
which to me again I didn't care so but
for those who like it that's fair that's
that's a nice feature Microsoft stole
that one from them but the rest of it it
was like we're copying the old gen 360
stuff and giving it to you and like oh
okay this doesn't add up to me I don't
what are you giving me this new all
right so don is trying to sync the ship
360 uh I mean uh the Xbox One is 400 a
little bit Sony is taking the climb up
how did you adapt to Sony taking the
climb up in a first party starting to
hit the God of Wars the Spider-Mans they
starting to take over it's starting to
get the Mind share Microsoft is starting
to lose traction all the great traction
that they did built in the 360 era is
Connie eroding Sony is getting a second
win The champ is getting up off the
floor he's fighting back how did you
look at that did you get a PlayStation 4
at this period of time or did you just
let them you know chill over there so I
got a PS4 I think like a year or two
after it came out and it was because it
was a trade-in deal okay like I trade in
one of my current consoles and it was a
very cheap upgrade to get to a PS4 I'm
like fine I'll just do that right and so
I ended up getting the PS4 then I knew I
was gonna get it eventually right it was
not like I was gonna play their games I
was gonna play their games So eventually
it was gonna get it wasn't a pre-order
or anything like that for me last of us
stuff like that was in the mix what was
it no Last of Us was way later right
this was Uncharted two okay one two in
that range maybe it was one
um so remember their their launch was
not that great right so that order 1886
which I bought finished
I wish I could just return it for you
but like yeah but I mean it was in okay
like graphically it was good but it
didn't really like it just didn't have a
midi campaign it just it is what it is I
wish they had like made that a little
longer but either way uh was it ah
Killzone yeah
Infamous I liked I think yeah yeah
um they have anything else in the launch
window I don't remember them having
anything else
yeah exactly it wasn't there wasn't much
there so and uh AC um Whatchamacallit AC
uh Black Flag yeah
that was everywhere right so I played
that on Xbox so right but that was one
of the ones that you know a resolution
gate right so what about what about the
fact that I was deployed with with on
Xbox oh okay that's about to say come on
it was with they they had the more
powerful Hardware yeah they used to
right and then well so here's the thing
even the 360 that's you know technically
on paper the PS3 was a lot more powerful
yeah it was just so hard to use that
nobody took advantage of it yes
and so like that power narrative never
really mattered to me but the the
headache you run into is they they
decided to use the connect they had a a
much underpowered box if they had said
you know instead of 1.3 T flops it was
two and a half tea blocks right hey
we're taking half of that to connect you
still got a little bit of overhead over
your competitor or it's very similar
that would have been okay right we
wouldn't have had this whole headache
but it was 1.3 versus 1.84 something
like that the the CPU is actually faster
on the Xbox versus the the PlayStation
but that Graphics just you just saw
obviously the resolution was you know
720p versus 900 or 900 pluses
and a lot of this by the way is
Community Driven right the average gamer
who plays a game could give a crap and
[Music]
it was the community like whatever it is
it's it's internet-based console war
stuff right yeah and so ultimately you
have the game can you play it cool it's
good you can play the game right uh but
for those who wanted to know oh but it
runs better over there now there are
some people who are like that is an
absolute must for me that's gonna be
like one percent of The Gaming Community
but fine they exist but to me I didn't
care respect no like we come back we
okay so you and I come from well you
didn't do genesis but I came from the
Genesis Super Nintendo I came from
buying multiple games I brought that
Street Fighter three times actually four
times I brought it for Super Nintendo
Genesis and turbo graphics and I had TVs
and I will put them all on and I would
do the moves and I would listen and you
know uh you know Cog will be there with
me and we will check do the check marks
uh which one did the fireball fast and
which one had the pixels did we would
compare we go screen by square yeah we
would we was doing
that the resolution didn't play a huge
fall apart in it yeah played a huge part
in this all right so don is out yeah
Phil Dominus Maximus well so one last
thing that Don gave us was the Call of
Duty contract right because they put the
money into Studios uh instead there's a
film studios right into the the you know
video part of it instead of into Call of
Duty which they should have done right
right they didn't do that and they let
that go to the PlayStation like they
were still doing fine until Call of Duty
became a PlayStation uh Associated thing
instead of an Xbox a cinematic gameplay
is is the Crux in in what holds Sony up
I mean you can't say that Don didn't go
after what so Tony was doing we Quantum
Quantum break was great probably one of
the best cinematic story driven games
that was released on in the Xbox One era
right yeah you agree all right so that
goes after directly after uh Sony but
also Sony had Sony Studios yeah and
didn't Don think greater to try to to to
to outdo Sony at Sony's game like let's
see we got our studios here yeah through
this TV stuff TV directly go at them and
Quantum break was uh one of the ones I
mean they had they had great actors in
every aspect of the game I mean I
thought the game was a really good game
the TV show was really good that was
integrated into it
um do you think that was a failure on
his part going after Sony's story driven
narrative base it's a failure of what
the allocation could have been so here's
the problem right so Microsoft invested
appropriately right they should have
done both right the games are necessary
you have to keep that going right and
then also add this and you it it as I
said it was Visionary for them to kind
of go in that path because that is where
things are look at right now how many of
the video games are going into movies
then the Don was ahead of his time
sometimes Microsoft innovates a little
too early and they're messaging
sometimes does it land correctly with
the bass and and it pushes all it
eventually goes there yeah but it's all
about them it's not just that though
it's like you you're a console uh you
know video game system right you have to
that part of it cannot be uh diminished
right so and that's what they did they
took the investment that was going into
games and said hey we're gonna take part
of that and put it over here you want to
do those things great that has to be
extra on top of what on top of what the
core is yeah if the gaming loses which
is what happened look they went down to
what four Studios that involved Mojang
that's not enough you're not going to
compete with establishment Nintendo that
puts out Banger after Banger year after
year
it is
bought it even if they were thinking
about closing down Xbox they're like
this is just a printing money machine
well I don't want to buy buy Mojang it
makes sense right or moyang I think is
how it's actually yeah but so all right
so you on the Don area Okay so let's
close off okay yeah
let's get to this last part and uh so
you on the donor
let's close out that part they allocated
funds that they should have put on Call
of Duty right this is what you're saying
and other exclusive games right so they
should have had those third-party Deals
they you know like I don't remember that
many coming out near the end of the Xbox
360. it was they didn't yeah and and
then the Xbox One you know Phil tried to
get a few things but like you need more
you just need to have a pipeline going
right and that is where I think they
failed they put money into the the movie
side of it which is cool so they had
remedy make uh Quantum break that was
one of their exclusives and that deal
was to expand on the on the movie side
of it right which the studio that they
had great but you know you need to do
the games as well and and losing Call of
Duty was just that's it all right
fumbling and Sony's getting greater what
is your position on Sony now
so as far as where Sony in-depth history
yeah I mean this isn't what he played
you want
me
to bend to be the sodium so he is not
about it you thought about what you
tried to do but I'm gonna let you get
hit
uh did a a great deal of soul searching
in the PS3 right you had to do that
right when they came out with these 600
or whatever it was console versus the
the 300 and 400 right that Microsoft's
had you you know you you have to look at
what happened there they got their their
you know butts handed to them especially
in the U.S market not in the world right
the rest of the the world it was still a
Sony Centric world but the US market it
was substantially 360 versus PS3 and
that matters right this Market drives
the culture of the you know yeah
absolutely pretty much what happens
everywhere uh so uh that happening to
them they have to say okay well we got
to come up with something better right
and uh they basically took whatever
Microsoft is saying and saying what did
not resonate let's make that our our
messaging and make that happen right so
the PS4 was going to do the same bloody
things it was going to be online all the
way oh yeah absolutely yeah me and kids
talk about that all the time right so
all that stuff was going to be there
they decided to pull back because they
saw the the backlash they're like yo we
don't want that backlash so wet first
yeah so we're gonna undo that and hey
they put their price at five we're gonna
make it four to remove the camera right
so fair enough I mean that's that's good
business right so they they did that
um but yeah so so with that they also
established during the PS3 era hey we
need to have games that are going to
bring people over right they have to fix
their house as well and so they did they
brought in a bunch of students they had
a whole bunch of of great games right
and that solidified them as a potential
for the next generation and people left
onto it because remember the beginning
of the generation was nothing was a
promise of games that were to come and
they did eventually come and they were
good games right so uh that just
expanded their thing the the uh Call of
Duty thing being there and the marketed
with PlayStation just helped accelerate
that right so uh the majority and you
know now that we have the ABK
acquisition stuff we have all the things
that came up from the court cases uh we
know that majority of the players are
doing stuff like Call of Duty and Apex
and you know they're not buying their
games they're saying that this is Sony
saying that right that they they need
that Call of Duty they need like those
kind of games that's what drives their
revenue for sure right and so like we
know what the majority of the players
are playing uh that that is what they're
they're buying their box for us play
those casual games
it's not a bad thing to have a catalog
of games that uh exemplify the the
great capability of your your system
right that's cool but I don't know if it
drives the actual sales I think people
just want to box to play games and
Nintendo because they got destroyed by
them they said well we're not competing
with with Sony and Sony says the same
thing we're not competing with Nintendo
right so if Nintendo does not want to
step up and say hey we're going to make
a console that will actually play all
the AAA games right so that the
viability for everybody to come to us is
there right and then there could be
contractual things that's fine right
people might get it whatever but there
is the potential but every game that
comes out on that Nintendo platform well
they aren't in that market and that's
where Sony is right and so Xbox is the
only foil to them but Xbox has been
faltering a lot right so uh that's kind
of where we are so Xbox hit themselves
more so than Sony did anything it was
more self-inflicted more Race So to me
it's more self-inflicted and then Sony
advantage of it and said why not we will
just go and take everything right so at
this point they're a wounded animal why
don't we just make it so impossible for
them to come and attack us okay that's
cool but there are some potential
headaches with that for them right if
you become too dominant that is also a
bad thing as far as the market yeah
right so and now they'll we'll see what
the fruits of that is now with this big
APK acquisition right as to whether the
one thing that I've been pointing out
and I don't know if anybody else would
agree or not but is that if they have
such a dominant position in Japan uh at
98 versus two of Xbox that makes it very
difficult for them to go make an
acquisition right because then they have
to say okay we are hurting in this area
you're at
98. why does it matter that's Japan
they're a Japanese company Sony is a
Japanese company anything they do has to
be approved in Japan right right so now
they have to go through the jftc to say
okay I need to go buy and people want to
say they're going to go by square
they're gonna go buy Capcom they're
gonna go okay they want to buy that how
can the jfcc say okay you need to expand
your 98 market share we should allow you
to do this that's impossible right
because they Define anything over 50 in
the market to be a monopoly right that's
the jftc guidelines right and that that
would have them say pause we're not
going to allow this until we understand
what's going on and I have to say like
it's very hard for me to understand a
scenario in which they have a case to
make against Xbox to say that you know
we should allow you to go buy a big
thing right I just don't see it but
again I'm I'm an outsider I'm not a
lawyer I'm not in the m a world that's
just my reading of the tea leaves so
this didn't matter before Why didn't it
matter none of the Regulators thought
Nintendo wasn't a part of the deal
it was Sony who said we don't compete
with them and they put that in the
freaking
so they don't now all The Regulators
have to agree okay so Nintendo doesn't
compete with you you're saying that okay
cool then if Xbox so this is where I am
so anyways as far as the market you know
I think Microsoft did a lot to hurt
themselves and then you know as far as
Sony they took full advantage of it and
why not that's that's what you're
supposed to do
and now it's funny now the like you know
Phil Dominus he decided to go into
soccer and say hey uh no we shouldn't
close Xbox we have something yeah
and he's on that Vision he's making
those things happen that's his greatness
and you can tell that the company is
behind them and I said this way early I
think it was the cult to somebody that
basically if you ever hear these words
we're all in on from Microsoft yeah yo
be careful pay attention pay attention
they are they are going to absolutely
and that when Adela said that that's
what I when I see a Satya parroting
Phil's comments is when I'm new and
that's the thing like I'm glad you said
that heartbeat because that's the thing
a lot of people don't want to give Phil
his flowers we talked about the Peter
Moore we get it but you made the key
point where it the chips were down we
don't know if they're committed to
gaming at this point at Xbox when we
talked about the studios we talk about
the movie Direction This Is The Dawn era
now he leaves Phil inherits a design
it's a disaster so for him to have his
sensibilities here right if we're gonna
be in this this is what we're going to
do then comes Game Pass and all that
stuff and that's a great point and now
we see the trajectory and the turnaround
that they're trying to you know they
spend what 85-ish right if you're not
trying to be in it absolutely they are
definitely in it right absolutely I do
not think they're stopping uh you know
they've outright said they're going to
acquire and so they they will keep doing
this and you know it's funny like so you
you're on um uh
right defining Duke and uh you know uh
Colin is uh
he's understanding but is annoyed with
this
to me and I think like to Colin I would
say look they are going to keep going
until you say I need Xbox because that
is their job they they want to make you
a customer right right and if you are
not a customer they haven't they haven't
done enough to make you a customer and
so they're going to keep going until you
say yeah I know it I needed my an Xbox I
need an Xbox in my life that's the way
right or I'm accessing the ecosystem
this way uh they are a player that I
need to to work with right or and so at
least that's how I see it and I think
you know Colin sees it more of like uh
you know this is going to push their
side to go buy things on Playstation
right that's his fear yeah consolidation
that's great that again if if more
people start coming to the platform then
they're good right that the ultimate
driver here is to be able to compete
enough in the market that they're a good
player right right now they are so dead
last that they need to keep doing these
things uh but anyway that's how I see
that you know but I think this is where
things are going to be interesting like
this oh it's going to get interested
already absolutely teetering but hey
this ABK thing could turn everything
around we don't know because we Supply
it comes to people wanting it if you
have an attractive offer of cod as as
you know like a Cod specific console and
you have cotton Game Pass you have
ultimate perks and stuff like that
there's just so much potential we got to
see what the effects we gotta move
forward because we went crazy we gave it
this was dope don't give me one this is
super dope I just moved to talk I was
like damn we gotta get topics I just
realized oh all right so look brother
tremendous history Jesus wow this was
great
um what I did one really quickly I did
have one more question for you in
reference to community and what kind of
what you're known for which is like you
really are in these Gaming Community
podcasts you really bring people
together you're in the Xbox Live party
chat you you're at the events you know
what I'm saying you're going what I see
doing that stuff it's just like kind of
what was the tip of point just to get
you into content creation now you're
doing podcast RDX I saw you initially
I'm seeing you moving so like what was
that transition to say hey I'm building
this gaming thing so long now I want to
actually you know put my voice out there
yeah it's uh you know I I got more in I
I would watch these things all the time
like a cultisto a thing or a dealer and
all these you know
um actually it got me a lot into it was
um crop gamer
eventually became a uh a Sony guy right
but
um he would put up videos all the time
it would just come into my uh you know
my uh YouTube feed and I was like oh
let's let's hear this and then add Jason
things would start coming up right
um and so then I started like you know
uh watching them live right so I never
did the live ones but then I started
watching them live and I'm like oh hey I
can I can Super Chat and then it just
kind of went from there and like
eventually I think I ended up
um it was uh Tim Dog needed to give away
a console and like dude I can I can
cover for you I got I got an Xbox series
X brand new if you need it uh so we took
care of that and then Colt and I sort of
hooked up at some point on uh Party Chat
and it just kind of went from there I
met Gaz that way hello
um and then Gaz had a a podcast going
where somebody wasn't there and they're
like yo if you need me in bud I can I
can yeah so that's the first time I saw
you I was like oh okay Huggies outside
so yeah so I went ahead and uh and
subbed in and uh and then Gaz just
wanted to like oh I gotta bring him into
into um fair enough so you went from
there and then
um you know I ended up on RDX and salads
well there's also boom um
podcast several times Prime Time gaming
and he's like hey why don't you just
become a permanent member
uh and then yeah then we you know soccer
um wanted to get like his own thing
going and with uh so shady and me and uh
yeah so we put that together so and and
that was had been going great but
zocker's got some like he just changed
his job and it's a lot more uh work and
so he's they have to go back on Prem and
he's like trying to figure out how he
can actually do it and it's very hard
for
now this is dope man and I love to see
you out there you know very informed
take very passionate in The Gaming
Community we got to ask the question
yeah I'm sorry please but one more piece
is uh as you guys right thank you oh my
gosh and I I gave you your flowers when
you had your your uh was it the um
[Music]
um so I'm like okay cool I have to give
you something so what I found was uh you
know I kept hearing from the community
about it and I look at your videos I'm
like four hours five uh are you kidding
me I can't spend that kind of time and I
want to say it was King it was on
somebody else's podcast and I'm like
okay I have to watch this he has that
effect on people it's like man so like I
have to watch and I watched one of your
older ones and I didn't even realize the
time just going by right I said that 300
episode I
don't realize the time goes by too but
right bro definitely does
[Laughter]
and I have been watching you guys a lot
unless there's some family thing I've
watched you live ever since wow it is so
entertaining it's so good and it's the
chemistry between you guys right you
like you know each you know how to
finish things for each other it's it's
great and then there's a lot of work
that goes into it and I think it's it's
it is well done and so it's just so much
fun right and so like so you guys along
with some of the other bigger ones are
are you know uh must watches but this
one I love ILP it's so good oh thank you
it is my Sunday oh please brother it
means a lot to us they hear people's you
know journey and I remember you I
remember you early days it is it's in
the chats and you'll say something to
push some buttons but you also say some
really informative stuff and we like he
corrected it on us oh he's right this is
what happened and we're like okay cool
and you just became this name in the
community we just started to see you
bubble so it's so dope to actually now
put the face to the name and then
obviously we built with you in real life
that was super dope brother it's always
fun you know doing anything we do
without seeing me you adding some games
Christmas bro so much fun and I like
that you're outside I want to give you
your flowers like you are about Gaming
Community like there's no question no
one can say your passion resonates
brother so we got to give you your
flowers now you know we do have to ask
you the question tradition that we ask
all those in the realm I need that top
five video games of French I'm expecting
a lot of Nintendo stuff I want to hear
what it's going to go yeah I mean it's
gonna be right so my top three are
pretty easy they're uh it's it's Mario
Zelda I think I'd say Zelda first Mario
and it's just a franchise because
there's just so many good ones okay and
then the third one is Halo because of
what it did it was like that Street
Fighter but it changed it for the Home
console right online and we are playing
oh it was so good so those are the top
three and then it becomes tougher
because I I don't want to miss one you
know things there's a aforementioned
Street Fighter but do I give it one of
those positions as a top franchise
probably not Mass Effect has to go in
there it's just so good I couldn't
believe when I played that Mass Effect
how engrossing it's just oh my God this
story it is so good and like the first
one still had some quirkiness the second
third just to fixed it it was oh my god
oh fixed it good yeah yeah it was so
good right um so like Mass Effect has to
be there and in that last spot I just I
have to give some love to the PC side so
I'm going to say king's quest
okay it's so good for me I it got me to
like it was that that made me want to
continue on the PC gaming side yeah that
got me moving along on the PC games I I
I still have to give them some love so
I'll say king's quest that is fine I
love that five murder Williams oh yeah
yeah and of course we he already
answered this early but favorite Coswell
of all time we we assume it's the 360.
oh it is it's pretty Golden Era but just
give them give them some more balls to
why yeah yeah so uh the 360 did what it
needed to do as far as power uh but also
online and it established a new mode for
gaming and on top of that it was just
the Arrow when when developers were
pumping games out and there was so many
great franchises it started up then or
were expanded Call of Duty became a
thing as part of the 360 era uh you know
you had the Assassin's Creed you had the
bioshocks
um right there's there's so many
different like you know you think about
uh Rockstar and like they put out GTA 4
RDR
GTA 5 on the same generation and since
then we've had you know rdr2 right like
we still haven't had the next GTA true
uh and they put out two in that
generation along with putting out Red
Dead Redemption right like again like
almost all the studios you just keep
looking at you like oh my God how many
things do they pump out right the one
that was disappointing was rare who had
opportunities to do a lot but they
started with Cameo and and perfect dark
zero I think right then they did like
Viva pinatas it's like okay these are
kind of cool but I was hoping for more
from them
um but outside of that it was just
killer like there's so many games and
and you just like you didn't have a time
to say oh I don't have something there
was always something new coming out yeah
um and like the establishing of a whole
bunch of franchises then I think
Watchdogs started in that generation oh
yeah absolutely yeah far Christ kind of
became a thing and right it just like so
many different things that just started
up in that Jen and you had so many of
them you know looking at the um the Tom
Clancy stuff one and two raw goldfish
Rainbow Six Vegas one and two that was
three glass Freight the best glass
breaking ever physics
terrorists oh good and like yeah it was
just split a sound every every one of
these Publishers was just like on fire
it was great
um so like that gen you know it also was
the time when when Xbox actually pushed
out some jrpg so he has a dragon and
Lost Odyssey and yeah you know things
like that that were coming along right
um so you know and we had Splinter Cell
uh I don't know if we had like Ninja
Gaiden was OG Xbox one yeah I don't
think they had one after that right but
um but either way so like there's all
these like you know things and then you
know the the 360 did bring in some back
compat it was kind of hokey but it was
okay it was it was something to let you
play uh but yeah I think it was just the
the breadth and depth of franchises that
just came up at that generation no you
know outside of that from like a uh me
getting into the gaming thing I think
the original Nintendo solidified that I
would want to be in this uh and then it
was the OG Xbox with that Halo oh my God
was that awesome but I have to give it
to the 360. it's just so crazy how many
things I played on that freaking
generation Indies when they did the
whole Xbox Live arcade Xbox Live arcade
whatever right like oh my god there were
so many good things it just kept going
and going such a great generation I wish
they had had continued right the you
could just tell they kind of pulled a
back of it on the exclusives but uh but
360 was just no doubt tremendous Choice
brother loved the history love the
journey hard work brother we need to
talk to you for hours you have a jury
that is truly remarkable and just give
you your flowers on your determination
as far as your schooling your background
your secular stuff and then still
operating the game and always get to see
you so I know you said let's go hang
around because I know it's the bad
thought today so um so if you want to uh
transition into Super chats or sure and
then I do have I just went before you
actually start I do want to give country
big the homie 94 he got the classic Hold
the Line T he said finally got the shirt
looking forward to wear this and holding
the line at the aew show at Wembley
Stadium on the 27th so he's gonna be
holding the Lion King he's gonna be out
there at Wembley Rapids a little country
big professional put this [__] is up so
I can retweet them and quote to you yeah
yeah put the hit us up on Twitter put
the pictures up when you get the shirt
you know what I'm saying we're gonna
hold you down country big though he do
the wrestling for real y'all
out there so sorry if you want to get
the uh super chats or yeah let's let me
know what you're doing and then we got
Gary the brown Gary D Brown five dollars
back in L.A it sucks I donate uh I
donate this to saving the Saharan Desert
tiger shark but I think in this case it
needs to go to the Bungie intervention
fund
then we have Lucius 95 with the 35 czars
love from South Africa as as a lurker
I'd like to express my appreciation for
what you guys do discovered you guys uh
like this and always listened after the
fact shout out always surprises me like
how much of a reach we realistically had
yeah it's awesome man then we have Lord
Metroid two dollars Super Chat you pass
the test hargit Nintendo first and Sega
alola
ban this man someone banned this man
there we go let's play with each other's
joysticks except five dollars Super Chat
I'm late but just know that that was a
fake account addict your spin is nice
but I only spin the block for saving his
Puerto Rican freaking
ah brother thank you for your support I
appreciate that much appreciated the
evolutions95 again with the 35s R Us
kind of envious of this uh gaming
history only started last year after
realizing the series s was affordable on
this side amazing that's awesome
and we Hollywood rules five dollars for
chat happy Sunday to my NYC and West
Virginia cousins after seeing them Sony
financials oh boy in my Palpatine voice
or the 66 operation ps6 app is in full
swing King
then we have Nick Kerr two dollars to
the chat love this show realm hit the
like button yes let's hit that like
button no doubt then we have Dr
Strangelove five dollars it's pretty
that which one Nick
Nick oh good luck oh wow wow yeah that
was crazy
wow didn't see that one but yeah
they got some they got some well I don't
know it just
I think we've seen this we'll see we'll
see
then we have Doctor Strange Love five
dollars what was that I love me some
Cognito but I'm craving something sugary
and king you are looking mighty sweet
let me take a bite out of that thick
long Snickers yo
[Music]
are you watching me
I press this are probably one of the
most paused moments
no I didn't hear any music
what's on your B button or the B button
let me see let me try
I just press this blinking that's all
it's doing blinking this he probably got
it's a setup it's the way it's got to be
set up yeah
damn it
there we have C dub 8 13 305 ten dollars
I remember renting TMNT on NES and it
was nothing like the arcade yes
I told my mom it didn't work and we took
it right back to Blockbuster I will say
the NES punch out was better than the
arcade in my opinion we've got two
different games yeah like a super punch
out and you have the arcade punch punch
out yeah okay with spikes were big it
had the green the green
the machine
you actually turned the punches over
yeah yeah so it really wasn't made for
that it was really made for like the
pachinko machines and a real large
for sure
then we got Grumble Grumble five dollars
got an OG Xbox day one do A3 or
Morrowind later revolutionized my gaming
life Halo was the first FPS I ever liked
I couldn't believe what Xbox did yeah
that was a moment man yeah a moment for
sure
we got four is a legend two dollar Super
Chat King I still got Mortal Kombat
Trilogy best MK yeah okay it was great
it was that was crazy yes then we have a
Halo Reach Around
boy that's Attic Fan Attic baby spin for
me and show me that star field and open
up that ball in his gate whoa you said
open up his balls his gate you go spin
the block on that one what is the show
become what is what are we doing we need
a podcast
since we got beefy Coggins
we had to play with your joystick before
me okay so listen we had to play with
your joystick and that was cool but then
all these people is the same person I
doubt it very seriously
uh hear ye hear ye Lords of the realm if
Microsoft gave y'all all 350 million to
spend however you wanted would you
rather make an insomniac level
acquisition and have a hundred million
remaining for Game Pass deals or pay the
2023 Mets game bro yo yo you disrespect
you disrespectful bro get out of here
yeah
we got the homie Astro pirate king
remember for four months Lord bronze all
the Lords are stuck in an island in
order to get off they must agree on the
best Xbox CEO who is it have a hit the
slurp type of day
you thought about the slave juice before
yeah I don't yeah I don't like when you
say that this little dominance Maximus
all day you know um from what he's doing
now see the other one's already capped
they're already capped so they're
already done we already see what they
did and Peter Moore definitely you know
listen to the heart and listening to
what Peter Moore was actually able to
accomplish in that period of time I mean
at the point of the matter right now
Peter Moore was probably the most let's
go but um Phil Dominus Maximus really
expenses a living legend
I would say my vote is
um Peter right now still but the only
what Phil is doing right now the
turnaround is so impressive from what it
started from yeah but like I said you
see the games and land I just need the
games to land away Peter's games landed
yeah and so it starts with the Starfield
the 2018 class of everything that he
brought in that's how I judge Phil so
once Phil lands these in these games I'm
gonna start with a high five Rush yeah I
mean I'm gonna go with publisher of the
year in 2021 no that's fine yeah
but you know redfall is a blood no I get
that or I would say like I said we'll
see how the generator because we're
still early in the generation but um
yeah once those games hit for me then
I'll get Phil
I have a feeling Phil hasn't even
started yet for sure no I mean look what
he's doing as far as a turnaround and
the hands he was dealt was is impressive
so yeah Phil deftly he's right there
like I'm just letting it play out that's
all I've just letting it yeah yeah I
think but yeah and it's far
as a platform Peter did more because he
actually had like Bioshock yeah you know
uh I think the original Dragon Age was I
can't remember like he BioWare games in
general well I think he did better on
like an eye for talent than I for games
uh but I do think Phil has set himself
up
the most important thing when it comes
to a gaming console is the game it's
definitely
been ups and downs when it comes to that
particular part endearing his right
really quick I'm just curious what hoggy
who he has
um so
um
I I like the Peter Moore era but it was
only a few years and he did do a lot in
that time okay uh but I and it also was
in the ascent of where you know
Microsoft was still spending right so
true you know he had the the wallet
available to him and so he spent that
wallet I think Phil had to dig out of as
you said it was a mess it was a mess it
was a bad situation a disaster right and
he had to dig out of that convince the
company not to kill Xbox and bring it
back from the desk to where it is now
and you know yes it's not where it
should be but it is way better than
where but at the same time Peter Moore
had a deal with the red ring of death
and that's one of the which is like the
worst dominant and a dominant
PlayStation
well
it wasn't dominant when Rog came out
though by that time Microsoft had kind
of solidified themselves yeah it was a
year early it was a year early correct
right so yeah so they were a year early
I already started like what was it like
a year and a half in something like that
it started to become an issue right so
they extended the warranty for three
years or whatever it was right but
that's a warranty issue and it's a
simple one when your CEO says here's an
open bag go ahead and just do it but he
I got to push back it was the Tylenol
moment because if if he can't convince
them to spend all that money to correct
this issue he could have been on there
and we're talking about like but we're
talking about convincing someone
that sure Engineers cost
they were scared Obama terrified but I
understand what you say honey
Microsoft isn't like they're not immune
to having bugs and problems in their
products so they're used to the fact
that they have to fix stuff and I'm just
I'm pointing out realities
so this wasn't out of the realm of Norm
for them so to to handle it they had
they're a big company they had to take I
do feel like the red ring of death is
not just a problem though it was it was
a PR nightmare yes absolutely handled it
the right way I said we will just cover
it like whatever just tell us you had it
cover it we will we will revisit though
who did that but I think Phil has done
so much more to bring a company a brand
that was dying out of that into a brand
that was at least at the start of the
series s and X generation was the most
Buzz there was right it was it's the one
with the most enthusiasm going forward
and now they've kind of killed that a
bit and coven might have done some of
that whatever it is but uh they've had a
few bad things happen stupid things
happen right but going into this
generation you can't say that the Xbox
didn't bring the energy and that's got
to be on Phil Right to say we're going
to turn it all around here's how we're
gonna do it the community like they
finally they come to the computer they
come to these things
shut up talk to us right so
we got the votes okay I'm gonna be the
contrarian here because y'all y'all seem
to forget y'all history right
there is no Xbox without Robbie Buck
there is an oh geez
these are these are the dudes that had
to walk into the room fact and convince
team direct back Bill Gates yes let's
get them new flowers this food's a good
idea good point back then and back then
you got to understand it the rule the
rule was with an iron fist fact this is
what we are we're you're convincing
these guys that getting into this space
is the right thing to do they should
spend money yeah and and and then the
thing they came up with was so
revolutionary for the space
that and the fact that it the machine
came out and it did everything that it
professed it was going to do it did
everything a professor was gonna do the
Box hard drive soundtracks they did a
lot of stuff everything everything at
the time was crazy just wasn't on
Windows and it wasn't that that was the
only thing and it went Bill and he had
to get over it because he could have
nixed it right there to wait a minute
hold up and he could have given a
project to the other team that just
wanted to make an iterative thing right
and
so without these guys sort of advocating
for this level of change in fact it
would not have happened so I I love I
love Phil Spencer I love
um Peter Moore what they did with the
brand and taking it right and I think in
the long term I think Peter Moore had
his moment where he was the perfect
person at the perfect time because the
showman was given the keys to the
kingdom and said show and he did and he
went out there and showed he did
everything that is in his nature to do
as a marketing guy and made Xbox that
thing and he saved it when it needed to
be saved and then now Phil came in and
Phil's story has not been written yet
right completely written yet and I do
think that if Phil manages in the long
term to accomplish what it to to
reinvigorate the Japanese base and bring
that back into the fold and then to
continue and then to continue to be uh
like you said Cog we need those games
and we need those games to hit with
regularity facts if that happens in the
long term when this story is done at
Xbox and you know he's a life person
maybe he's there for life or who we
don't know
um I think I think it's a very
compelling argument to make that is him
but but to start you gotta because again
Xbox had no business jumping into the
space Sheamus Blackley the whole let's
get this yeah so that's it I'm done okay
cool oh let me see
okay that question no more questions in
super chess thank you
THX 1138 two dollars to attack Colin
will die on that PlayStation Hill
hashtag mega fat I don't know what Colin
is said why is he catching Strays people
are trying to get him all this this is
Colin we're talking about me alone
then we have THX 1138 a Sunday without
IOP is not a Sunday hashtag goat thank
you sir appreciate thank you much love
much love then we have Mexican Zoidberg
member for 30 months Lord bronze now we
know why heart Geet is always gifting
codes this man is bawling
then let's put the crust in the chat but
rambling entertainment welcome to the
realm Lord bronze appreciate you
rambling into entertain that's right
entertainment entertained rambling
entertainment all right salute then we
have let's play with each other's
joysticks five dollar Super Chat just
remember who started the movement the
difference is my love and lust for Sam
is real and pure unlike these ponies
for the flag down you then we have S
Cruz Aida thank you thank you for your
support
Cruise Eight dollar Super Chat yeah Xbox
lost last gen but PlayStation didn't win
it correctly heart keep mouth opened
honestly whoa
visuals sir visuals
uh would switch to rumor to be launching
in 2023 which aspects of the console has
you most concerned the winner of the
four-way IOP poll at 63 of the vote was
no backwit compatibility group so that's
the highest concern coming in at second
place that 16 of the vote was I don't
quit kid switch two will hold back this
generation if it's less powerful than
the series
coming in at third place is the 12 of
the vote was the LCD rumors over the old
over no olev and in last place at seven
seven percent of the vote which I'm very
disappointed Nintendo Party Chat and
messaging group that seems to be the
least of people's concern
crying inside uh yeah uh attic people
are concerned about backup pack bro
I don't
I I don't know what to tell you guys but
yeah I I feel I feel them but yeah I
feel like at the end of the day it's
just it just depends on what you want
from the system
uh and it is what it is at that point
yeah that's all I really got to say
about that no doubt are we going to take
care of business
yeah yeah let's do action before
business real quick how to get your knee
remember for 25 months Lord gold we got
a bunch of codes in the chat thank you
hargit appreciate that brother we got
stray Remnant two we have Atlas Fallen
Shout Out target always coming out
showing out for the community if you get
this cold give a big thanks to Heart
Geet and then shout out y'all come on
and then we have a new member in the
realm Lord bronze Huffy Bears
shout out to healthy bear and we are
done let's pay the bills oh okay Mike's
muted
Mike muted
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big Wireless
providers if you learned anything it's
the there's always a catch so when the
first hand so when I first heard of mint
mobile offers premium Wireless search
starting at 15 bucks a month I thought
what's the catch be honest with you I'm
like for real
but after talking to him and using their
service it all made sense there's
there's one there isn't one mint mobile
secret source is that they're the first
company to sell wireless service online
only they cut the cost by the retail
stores by passing it on to your sweet
savings
to the customers
all right so when I got the mint mobile
uh my son needed the the phone right so
I got them for the summertime and he
goes to the store you know he wants to
be out and about and I'm like how can I
keep contact with him without you know
um being overprotective so mint mobile
allow me the opportunity to do so so I
you know got the phone
uh got the the the the the SIM card and
everything in the mail put it in and
you're expecting it to be you know some
weird charges to pop up someplace but it
didn't you know he actually was you know
out in the service is incredible I'm
like where you at he's like oh I'm at
the park or you're at the store and he
calls me uh Daddy they don't have this
uh I have I want to get this and I'm
like wow this thing sounds really clear
it sounds better than the service that
I'm using I'm thinking about switching
over to be honest with you
um to just join him in his mint mobile
uh Journey so mint Mobile's definitely
gave uh me the peace of mind when he's
outside that I don't think that he's
gonna drop calls or it's going to have a
problem with connectivity or service so
it's definitely something that works for
me and works for him to get your new
Wireless plans for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com iron Lords
that's mintmobile.com
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com iron Lords no
doubt don't get the clam get the call
yeah don't don't get no clue
clamps in there you ain't gonna get it
yeah they just it's funny man I see you
know I see Ryan Reynolds on doing his
commercials and stuff like that like he
really like he out there because
you know he just recently I cut it in
half didn't he like from 30 it was like
15 so like he really trying to get
people on this man I gotta give it to
him you know what I mean he bought this
this this uh
this company and kind of just said you
know what let me let's see what happens
if we don't you know take people to the
bank every single day with with these
services so I I I like the fact that
these options are out there and the
quality of the options are are just
increasing right like the quality of the
of the phone call you're going to make
or the internet access is all par with
what you you know people just used to
having this safe oh I just paid my
monthly thing to T-Mobile wherever
whatever but this is different right
this is just like you go in and you're a
little scared at first but then you go
in and like this is the same oh my God
my pockets thank you so much
I just really it's it's just so clear I
like the quality of it the quality is
nuts so it is what it is to be honest
with you I have my trepidations with it
I thought it wouldn't really work it
actually really works so yes
welcome to the first topic y'all um yeah
yeah three hours it's a fantastic timing
so look um I will set this up this is me
we kind of um jumped this kind of
developed organically this week just so
much craziness going on so uh ball just
gate let's uh shout out good friend to
the realm uh Destin legarre seems like
he had an editorial out in reference to
Bald is Gate 3 causing some developers
to panic and uh so buckle up this is a
little long setup there's a lot of
moving parts to it um so it looks like
uh in this editorial by an IGN that uh
destined Lord Destin had you know well
Boulders grade three is being widely
celebrated by fans developers alike but
some are panicking that this could set
new expectations from fan and his
opinion good he said why fans feel this
way and while they're celebrating games
like Baldur's Gate 3 and Elder Ring The
baldus Gate 3 reaction has stirred up a
pit of controversy that is worried that
has some worry that Baldur's Gate 3's
gameplay will cause a raised standard
from fans the Baldur's Gate 3
controversy is because Larry Studios has
created something that others are
worried will be compared to their games
The Boulders Gate 3 developer reaction
wasn't all bad with some pointing out
that it should get them to look closely
at their practices but many also
defended the status quo so there's a lot
here that that's the first part and he
was going off of um I believe I forget
the gentleman's name I'm gonna butchered
it
Xavier Nelson Jr who's um also Devil
he's also um he had initial comments
that Destin really reacted to and then I
want to shout out another good friend to
the realm from uh respawn
um Tyler Owens he had a response kind of
to the editorial that um from a
developer perspective perspective that
Destin had so he basically said says
again with Baldur's Gate 3. I don't know
a single Game Dev who has actually
conveyed this sentiment about baldus
gate 3. instead I've heard devs ask
folks not to use the great things
achieved by this team as a weapon to use
against other devs which is exactly
what's being done he continues devs are
absolutely looking at this game to
analyze and learn from his success it's
a great example of what consumers want
and more something that we should
celebrate it should not Stoke anger
motivate harassment or make you upset at
other developers I've seen content
suggesting that it should make people
angry and this is why devs are talking
about it we all strive for excellence
but few of us will ever achieve it in
demanding every game provides once in a
generation Innovation is just Insanity
framing this as devs panicking Baldur's
Gate 3 will somehow stop us from our
real goal of extracting all capital from
Gamers is just disconnected from reality
anyone saying this knows nothing about
the people making games can we stop
pretending like the people who may make
games are the ones who play right talk
about them are adversaries let alone
people he goes a little personally I'm
going to skip the other part on top of
that most of us don't make very good
money many devs living below the poverty
line where they live why in the actual f
with we be against consumer friendly
practices in the game industry now the
last statement I want to get in defense
to Destin responded to to Tyler here and
then Destin's point was the idea that I
brought up the topic to use it as a
weapon against devs is gross Xavier said
that a 200 200 200 million dollar risk
could take an entire wave of Studios
with it that should make devs and Gamers
mad the bosses of company placing those
200 million bets are posting billions in
profits maybe Panic is not the right
word but what is it then to see the
industry rally behind not having raised
standards is bizarre and I'm responding
to a conversation started by develop
numbers to explain why it comes off the
way it does to many others it is
absolutely not to create a weaponized
attack it's simply to talk about the
topic Broach customers are feeling
frustrated by business practices
implemented that you probably don't even
like the original thread reads like we
should get used to baldi's Gate 3 like
games as it will probably never happen
again and we should probably get used to
the status quo we should be on the same
page and probably are in some respects
but the thread I reference seems like
anyone shouldn't I mean it feels like we
shouldn't even hope for something better
for everyone that's frustrating to your
company customers because we want
developers to feel like they can succeed
instead this topic is labeled as a
weapon and completely shuts down what
people are trying to say that we wish we
lived in a world where things could be
better for gamers and developers so this
is the hottest Topic in these Twitter
streets actually excuse me and it's
going back and forth so just want to
bring this to the realm this is you know
one of the hottest ones to start with
Harge Our Guest um where do you land on
this this whole situation
so it is interesting that you know
there's Potential pushback from
developers it
it does mean that maybe there are issues
with the current development cycle I get
that uh you know but look larion did
what they needed to make a game that's
uh that's just working well and to to
then say you shouldn't expect to meet
that level uh that's not exactly the
right message like it you know and when
somebody comes up with something that's
good you should then say okay that's
what I need to match up to that's an
open market right so uh when somebody
comes up with something that's
revolutionary you then say okay well
that's the market now I gotta pivot to
that uh and I don't see this as
revolutionary I mean like we used to get
this all the time if you bought a game
for you know the the Super Nintendo did
you expect it would be half broken and
then you would get patches no because
there was no way to get patches you
basically just had the game so if bloody
had to work it's just the way it was and
like that's what they're delivering
they're delivering a game that like has
it all the game there's no
microtransactions there's no DLC or
whatever maybe they were but there's
nothing they're asking for there's like
the game is done here it is and it's
just working now there there are bugs
they're finding that patching those in
but what I guess they're you know the
developers are are or the other
developers are uh hinting at is like
look the level that they've gone to they
sort of branched away from normal thing
they had a two-year
uh consumer-led uh development cycle
right because of Early Access okay
that's cool uh there's nothing stopping
anybody else from doing that too you
could do that in a private beta of some
sort you could you could find that out
uh and find out what the community
thinks uh so that's a possibility but uh
I think the the current standard we're
seeing unfortunately is most games come
out unpolished they're being required to
be somewhat live and that there's
microtransactions of some sort there's
you know battle passes or uh you know
expected DLC drops where you can buy the
ultimate edition that has those with it
right whereas this is just foregoing all
that right and uh I don't know that it's
a uh you know that there wouldn't be a
backlash for something like this but uh
they do need to recognize if they're
gonna say these kind of things right the
expectation from the the purchaser the
you know the consumer is that you are
going to release a game that is not up
to par because this is now the the
standard right right it's the same thing
as breath of the wild coming out and
then you say okay well the next game
that comes along that has anything like
this I expect you to be like breath of
the wild right and so is that a bad
thing no because that's the way it is
right they came up with the game that's
how it comes in that and what you
ultimately will always be compared to
right yeah exactly there's so many that
have been compared to that and you're
like well but that's the way it is right
that that's the world that you live in
now right you can't just say well okay
you know I'm making a new product in an
area that has a whole bunch of
competitors and somebody else came up
with something better than me therefore
I need to complain well no you need to
match what they did right that's just
the way it goes and you know in in this
same industry it's a lot of players and
somebody out of nowhere can come up with
something cool and that's the way it is
right so like Halo infinite would they
have been happier if there weren't other
games that pull people away I mean
that's just the way it is though there
are games that pull people away and
those games resonated more and they took
the community to the to that right like
Halo started with like this massive Buzz
right when it came out in in 2021 but it
fell off because of their own failures
right and that's like that's just the
way it is you have to to compete and you
know if Apex is coming up with more
stuff or fortnite is coming well hey
guess what they're going to take your
market share
right and you just have to you have to
deal with it that's the world
um so I hear what they're saying as far
as these other developers that don't
expect but like look you you now need to
live in the world where this came out
right and so you have to you have to
react right so yeah you know if if
Microsoft didn't have to compete with
PlayStation's you know games they would
be in a different position right because
we would never see it hey but wait a
minute that game over there is so much
better why didn't you do that right well
that's the way it is right so it's not
like it's a hashtag just one was created
for that it literally
no it doesn't matter it is what it is
that's that's the market right you have
to compete into the market and if the
market is here that's that's where you
are if somebody shifts it there that's
where you are you have to contend with
that and larian did a good job they put
out a great game uh and they're
staggering it to make sure it's quality
wherever they put it fair enough that's
the way it is right and that's how you
let's say now you have to say Okay well
that's what you need to meet as well uh
now will that happen I don't know I you
know in most cases Publishers uh you
know even the big Publishers like
Microsoft and Sony and whatnot have like
deadlines of when they need to kind of
put things out right they have Windows
now you know some of them are more
relaxed sometimes Microsoft is like hey
you know what you need an extra year
yeah
right fair enough right but that doesn't
always happen and not everyone is
afforded that yeah exactly and so this
is the world I get that but there's
pushback and then that you know these
things happen and EA mates may say like
I I need to put a game out this this
fall I don't care if you're like fiscal
quarters coming up we got we got get it
out right yep and and so that that's
unfortunately the world we're living in
uh so I get some of that from that side
but to be fair the market puts what the
market puts out right and you have to
deal with whatever happens and now this
is the top rated game of the year
you're just gonna have to contend with
it right yeah it is what it is it is
what it is well said brother let's get
at it because I know it's time is
limited I got to get them in um this is
big for you because I know addict you
know you really go hard for Boulder's
Gate three you know you've been playing
these games you got me to pick it up
when I thought I was going to try to
stand strong and wait you know that's it
and I've been loving it too so where you
at with this I know this these type of
games are near and dear to you and we're
Lodges of turn base and to see Boulders
gate shining the way it's shining them
the engagement the Metacritic everything
is cooking so where you at with this
whole you know what side are you on as
far as you know with the devs push it
back at that's the investing statements
and this whole thing
Dustin's 100 right when it comes to this
look you know I find it hilarious that
you know developers and Publishers want
to push back at Dustin they said well
this this can't be the standard well
what's the standard let's define the
standard
almost every other game if not every
game just about is broken doesn't work
bad performing games and the ones that
do work they're flooded with
microtransactions they care more about
you buying extra stuff than the actual
core gameplay that's going on we're
looking at Destiny
Bungie has a hard time keeping up with
demand that is wanted they can't come
out with armor but guess what they can't
come out with whatever verse 15
everversed armors that's in there
constantly being shifted make one more
regular suit for you we won't be able to
give you an exotic missions
technically I I guarantee you you know
and I can never prove this but
it's like one of those things it's like
they're working on okay does this look
good it's just the free armor we want
them to buy the new stuff anyway it's
like look I'm getting so this is our
fault let's be real here we have the
ability so much
we'll fix it when it comes through we'll
play it when it comes to we'll watch it
without the features I don't mind day
one patches I mine day three pack day
three week patches that should have
fixed the game three weeks ago that's
what I'm on you know love Jedi Survivor
unacceptable and high launched love
Diablo uh Diablo 4 well actually I ain't
really love that game but it is what it
is they they chose to take the game in
the direction that it went because they
wanted to encourage you to get into
their seasonal past they want to
encourage you to buy stuff to help you
with that seasonal patch instead of the
core gameplay of stuff people are gonna
play
it's like I said when it comes to the
broken games how often do we buy a game
it's gotten to the point where people
well I'm away just to see if it
functions we are consumers waiting to
see if a game could function before we
purchase again
well and then when it comes to like does
this game
should this game Elevate standards I
think us as consumers demand games to be
elevated what worked 10 years ago don't
work today well work today ain't gonna
work 10 years from now it's naturally
going to elevate and until the industry
gives me more
fixable and games that function on day
one
then games that are broken you have no
right to tell me what I can and cannot
feel should be the standard of the
industry because until I could go out
there on any store and buy any game and
it functions correctly that is when you
could tell me what the standard should
be the standard should be a game just
functions and we don't get that half the
time the status should be if I pick up a
60 game I'm not nickel and dying for the
rest of the game so when it comes to
micro transactions that's what the
standard should be
so you don't consider bald is gay
because a lot of some of the devs will
push it back and say like this is an
outlier like this is you know uh larion
had you know all this time and you know
like that
you know I'm not trying to say big
excuses but it's just like you know they
they're saying like this is kind of rare
so to speak that this doesn't happen so
your thing is well this is like kind of
what you're mirror what hargeek saying
like like this is the new standard I'm
sorry but like this is this is a new
stand because we let it be the new
standard okay what a game this can be a
standard look every game look
obviously you take a game like Boulders
gate three you know in its function in
its genre it is the high standard
games like this raise that whole genre
standard higher and make the rest catch
up and I'm sorry I'm not gonna tell
Dustin that that shouldn't be what we
want we should Thrive for that
and look there is there is scenarios
this is more on the publisher than
developer side most devs are pushed to
put stuff in games they don't want to
we've seen it with you know bait way
back in the day with Dead Space Three
they even want that game EA pushed that
game on them so a lot of this issue is
just whether or not you know uh the
people who make Boulder's Gate 3 have a
hundred percent transparency on what
they want in their game and what they
don't want in their game right it's one
of the reasons Bungie and Activision
split because Activision wanted
something bungee you wanted something
that didn't it didn't it didn't meet on
equal grounds so it it was easier to
split that relationship up it's just
like I just get I get so sick and tired
of just seeing games broken and it's
just like at this point people are like
well you know they'll use well holders
Gate 3 was in Early Access for three
years okay that's not an issue maybe
that should be the standard
you know maybe we should see more games
than Early Access for three years if we
get a product like this at the end of
looking at the result and then people
are sitting there attacking them because
they have a bunch of people there is
countless Studios with double to Triple
their size delivering subpar content
compared to what Boulders Gate 3 has
there's no excuse like you're like whoa
you know there's indie devs I don't
think Dustin's talking about Indie Debs
Justin is talking about the AAA
structure and how nickling diming us and
broken games have been and how something
like voters K comes out does none of
that and it's selling three four million
in the first couple weeks
because guess what Boulder's Gate did
the did the oldest oldest trick in the
book when it comes to Selling Stuff Word
of Mouth we're going to give you a solid
product and you're gonna sell our game
we ain't doing it yeah there was no
marketing Blitz there wasn't no yeah
this game is off the strength of the
word of mouth High Praise review no well
said I hear we couldn't it's like you
know I get the Boulder's Gate three
and all sense of tech it should be an
outline but my thing
is we're not we're talking a a way big
difference thing well it's like I said
the biggest issue in the industry right
now is every other game is broke and I'm
not even putting a lot of that issue on
on the developers there's a lot of the
Publishers they want to meet these
quotas for these investors they want
this they want this quarter being higher
like all this there's way more layers to
this one of the reasons that Boulder's
great three does and I'm not saying it
because I got butchered how I pronounced
their name
the biggest reason they're able to
succeed in the way they did is because
they have very few people to answer to a
lot of other people and devs in the
industry they don't have that gift and
unfortunately maybe we need to let more
of these you know examples happen I
think that's one of the things that like
I give Microsoft a lot of props with
they're like look make the game you want
to make this is the kind of game that
Microsoft would have let them make now
I've had acquisition by Microsoft's
actually has some positive results wow
yeah you you give this same tools in the
same Studio to someone like maybe an EA
or Ubisoft or an Activision it's hard to
tell how it would have came out the
other end
they look at the overall perspective
yeah I feel like you know these these
armors look hard well it's the end game
armors the armor that you really grind
for can we can we charge for that
you're funny let me get some look like
I'm worried so I'm fixing his face I
don't know where he going with this
suburbs see what's up is going so
there's a lot of controversy the devs
are pushing back you know and and
obviously the gamers and Dustin feels a
certain way where do you sit on this
whole baldus gate three it doesn't you
notice that the rising vote what's that
what's the analogy yeah Rising tide
lifts what are we doing what are we
doing
um I was laughing because it's like if
you let addict go on long enough he's oh
he's gonna get my he's gonna he's gonna
save my point
okay always happens so it's but it goes
back to this idea for me that it's it's
full the philosophy behind this idea
that no we we can't achieve this certain
thing behind the reality of the business
realities of why it can't happen right
and I just feel like those things are
the argument is is sort of happening
head to head but they're kind of arguing
with apples and oranges real quick I
forgot to say this
Baldur's Gate and I am not a butchering
their name this studio made a game this
popular that's a turn-based RPG that's
all I gotta say like could do yeah it
and it's quality right and I think we
discussed this briefly last night but
for me looking at it when you compare
some of the comments that some of these
devs were making they're coming out of
spaces where they don't have the luxury
of this early access that that Baldur's
Gate had Baldur's Gate they started work
on this game
after divinity 2. and then Midway
through development they said hey we're
going to put it into Early Access you
can buy what's there now
and support and continue to support as
we continue development right same thing
happened to a lesser extent with Hades
look at the quality of that game at the
end of its of its development cycle so
I'm not saying whether that's right or
wrong I know king is not about being
debated boy I understand not available
could have been like if we look at it
from then if we look at grounded right
do you think grounded would have been
obviously grounded is coming out of the
Microsoft camp right the bag is a little
ground it did have an early access and
it came out very polished people were
very impressed with obsidious
wouldn't have got that heat right out
the gate if it was right yeah the
millions of people disagree with you but
that was years of building that quality
like the game is still viable regardless
oh no no no but he's talking about when
it first came out that he did got one at
first dropped it whatever bad vibes it
had it didn't affect it at all well it
continued to improve though it didn't
continue you can't say that it's staying
trash and then people kept loving it and
that's exactly what it's supposed to do
if it's a game of service what happens
on a game of service it builds you know
and if you're going by what people are
saying like bringing up severe thieves I
think that was the worst thing that you
could ever do a million you know because
the fact of the matter is sea of Thieves
is probably one of the most played games
period on the platform so I think you
know should stick to Boulder gate
anyways I already know where he going
continue so again so when the arguments
come out that no we shouldn't strive for
this is that any other in some ways
you're comparing apples to oranges
because a lot of these other devs don't
live in that world where their game
could come out and be like yeah we want
to put this in Early Access and have the
community pay for it's not not the case
they're beholden to what your publisher
deadlines internal deadlines and at the
end of the day we've talked about this
in the past the fact that that that the
financial aspect of game making is so
intrinsically tied to the product it's
not removed from it it affects the end
result of the product so over the past
decade we've gotten used to the fact
that hey a patch is going to fix this a
couple of patches are going to fix this
oh this is gun don't worry about it
it'll be fine a couple of months down
the road that is just the nature of
normal game development now when you
when you deviate from that right you get
things like like like a Hades like uh
about this gate three that isn't the
norm that isn't going to continue to
happen right and I think when some of
these Devils talk about we you should
not you should you shouldn't ask us to
to Aspire to that
that is not being considered in the
conversation that's part of it right now
if the any of these depths it's weird
for me to even think that that the dev
is saying nah we can't do that don't
like it's really hard for me for a
creative person whose life is built on
building these things from the ground up
from nothing mind you game development
as much as all of these devs are
professionals they've been doing this
for the for a very very long time if you
ask any Dev when you build a game from
the ground up even if you may even if
it's the third game in the series it's
like building the Wheel from the from
the beginning you're like now the world
doesn't exist we got to rebuild the
wheel it is literally starting from the
beginning so you have to intrinsically
be a person that loves that level of
Discovery and and pushing yourself to
see what more you can do so for a WWE
like now we can't do that it almost
feels like Stockholm syndrome a little
bit where they some of these comments
feel like they're defending Publishers
like they defend like like they're so
entrenched in this idea that their ideas
get to a certain point and the money's
gonna stop or the deadline like it
almost feels like that is that is the
nature of what they've been doing they
don't see anything different they're not
part of an indie dad they're not part of
this and all of a sudden it's like it's
weird because it felt like they're
developing the power they're defending
the powers that be and I'm like wait a
minute that's very weird fairness In
fairness a little bit because I know you
go but Tyler's thing is saying that hey
like you he they want what you guys want
it's not that they don't want it like he
again he's saying I've seen content
suggest that it should make people's
angry he said we're all striving for
excellence but few of us will ever
achieve it and demanding every game
provides once in a generation Innovation
is insanity so he he says not that he
doesn't want it but he's just saying
like the reality of it happening is
where the disconnect he has with right
and the reality of it comes from the
realities of the business right I call
Capital the majority of these AAA
Studios that have these type of funding
that this studio went with voters Gate 3
they fell from a variety of variables it
had nothing to do with with the quality
of the studio that nothing to do with
the talent could have been magic it
could have been a variety of all this
stuff that the majority of them can make
these type of games they're just because
of you know like I said publishing
Outreach because of bad management that
is what's resulting in these things that
seems to be the key thing
key thing yeah that is the key thing but
that that is to attic's point we've been
supporting this right yeah and there we
go let's get to it let's get to it now
exactly let's get to it all creating the
conditions and it goes again it's not
it's one of the things that's very
circular right yeah because as as
consoles compressed power progresses bad
behavior we reward bad behavior because
the bad behavior begets in a lot of ways
begets the the hot new game with the new
tech launch it without great feature
launch it without the phrase
and it's just this it's this right it's
this one of our topics is something
we're about to be disappointed in as far
as sports right so it's like it it is it
isn't a problem that is intrinsic to the
industry and how it's functioned now for
a pretty long time right and it's not
gonna that's the thing it's not gonna
stop because we keep it and it's never
gonna happen because if you think about
the scenario that causes this to happen
is everybody just stops buying and
[Music]
when it comes to this argument I get it
on uh but it is talking at the end of
the day when the next thing if Starfield
comes out yep and it and it doesn't
reach that level of quality
or whatever
they're not gonna hold that oh the
Baldur's Gate did this no they're not
nobody's gonna do that at the end it's
not gonna happen right and it and it
wouldn't be fair to do that to Starfield
because circle is a different thing a
different entity you at the end of the
day when you finish playing both of
those games you could say I like this
one more than that one right
but it wouldn't be fair to make that
comparison either so again people are
outraged once again for something that
is going to blow in the wind and and be
done with
um I but I do think it's an interesting
conversation to have when it comes to
this cyclical nature of these problems
that we all feed into factions we all
feed into and at the end of the day the
the answer is to stop doing it and
that's not gonna happen so we're gonna
sit here arguing about the same things
over and over again for for decades
because it's it's just gonna the scale
is gonna change right I said yeah I
stood up my Square I didn't support
Nintendo
objects I'll be your bestie I'm sorry
okay I play Tears of the Kingdom I I I
don't want to talk about that
um so you trying to expose me and I
don't know
the gaming industry has talk our
compassion yeah and our passion they
have it straight and they they hand and
they know that there's been very few
moments in history in gaming history
where everyone came together on
something and when usually it does
happen so I always got to give it to the
PC people even though you guys get on my
nerves you know you guys stand together
a lot more than the rest
of the restroom no fashion let's get the
cake I'm dying for this this I'll be
waiting for the kick this is Valdez gate
is causing
industry shifting dialogue we got devs
versus Gamers influences it's real
outside where does the king stand on all
this
oh God these dudes are so
all right one person saying that uh you
know Dev should aspire to do this and
the devs want a participation trophy no
we participated these as a participation
trophy dude no our game it should not be
held to the standards of the next guy
because the next guy can run fast to
jump higher and do other things we
should never aspire to be as good or as
great as that guy
I don't know I haven't even heard what
this game has done that has broke the
genre that that is supposed to be so
mind-bending I hear Kyle talking about
oh the the dwarfs got destroyed
I had people talking about oh they're
able to do things with beers that should
not be done not like this it's just it's
okay it's a game that's out in a cycle
now it's a lot of things surrounding
this game that's having a lot of
conversation about it's a high quality
game that's being staggered on release
you have one uh group talking about oh
it's it's exclusive to us shut up if it
a lot if it released on the the PC is
exclusive to the PC first all right so
stop claiming things yeah Larry said
that yeah this this is ridiculous this
is absolutely ridiculous but it is water
finding its level
all right
before you know if y'all listened if
y'all was here in the early part of the
show our geek and I and you know the
rest of the the panel was talking about
games being released those games didn't
have an Avenue of a patch and stuff
being upgradable so when they came out
these guys did the best that they
possibly could to deliver you the
product that they possibly can give you
the best quality product right and
though from those days you got gems you
got those games that oh man it was so
dope and and they were really good you
got the boulders getting stuff like that
all right so now
you have people that got so relaxed and
got so uh laid back in the ability of
saying are we going to launch a patch
later down the road facts oh we we got
this oh hey man when this feature's not
there we can just release this feature
later facts so
you know both this game fell into The
Perfect Storm
yeah I'm gonna know what the
conversation would be if stadia was
still around
right so because the game would have
been released on stadia right so I want
to know if it would have released and it
seems Polish state that it is now and I
know you're going to say Divinity and
Divinity 2 original sin all those games
show that they do produce quality so why
are you shocked
right why is this oh my God they've done
something that nobody has done in the
industry cook
it's it's not it's just a quality Studio
releasing a quality game and it had
enough time to release this quality game
to the platforms and you guys are
overwhelmed by the fact that it's a
quality game being dropped and then
somebody had the ability to say yo you
know what everybody should strive to
this and developers is like no we should
not be held to the standards of somebody
else
that doesn't make any sense that's
idiotic in a statement you should be
held to the standard but it's water
finding its level and what y'all don't
want and if anybody's opposed to a good
game being good in a good game uh having
not to to release a patch and to fix
this after you made your purchase if you
the developer
as opposed to that that means that you
don't want them to look at you you don't
want them to look over to you because
you probably planning a patch after the
fact you're probably saying we can get
the game up to running speed here and
then we can release later with this
patch that get it up to 1440p and then
we can release the 60 frames per second
patch later and then we can no let's
let's stop that rhetoric let's release
the best possible games that we can
release
yeah I mean like you said we're
consumers
when you go into the store did somebody
say all right um here's your fish we're
gonna give you the potatoes in like five
hours no they don't do that right or
they charge you to cook to to cook the
steak we can give you the raw steak and
if you want you can pay more to have it
cooked that's if you're at Hibachi but
you gotta you gotta think about it right
you got to start demanding better as a
consumer you guys are so easy to bend
the knee you're so easy to give your
money in and like addict said you're
rewarding bad behavior and it's and it's
us too it's not just a challenge okay as
long as y'all no no no about the good
job
I'm I'm definitely 100 in on this okay
Halo Infinite release I didn't care
about I don't care about a lot of stuff
about ref 460 y'all ain't care about
little man's split screen yeah I care
about none of that I don't care
you remove the bickering by giving
somebody something they perceive for
free right right so
that's why I don't have a dog in the
fight I haven't played bold this gate
and I can't tell you the quality that is
in and I refuse to play ball this game
right now knowing that starfield's about
to come out and I'm about to jump into
that and I gotta finish Final Fantasy
60. I got a backlog of stuff but for
those individuals that dig your balls is
getting you do like that and you expect
quality uh going forward then by all
means you should speak to that you
should you should tell people of
developers I want the same quality here
but you can say that you want the same
quality and then you're saying well they
can release that 60 frame patch later
but I'm about to dig in on this actually
right so you got to stand on your square
and we are not willing to do so the
hypocrisy in this whole topic be honest
with you it's all very high
yeah
right now star filled it's buggy it
don't work it's a bad game and I'ma
still wanna buy that sucker to try it
myself wait I don't do something but I
gotta ask you this because this is the
other thing is again where I gotta you
know I mean I gotta keep it balanced you
know what I'm saying as far as what the
devs are saying they are saying that
this is an outlier they're saying these
dudes got like six years to make a game
who's got shot the laryn because the
game's amazing these dudes got Early
Access they got paid too and right and
my question kicked let's go back to you
because you are
anti-beta boy you do not like doing
betas you do not right I know you don't
you you've always said on this podcast
that Gamers should be paid that's a
development
so how could we have that with these
goals against what you believe in well
this is this this is this part as far as
um if you're gonna beta test something
and I want everybody in the community
y'all can sign petitions and do that
refuse to beta test Day games until they
pay you because they used to have
research and development departments
they used to have gameplay departments
they used to have all the stuff that
they used to play they used to pay
people for they brought people in and
people played the games and found the
bugs bug testers excuse me they had all
of these things in place they removed
those things when they found out that
you idiots decided to say you know what
I'll pay I'll test it for free and I'll
give feedback if they give you a whole
questionnaire right after you played the
game did you like it did this board have
this if you see any bugs could you
please report it so you are snitching
getting paid at least these snitches out
here in the street is getting paid in
the police officer
I'm technically in the QA yeah I know
iqa I know we know as long as you're
getting paid it's no problem if you're
not getting paid the hell with this so
no I I don't I don't agree with a lot of
this stuff and I don't care but if you
gonna have me beta test yourself
pay me because that was what I was doing
before I come from back then I come from
looking at the the job hunting in the
back of the magazines and they said if
you play games do you want a bug test do
you want to do this do that but you guys
are doing it for free like this is done
me I think what the individual that was
saying this tweet is like uh you know
game development is so many variables
that Boulders Gate 3 is an example of
the majority of them being gone done uh
you know successfully or just about a
lot of issues they didn't do nothing
they got the bag from Stadium let's keep
it a buck oh you got the bag from
station he was making a game
and it was sitting on a game and they
said you know what we're gonna get more
money we're gonna get the PC money now
we're gonna get the PlayStation money
we'll get the Xbox One you don't think
all that money can turn into a great
game and all this time but we've seen
plenty of times where all that money
didn't matter
I never heard of no problem but I don't
I don't know okay larion Studio says it
believes in Google's platform all right
that that age poorly but it is not going
to participate in the exclusivity game
so it wasn't exclusive
always it was always and I see the the
question is when did they decide the
Early Access route was the right route
to take that's the question because
that's what made this game what it is
right it was the player feedback it was
the feedback and the fact that they were
allowed to make it no they got paid they
got paid
that's crazy right this is my problem
early X yes yeah I'm playing it in the
background you know it's crazy Club if
you're in Early Access you're literally
paying them to pay to test their own
game this
I'm going to be part of the exclusive
hold up let me asking this if if having
more get more Publishers experimenting
with you know early access games leads
to better quality games I'll be okay if
they start paying people so I'll be okay
if these dudes stop
so you're not gonna be happy at the fact
that when you do decide to play ball
this gate three it's going to it's a
better product because when the beta
boys that played it before you know what
okay you know why I don't care Tommy
just sitting there putting in 30 hours
but can't play can't buy food for the
week
but I'm playing both this game
this one this topic is Raging I'm glad
you was able to judge because I want
your perspective I know your time is
limited so whatever he was very vocal in
the chat so I said yeah he's very vocal
so look obviously we saw Destiny's
comment we saw the editorial we saw the
pushback from Gamers we saw obviously
developer push back from saying hey
outlier not that we don't want those
same things too but it's not Apples to
Apples that kind of thing where this
little Jean Park stand in all of this
controversy about Boulder's Gate three
and the Excellence that it is raised in
this community I didn't get this off my
chest because like watching the
conversation has been infuriating here
we go let's go
uh my biggest question is uh goes back
to the original tweet which goes back to
Mr X Nelson right yes the one that that
Dustin was saying yes yes right my and
that was back in July 8th and I totally
missed that tweet I didn't I didn't even
know that there was anyone talking about
or anything like that Destin's video was
the one that highlighted before me my
question is who was he responding to
when he wrote that Twitter thread like
like where where did the context
originally originally start from because
because from what I can tell I don't see
anybody I don't see people saying hey
super giant games or hey small Studio
you need to make a Baldur's Gate three
if you're gonna make an RPG this is the
standard you got to be I don't and and
Nelson writes for small Studios so I
don't think anyone's expecting their
Studio to make a Baldur Escape 3 right
but maybe maybe there were people who
who were saying that so that's why I'm
wondering like where did the contact
here it started July 8th yeah would he
put that yeah because like people like
at this point that threat and Dustin's
point was is just talking past each
other and what's crazy is that Destin's
video is making other devs talk past
talk past him and they're starting to
say foolish things like oh my God like
like that uh that PR guy in Canada uh
Sean got a ratio by Cromwell uh who said
well it was gate three had insane
funding from DND and then Cromwell would
have to say what funding
wait Cromwell say what funded I almost
passed out that was wrong in my account
you know that's crazy but like he was
defending uh the original Point by
Nelson that says hey you know like like
this a project like The Potter's gay
would be too risky at scale blah blah
but it's like are people saying that are
people asking but then also to that
point disco Elysian was made by like how
many people you know 30 yeah like 30
people and that game is rated higher
than Baldur's Gate three right it
obviously is not it didn't sell as well
but it's still at that quality it's just
a much smaller game you can still make a
game like that with a small Studio
so even that point is confusing to me
and then destined uh has made the wrote
his article uh because I get I guess he
saw uh even if you go back to that
original tweet by Mr Nelson you see
people responding already Yes uh by
saying things like hey you know like
like you can't do this and what's up
with with micro transactions and like
buggy games and blah blah blah and all
these Shady practices so already that
interpretation of the original thread
was out there I think Dustin was
boosting that that point of view you
know I don't think that it that he would
just decided to just make this on some
other thing I think it was already some
other thing and in Destiny was boosting
that point of view and then now people
are responding Destiny he's the
initiator yeah that's a good point
that's actually an excellent point no
I'm finished I'm sorry so I mean to me
it just goes to show like how crazy like
you can just see the communication
breakdown in real life I I imagine that
everybody is actually agreeing with each
other to a certain point like yes you
know small Studios probably can't make
this as big of a game yes micro
transaction and Shady business practices
are bad yes like
who can disagree with any of that [__]
and that's why what you can't really
disagree with what Destin is saying
because and that's why Destiny's video
is popping off because like at the
surface level of it he's right you know
but it's like is he addressing what Mr
Nelson was talking about I'm not sure
you know it doesn't seem like it but
then what was mission Nelson responding
to responding to yeah because it seems
like his initial talk was just kind of
like again what you know I he said I
like a lot of people I'm deeply excited
about what the lovely Folks at Larry and
accomplished with Boulder's gay three
but I want to gently preemptively that's
the key word I preemptively push back
against players taking that excitement
and using it to apply criticism or raise
standard to RPGs going forward and then
that's what started the whole thing
about Dev cycles and developers and
office and all that other stuff I I
wanted to get Huggy unless I'm sorry let
you finish I just want to make sure you
get everything off and I want to get
hard game then I'll jump in yeah yeah no
I just want to end off with like it's
just crazy to see the communication
breakdown in real time and then for me
like that makes me being like like you
know like what other things are are we
getting wrong in history because we
can't even get this this one thing that
happens
this [__] is on text on paper and we
still cannot interpret this [__]
correctly language The Ten Commandments
are correct you know come on
listen we definitely I mean yeah it's
just wild to see like everyone just
completely talk past each other yeah we
just got this messy whole discourse
where everybody is just saying kind of
what just saying different things and
fighting about you're just everyone are
just having their own argument and their
own fight in their own head right now
yes yes and I think it's getting really
really messy out here then I gotta get
my boss because I didn't go yet yeah I
was just gonna add uh the the
development cycle like as far as the
time frame you know games are taking as
long and like so it literally took what
six years I guess to do this game and
you know look at about that six plus
years of development uh at least we
don't know when it actually comes out
it's maybe next year that would make it
at least six years because they knew of
that game before they acquired them and
that was in 2018 right so we're talking
at least six years star feels eight
years right so games do take this long
now that's just the norm and like so
again if it is you know a triple A
versus double a ND right you can give
slack to a double layer Indie right to
say okay we don't expect this to go at
that same level larian is a pretty big
Studio though and they they should be at
that AAA level right so they they spent
six years to do it and and they came up
with a polished product I I think some
of the things King was saying were were
very important to note they didn't do
anything crazy all they did was put out
a game that they should have put out
that's it that's all they did that's all
they did they put it put out the game
and it's just polished to the point
where it does what it's supposed to do
they promises what it's going to do and
it did it that's it that's you know
what's funny Harvey this game literally
just comes out it functions very well
like it's supposed to on launch and it
doesn't have microtransactions in it and
people are giving it this much price
that's how bad we are in the industry
right now with my transactions and
unpolished games that when those two
things are done
we are putting them on such a high
pedestal for stuff they should be doing
when I get here look let me jump in I
don't want to point out here I mean
bottle Gear 3 does do something special
you know yeah
and we haven't seen a game like this in
Mass Effect and it is more complicated
than messing yeah about to take my
points good good it ever was you know
like at the beginning of the game there
are there are main characters that you
can completely Miss and kill and they're
just gone from the rest of the game yes
that's it yeah
well that's the thing that that's one of
the arguments that people were talking
past the fact is the fact that as a
Baldur's Gate game if you look at the
history of what Boulder gate has been
and and it being based on d d is about
emergent gameplay this is it's just
stuff that stuff that happens on the fly
in these games it's not built for that
in other games like this is put this is
so they decided to take that formula
right because I I guarantee you people
would have been disappointed if you just
got ball to get one and two again
looking prettier right they had to
elevate that and in in elevating that
now you have it where besides the PC
Community now you have the console
Community looking at it and now you have
this whole Squad of people never thought
about balder's gate before looking at
the most complex RPG they've ever seen
in their life and looking at like it's a
brand new toy and it isn't a brand new
toy it's a toy that has been improved
upon over decades exactly it's the same
thing same thing as what happened with
Eldon ring right where people are like
oh my God what is elderman doing abroad
they're doing the same thing they did in
Demon Souls back in 2009 yeah but the
beautiful thing about elvenaring and
Baldur's Gate 3 is that these developers
are doing what they uh what they always
been doing good and that's that's what
we're celebrating right here I've seen
the change or didn't change the dynamic
or anything like that despite what the
market says they didn't make it more
casual
good point good point you know good
point yeah I gotta jump I'm sorry
I've been hosted look man this this is a
great discussion um
I think personally a lot I lean more
with Gina saying I think we are talking
over each other and I think between the
between Gamers and developers and I
think honestly the anger is misplaced I
think that the anger really should be at
the Publishers here I think we are
attacking the developers you know say
say the day should be doing but a lot of
this is coming from up top when we look
at what you guys are saying especially
what solver said as far as like the
structure of these games
right and right now we're looking at you
know insane player choice you know
Boulder's Gate the term a turn-based
Game Addict right doing this kind of
kind of thing and
to me I always look at it and I think
Gene you alluded to with the Mass Effect
comparison which is what I was going to
go to is that if you're the publisher
right and you go yo all right Boulder's
Gate all right you know Mass Effect why
is this game taking five to six years to
make right now we know Larry is in a
different situation but let's just say
your EA let's just say you're some
publisher that is managing this game
right and they're like look we got all
these player choices and you know all
this uh ability you talk about
characters that you you may or may not
even see you or die at the beginning
that you may miss and all this choice
and Paragon Renegade and then they sit
there look at the metrics and say well
ten percent of the people five percent
of people actually pick this choice and
you made all this development time for
this right so then now it's the pushback
right because the games games are
expensive games are taking so long to
develop and then in their mind they like
so much few percentage so little few
percentage is actually going to see this
yo
ball is gay four Mass Effect air drop we
gonna have to cut this you should have
said this is where the pushback is so I
think developers want it but again it's
the Publishers and it goes back to what
we were saying earlier where it's just
like rewarding bad behavior so to speak
right when when the game comes out and
we don't see that level of Polish and we
don't see you know the features that we
we see the nickel and diamond and the
over monetization right the problem is a
lot of times and we don't see the
multiple paths I remember even at it
remember Fallout 4 got a little pushback
for not being as hardcore as Fallout 3
with player choice dialogue it's a great
it's a great like first person shooter
action thing but right it's not a good
Fallout game yeah because a lot of them
we just had a really good recent example
rainfall yes yes come on you want to
talk about chasing Trends you want to
talk about Publishers
[Music]
you know interruption or whatever that
yeah you want to talk about devs wanting
to make their own game but then they
couldn't that's right
they went out of a lot of the original
team as we heard right yeah they quit
because they was like this is not the
game we're gonna win so I I honestly
still blame it on the Publishers and I
still blame it on the gamers for
supporting bad habits
microtrans that all this stuff that we
say we're not gonna do We're Not Gonna
support but when the game the hot
trailer come out or that game that
you've been waiting for that remake or
whatever we bending the knee so I think
I think that's what we're put in that
situation too when people use that as an
excuse all right let's go okay okay it's
just the fact that okay yeah redfall
whatever if the game would have hit then
you know we would have just heard
despite all our challenges the game
still came out to be good oh now the
game is oh it was whatever well you know
I didn't want to be there anyway
you know so it's always you know it's a
cute late excuse later
listen take your loss or got your loss
you know you were there you could have
easily said you know for the people that
did leave they say I'm not going to be a
part of this I don't like this this is
not where I'm going standing Square get
out go ahead and do that so then you can
tell across the street I told you it was
gonna be trash I told you I that's why I
left good I'm down with that but don't
after the fact you know yell out you
know it's just game you know I wasn't
about the the direction
if we were to hit though you you know
despite all our Channel nobody got two
different acceptance speeches
I know see that famous like yellow tint
uh like apology thing on every studio
now we know we have we launched with
issues and we're sorry that it went this
way it's like that's becoming
I honestly think there is someone out
there that can get really good at that
and make money because so many studios
of the apology tweet about how the
expectation wasn't made we're hiring for
an apology tweeters
got one left one I'll give it to you
right back to you Huggy but like to hug
each point I just think we are at a
reflection point I think baldi's gate
has changed the game even though
theoretically like to solve and Jita
said it these games have existed it's
just that the we haven't had it in such
a while and now you see the positive
response rarely this polish right for
the Polish right and that is the
pushback but again to our geet's point
right like this is the new I'm saying
the new normal but this is what the game
Gaming Community is now gravitating with
their wallet so far and say hey we want
to see this and it's like oh wow it's
like there's certain inflection points
where breath of the wild came out it's
like yo remember we a lot that these
soil Publishers kind of Chase it up
breath of the wild clone bag for a
little bit it's certain points where it
does raise things and now it's like if
you don't have this then gamers are not
going to respond to but argue I know you
want the joke yeah so on the publisher
thing I push back a little bit in that
it is good to set constraints on a
development Studio to say like don't go
crazy if something only resonates with
one percent you know don't spend half a
year on it right it's not going to be
enough of a result so don't do that I
get I agree with that what I am very
concerned about is when they take a
single player studio and say make it
something that's live because that has
almost never works I had the co-op
component you got to come out
okay with potentially doing Co-op it's
more if I want to add uh you know some
sort of uh live service capability to it
make it multiplayer right
yeah and yeah and things that just don't
make sense right so uh you know when you
try to do that you take what a good Core
Group can do and say expand yourself
into something you have no comfort with
and suddenly make a product that's at
the same quality as what you did before
and it it rarely works it's very hard to
do I'm not I can't even think of an
example where that's actually worked
right but it works a little bit in the
Assassin's Creed games where like they
they did just enough to where they can
put microtransactions in but they didn't
go like they didn't jump in the pool but
it's not live service so they did have
like a couple where you had Co-op
missions right but yeah it's not hey you
you know this is TV people where
everybody's playing together like it's
it's very hard to do that well in an
established thing and a studio that
tries to do that it's it's not as easy
to pull blocks so I I prefer that they
don't do and I'm very concerned with
where Sony's going I'll just say like
with the last
majority of their money into live
service and some of their Studios to say
hey you should look at live this is
exactly what happened with redfall right
Max is like yo uh we we need people to
you know we need games that make a lot
of Revenue and it's good to look at
these live service things which is how
redfall came about right 76 happened
yeah so happened right but uh you know
that studio Arcane was not like a good
multiplayer Studio they're very good at
making but there's that at the time was
chasing Trends and a pre-acquisition
error that's what I keep telling people
they trying to get that back and to your
point and adequately will appreciate
this because even though it wasn't a
topic we moved this topic out this topic
was supposed to be a vow today but then
we saw this book we changed it but did
you see with fur cross and and the eval
CEO said as far as how they initially
thought it would be more attractive to
Publishers for a vowed if they had a
co-op right and they they had to sit
back now that they were the Microsoft
and say you know what that is not our
DNA this is not what we do let's do
these more contained well-written
stories and now evolved is turning into
the game that they wanted to choose and
was like yeah
they don't want to say those like shout
out to Microsoft for allowing them to
make that's what I'm saying yeah
you promised me a co-op experience in
this so I could sell it better because
that's where I'm against
yo they also reinforce a meeting meeting
meetings this is the full reform no this
is from before right it's before this is
one of the games that they show and fell
in love was like oh they got this
cooking outside of our world
was good it ain't nobody in that
building
here's the thing this is when when Carl
uh we always say not every developer is
created equals yeah there's a lot of
other Studios would have seen what was
going on with a vowel and said we're
gonna make it work obsidian was like we
can't make this work we gotta re we
gotta restructure that's right because
from Arcane Studios yes yeah yeah he
said you know what sometimes other
studios are just at another level we
can't make a game like thank you for
saying
unfair to death that is big like not all
Studios created equal we gotta be real
as far as development gets beat up and
said I'm not going across the street
anyway look we beat this to death
anybody saw him yet any other boys no I
just I just laughed shout out to the
canary in the coal mine to all of this
Sean Layton
a couple years ago has been saying it
and this is this is all about
the scope of these games being so
unwieldy that all of these other
circumstances
impede the art right that's what it is
like it's just crazy so would you rather
go backwards or you rather continue on
the thing that I see I don't think there
is any going back right there's anything
going on right so like it's figuring out
yeah it's figuring it out and that's the
thing we've been conditioned to expect
more we've been conditioned to
constantly expect more better graphics
frame rate Fidelity
why is that oh that's because you pay
more exactly exactly so as we as we move
forward then what are we gonna do we're
gonna do cognitive yeah let's go let's
just jump this right in right because
it's a perfect transition
yeah you got to get the right airport
out there get it out let's just get it
over with I'll do it right after that
yeah
um speaking of rewarding bad practices
let's get it let's get right to it but I
want to save for this one
after this yeah I'll get you I'll get
you first uh take two interactive and
Rockstar there
have decided that they are going to
Grace us bless us
with not a remaster not a remake but a
straight Port of 2010s the Xbox 360 PS3
Classic Red Dead Redemption
a straight Port that guarantees the
minimal amount and I I hate to say this
the minimal amount of resources they
would have to spend in order to allow
that game to be playable across all
modern platforms
it's like I took the microtransactions
for one month this is your budget this
is your budget let's go just go do this
so yeah the uh the re-release of Red
Dead Redemption will be coming to the
Nintendo switch
a platform that uh is going to more than
likely receive a new version or a new a
new system next year too but uh you have
to assume that they know something about
what's going on there so I'm assuming
that this game would be backwards
compatible with whatever the new machine
is and a PlayStation 4 version to also
ensure that that game is playable on a
PlayStation phone's out here who's out
here in the industry so as someone who
loves this franchise loves this game in
particular I was particularly
disappointed that we got Philadelphia
Elation was not a word that was in my
vocabulary last week
um so I've heard a lot of different
takes about why this is from a business
perspective you understand why they
would do it minimal amount of investment
maximum amount of uh profit of return
now when you look at the worry right the
worry in this porting moving of it is
that um we get the same initial result
we got with when you know Grove Street
games got the GTA Trilogy Definitive
Edition and it was far from definitive
um and it was far from definitive to the
tune ultimately of nearly 15 million
copies sold
rewarding bad behavior so
now the uh the dev team working on this
game is double 11 Studios a studio that
has worked on a number of Vita games
they've done work for thick games like
Crackdown three they've worked on
Minecraft dungeons they've done a number
of different sort of uh contract work
for a lot of these uh games and they
have done smaller games of their own
accord as well
um they've been tasked with bringing
this forward so I'm as a fan I'm
obviously disappointed I'm disappointed
in the fact that we don't get a PC
version but obviously that wouldn't that
would have meant that would have meant
you know putting in the buzz bells and
whistles that modern Gamers expect from
a PC version so from a business
perspective with them being all hands on
deck on GTA 6 I understand right not
happy but I I get where they could be
coming from with this but at the same
time I think with them specifically I
think there is a trend towards them
caring less and less about the single
player aspects of their IP right I'm not
saying GTA 6 single player will not be
amazing right but they're gonna drop an
amazing thing and then walk away from it
and focus on whatever the next aspect of
GTA online is going to be right and
that's to me
disappointing because it means that when
they're they're looking at the examples
of an re4 remake they're looking at the
examples of a dead uh Dead Space remake
and they're saying nah we don't need
that we don't need to spend the time the
money the resources to do that we're
going to give them this and they'll be
happy with that and 15 million sales in
you can't blame them
um but either way it is bad behavior
that we are continuing continuing to uh
to support because my man Gene I heard
you I'm punching up he's like I'm
getting it
is the problem
s
I'm the guy buying Assassin's Creed
every year so yeah me too me too again
again I'm at falling in other ways as
well so what do you guys think I'm sick
to my stomach but what do you guys do
let's start with the offender let's go
right to him well I think I think I'm
going to be preaching to the choir here
but I think the real winners here are
Xbox players yes right yeah I think it's
fantastic uh one of the biggest uh
bonuses with the Xbox platform is the
backwards compatibility uh the fact that
for some reason Microsoft is the one
that's actually caring the most about
their legacy titles yeah and their
legacy games uh the fact that I can log
on to Red Dead Redemption Online on my
Xbox series X right now and still have
my level 17 Cowboy from back back in
like 2000 whatever uh it's still
playable now at the exact same spot that
I left him like like 12 years ago that's
crazy yeah that's crazy and and multi I
think you forgot multiplayer is not even
included in not in the new package wait
no no it's on
Undead Nightmare is going to be in the
package but no multiplayer so yeah just
yeah go you just go just get hit yeah
and it's like the servers don't ex if
the servers didn't exist anymore
obviously you understand they exist oh
the service
that's crazy they're still live on Xbox
that's different so yeah I logged right
right back in and you know if you log
back in and get people are are cheating
like crazy
as soon as I log in I got sniped from
somebody in the clouds bro yeah that's
crazy
don't even try to play it right now but
I mean it still looks good in 4k I
actually played that did a fresh run of
it a few years ago when Xbox came out
and I saw it there and I was like that
that's the magic of Xbox
really emphasizes uh you know how we
don't care about the legacy of our
titles you know this is what's enabling
these companies to to to keep charging
us more you know the fact that
PlayStation has no backwards
compatibility with PS3 at all and the
only reason why they're releasing on the
PlayStation 4 is just to have it on
Modern consoles I guess that's it you
know so that's why I'm going to get it
and switch that's the only portable
version that that'll be legal around
it's true
um but yeah otherwise it's uh hugely
disappointing right
um
no 60 frames per second I I think people
saw that the laws the the the the the
distance of certain certain objects uh
is a little bit pulled back so you can
see a little bit more farther back
that's kind of cool I guess but
otherwise I don't know I don't know what
they're doing no 60. no 60s and to be to
be clear a lot of people have been
saying this incorrectly the remastered
the conversion the port the port the
version
let's be clear too A lot of people been
saying this online it's not true the
Xbox version is not 60.
it cleans up the choppy 30 that the
original game had it's very it's a rock
solid 30 but yeah no sexy either it
looks clean it's very sharp it looks
great that's a 4K Set uh I highly
recommend it if you still got your your
copy downloaded just go buy it on
Netflix yeah you could just go cheaper
too cheaper cheaper too the cheaper and
you get online you know yeah good point
appreciate GG full enough foreign
step away for a little bit and I know
your time limited so um yeah every day
you ready right day one let's go switch
I don't know man like these days I can't
even I can't even touch anything that
has like a horse in it because I I swear
I I got pts yo like like I I just like
every time I try to play something like
a red dead I just Vision like trying to
pull out a gun and just it's not there
so it's like you know because of my
disorder I'm not allowed to to get on it
I don't know it's like weird like that
that's a joke but like there's legit
games that like mess with me like I
can't play hellblade because I can't
stand or like I just get so freaked out
by her voice in my ears and stuff it's
just like when it comes to this game
don't support it I'm gonna be real if
you like don't support this game you
know if anything go go go buy that
competition that that's we're we're
going to a different way than boycotting
go buy that competition you know if you
got stock in the company pull that stock
out oh damn yeah yeah it's just like the
only way they're gonna hear it is money
oh okay looks like Huggy is back that's
all I got to say you know I'm pretty
sure everyone coming through I have to
take all of you all right I know you
gotta run yeah I was supposed to be out
here by four so I'm probably gonna be in
trouble but you know it is what it is uh
I appreciate it for coming through
appreciate heart again and uh Gene Park
for coming through hit that like button
we almost got a thousand people in here
we got 476 likes hit that like like
something I have to uh I'm have to tune
in for uh that that PlayStation USB port
for King crazy I gotta hear that but I'm
pretty sure ever come through and uh I'm
going to stay in and just mute
everything because I don't want to
accidentally close out oh yeah yes the
thing yeah no doubt no doubt no doubt
Lord King we had no remastered I mean
conversion nothing new bro stop it
the news is new this is
putting me of the last topic we just had
bro this is exactly and you do is gonna
run out there you're gonna buy it and
you're gonna support and the sales is
gonna happen and they're gonna keep
doing this to you dudes they will not do
this to me I don't care the last time I
played it was when the game came out and
the fact that I was able to take my disc
and put it in and still play it on my
Xbox works for me this is the difference
between an Xbox user and you guys so you
guys can continue to take this and have
fun with it I like to hear that you
ain't getting nothing new
the only thing new is the price God
bless have a good time and and listen
see y'all on the other side someday you
may wake up you know this is for the
consumer that blindly just clicks and
buys or goes to the store and hey what
came out new good you think it's new
that's on you oh wow Red Dead Redemption
now they got it too
um you at home you find out that the
game is for for ten dollars
you sucker
the game is regularly regularly on sale
on Xbox wow like you could really you
can get it for ten dollars like it is
really affordability for the switch so
you can actually get the disc pretty
cheap right if you want to get it oh
yeah absolutely
they want to get some love
sucker he just Butler getting it at the
start of at the start of the switch
generation right 2017 I would have been
elated to see this at the end of it when
you know and this is the thing they
they have to know that the next thing is
back compat right yes because they're
not going to even spend the resources on
putting it on switch now with switch
sales waning
knowing that a new one's coming next
year so this is fully back comparison
and it is the minimal amount of work
that you have to do to just get it on
the Nintendo platform that's it same
with PlayStation it is the minimal
amount of work to get it on the Legacy
PlayStation platform that also plays on
the new one that is it and it's
disappointing you know what I mean but I
think that's what it is on the switch is
it cool yeah because you'll be able to
you know play on the go and it's a
native version sure I'm not doing that
again I know I know but I know I know a
couple of million that work oh I know
I've been waiting for this my whole life
shut up
I think the saddest part about it is
that you're taking a 360 game importing
it to the PS4 and the fact that they did
not tout anything about protein
nothing you know nothing that is crazy
to me no dual sense nothing nothing
11. bro they would have said something
what what did you tap that I was like
yoga ps4 version and especially playing
on a PS5 is going to give you no no
yeah that's nice
excited you get this day one gonna get
the DLC like king I don't have to I own
this on Xbox so I don't need to worry
about it we got a 1x enhanced version so
we actually get 4k they get nothing
I would like to ask our friend behind
the scenes so we know who we talk about
if because this this game
has all of the the great back compat
features except for FPS boost and I
think the FPS boost breaks at some point
it breaks to the point that like now we
can't Implement yeah that's what
everything else it won't work yeah so
I'm thinking is that because this game
is notoriously built on spit
they had to bring it the bands had to
come in and fix this game so
um yeah it it's probably one of those
things where it breaks so badly in
certain parts they did it they could not
even think to put it in the final sort
of back compact build of it so yeah so
one thing I'd love to see if they could
pull it off because we don't need a new
version of it I don't need to pay 50
bucks for it but if they could just go
in and say you know what we're gonna
patch the old 360 version like they did
with the 1X Advance yes you can say
we're gonna uncap the frame rate so if
your series X can drive it to 80 frames
go to town okay right why not just do so
that's a question up to to you know take
you like they can decide to like hey
what the heck you know like if you want
to do it why not just go ahead and make
that happen outside of that we have the
best version already it doesn't matter
this port is doing nothing to enhance
the game it's not 4K not 60 FPS it's
just a direct Port we got the best
version of the game yeah we keep the
multiplayer it's still running you can
still play it we keep them they don't so
I this port seems kind of weird to me uh
it's it really kind of slaps the players
on that on those platforms it's funny to
me right because I have it on Xbox but
yeah it's still it seems bogus right
they should they should make some
attempt to make it more modern uh yeah
and this is the thing like up press
that's the thing right and the thing is
you we haven't seen any sort of upgrade
to this game for 10 years so you're
assuming my assumption is okay they're
telling these they're telling Xbox to 10
PlayStation yo don't do any upgrades uh
at the console level because we're
coming out with something right we're
coming out with something you would
think that's what it is I'm like okay
fine they're gonna make me pay for it
again but they're gonna give me up you
know 4K 60 whatever no no none of this
is true none of this is true yeah I
think for me I'll jump in real quick um
my disappointment is more
they've been called out for actually
saying in the past that they wouldn't do
something like this because there was a
statement from Moses uh straw zelnik
2021 he says um I'm not sure
as far as remasters they'll be uh last
show they'll be a bigger part of
strategy remastering has always been a
part of the strategy we've done
differently than the competition we just
don't Port titles over we actually take
the time to do the very best job we can
making the title different from the new
release for the new technology that
we're launching it on so we improve the
technology we upgrade the visuals and we
have performance enhancements and that's
why I think our remastered titles
typically do so well like this one this
is what he said now it's funny he's kind
of had to walk it back because recently
now recently well now about remasters it
depends on the vision that the creative
teams have for a title and in the
absence of having a powerful vision for
something that we would do with the
title we might bring it in its original
form we've done that and in certain
instances we might re Master a remake it
now depends really on the title and how
the label feels about it and the
platform and what we think is the
opportunity for a consumer so clearly
there has been a shift here clearly the
lift is lighter and uh yeah they're not
doing the care and all this attention to
detail that they said they was going to
do in 2021 Grove Street baby how much do
we got to pay to get that money oh we
have to want to pay 50 Grand yeah let's
do that let's do that so I just thought
that was that's all I wanted to do to
end this topic if anyone else has
anything else but we move on to kids
sucking my stomach yeah for real let's
move on then we got the last we want to
do the super chat I'll do the super test
and then pay the bills and then we'll
move that's right we got bills okay okay
okay we got Gears infinite welcome to
the round Lord bronze gears infinite for
the crest in the chat
then we have Robert kellett five dollars
Super Chat the backlash or the backlash
is from Publishers not the devs the
Publishers only view us as credit cards
and are more than okay dropping busted
games yeah yeah that's true
Nintendo Taco five dollars Super Chat
I'm still waiting for open world games
to catch up to breath of the wild we
definitely not gonna see RPG standards
change with bg3
well I'd say Alden ring did that right
that breath of the wild and made it as
good as it probably could be it's pretty
pretty close exactly Mr mdj five dollar
super chat if you look at the state of
these full price releases we are all
beta boys it's nice for them to put put
it in Front Street uh before everyone
spends seventy dollars no that too
Hollywood rules ten dollars a chat as
gray beards we're lucky to have seen all
of the changes in the industry and it's
why some of these Sony guys can't wrap
their heads around the possibility of
Sony failing winning and Sony on top is
all that they know
that's true I can see that
we have the darje Knight five pound
Super Chat yo sorry I've been around
much life's been busy blessings to all
around blessings to you sir brother Bill
appreciate you blessings Lucius Augustus
five dollar Super Chat streamers were
saying bg3 should be the standard this
conversation happened before Destin
asthma gone as asthma gold was saying
bg3 should be the standard from now on
I understand Dev sticking to what
they're good at and being successful but
there should be some pushback when they
hole up in a box some of the best
franchises came from Debs leaving their
Square
completely agree as well completely
agree also but yeah there's there's risk
right because the whole thing is that
they when they try to mitigate risk with
stuff you don't like like
microtransactions stuff like that
Alvin ten dollars to chat I get this
whole bg3 combo except to pushback on
MTX long as it's cosmetic like D4 just
ignore it I work hard and my pockets fat
if I want my Oblivion horse to floss
mind you're broken
well he said Badger broke this minds are
broke [__]
[Laughter]
yeah stop pocket watching okay come here
I feel you I feel you void luck remember
for 19 months Lord bronze Baldur's Gate
Remnant two Zelda breath of the wild and
Elden ring all the standard we need to
set in the industry we're good won't
disagree
we shouldn't be celebrating devs like
obsidian saying we couldn't expand our
repertoire and keep it at quality so we
ran back to our comfort zone
it's not quite what they said that's not
what they said that's not what they said
we have uh Jericho ten dollars in the
chat bg3 is a good game but let's not
forget it's isometric he's not about the
isolate you're not about the answer
Vision I got a caveat nah it's not good
to know because it's always better
Robert Kelly rock star more like scam
star am I right yeah or something like
this shout out to Strauss
Corey Tidwell two dollars Super Chat bg3
is a good game but there is some cap
going on it's a it's a moment it's a
Zeitgeist Moment Like I said a couple of
weeks the conversation will be in The
Ether like everything else
we are caught up Sir so time to pay the
rest of our bills sorry Mikes foreign
this episode is brought to you by Factor
meals with the busy fall season just
around the corner you might be looking
for wholesome convenient meals for
jam-packed days Factor America's number
one ready to eat meal kit can help you
fuel up fast with Chef prepared
dietitian approved ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door you will
save time eat well and stay on the track
with your healthy lifestyle as summer
comes to a close and Autumn approaches
that means change is in the air whether
it's the kids going back to school the
changes in the weather or the impending
holiday season everyone is in a Mad Dash
to finish the year strong like I said
changes in the air for everyone except
for me because for me winter spring
summer or fall I'm always working so
that means unfortunately the seasons
meld into one and it's a little
difficult for me to enjoy other aspects
of my life as much as I should one thing
I can say for sure is that lady SOB
always makes sure that I walk out of
this house with my breakfast lunch and
dinner in tow
and she does all of this while also
being a working professional what that
means is at the end of the week you have
two very tired individuals looking for
ways to spend less time in the kitchen
and more time enjoying life in comes
Factor meals we started using factor a
while back now and I'm pleased to say
that it's been a hit
we've been able to cut our prep time in
half by replacing half of our weekly
meals with factor and it's been amazing
whether it's breakfast lunch dinner or
snacks the meals are fresh they're
varied they're healthy and easy to
prepare just heat them up for a few
minutes and you're done and Lady Saab
has just a little bit of her sanity back
so if you're too busy to end your with
your end of summer goals to cook but
want to make sure you're eating well
with Factor skip the extra trip to the
grocery store and The Chopping prepping
and cleaning up too while still getting
the flavor and nutritional quality you
need factos fresh never frozen meals are
ready in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy and they
can get back to crushing your goals
refresh your Healthy Habits without
missing a beat choose from 34 plus
weekly flavor packed dietitian improved
meals ready to eat in just two minutes
level up with Gourmet plus options
prepare to Perfection by chefs and ready
to eat in record time treat yourself to
upscale meals with premium ingredients
like broccolini leeks truffle butter and
asparagus
too busy running around during the day
to think about lunch keep your energy up
with lunch to go effortless wholesome
meals like grain bowls and salad Toppers
that are ready to eat when you're on the
go no microwave required
so if you're looking for calorie
conscious options ahead of the busy
season try delicious dietitian approved
calorie smart meals with around or less
than 550 calories per serving need an
extra boost to support your Wellness
goals and fill your best for the rest of
the summer try Protein Plus meals with
30 grams of protein or more per serving
round out your meal and replenish your
snack Supply with an assortment of 45
plus add-ons including breakfast items
like our delicious apple cinnamon
pancakes which I love bacon and cheddar
egg bites also a favorite in the
household and potato bacon and egg
breakfast skillet I'm a breakfast guy if
you can't tell or for an easy Wellness
boost try refreshing beverage options
like cold pressed juices shakes and
smoothies with Factor you can rest
assured you're making a sustainable
choice we offset 100 of our delivery
emissions Source 100 of renewable
electricity for their production sites
and offices and features sustainably so
or seafood in our meals this August get
factor and enjoy eating well without the
hassle simply choose your meals and
enjoy fresh flavor-packed meals
delivered to your door ready in just two
minutes no prep no mess so head to
factorymeals.com iron Lords 50 and use
code iron Lords 50 to get 50 off that's
called iron Lords 50 at factormeals.com
iron Lords 50 to get a 50 off
no they'll salute to the fact I don't
know there's a lot of beefy talk going
on
and they got they gave a lot of beefy
options a lot of beefy awesome a lot of
truffle butter talk beautiful butter
why do you have to say it like that yo
we got to get the link if you cancel
with the link in the chat
yes sir we can get the super chances
I'll leave a link in a second give me a
moment uh let me let me read this
okay hold on a second I didn't get too
many more in
uh we got okay we didn't have too many
more
Corey Tidwell five dollars Super Chat
another thing it Forza Horizon is Niche
bg3 is esoterico wow okay then we have
Corey Temple five dollars Super Chat Sam
said truffle butter like a rub it on the
background
yeah
truffle butter yeah I don't like the
video
it's different all right
um that's it we're caught up yes don't
forget to put the facts all right do
that all right
we made it she's loved it
um yeah this king's topics or else I'll
set them up
um
okay their news before they but actually
some actual sourcing on some of these
yes oh PS5 USB ports seem to be coming
in hot y'all um shout out to attack you
just have to get taco
um that ps5s got so hot at fighting game
tournament things melted Sony's consoles
reportedly cooked USB ports at the
fighting game tournament for Street
Fighter 6 and more so I'm going to read
some accounts here from King great
graciously provided me
um all the accounts going on so over the
weekend thousands of fighting games
descended in Vegas um for Evo 2023
biggest fighting game tournament event
of the year and some competitors had one
problem some of the ps5s running all the
games were melting their controller
connectors with the last batches of
games like Street Fighter Mortal Kombat
they basically was stating that um at
this year's event this meant more more
than a few players dealing with ps5s
that got so hot they screwed up the
adapter so we show a couple of people
with um the gentleman is Eduardo Cuervo
this is my melted controller it just
took one set
um it's
kyoko236hs he said this got stuck on my
stick I got I got it got ripped out of
the PS5 they say
um Evo is proving that PS5 is not the
answer posted Twitter user saber AZ on
August 5th USB ports are melting like
cray and he said on his this is not
isolated we need to go to PC or Xbox at
least
um Kyosho uh
responded with a photo of the plastic
insert in the USB port this thing got
stucked I had to rip it out of the PS5
so other locals that had setups for um
PS5 or Street Fighter 6 set for multiple
hours the backside USB ports of two of
them melted and got ripped out they said
they were not either not designed
or they underestimated the heat the
console generates so yeah there's been a
bunch of reports about this and then
shout out to cnet.com who um also
commented on this and also said tips to
ensure your PS5 doesn't melt
use the front USB a or USBC Port rather
than the rear which is next to the heat
exhaust put it next to the rear
it forced to use the uh the new rear 8
USB if if forced to use the rear USB
port make sure the console has had
enough time to cool before put it in
when it's hot
you're ridiculous and then three avoid
using unlies unlicensed converters until
there's a statement from Sony or the
third party Hardware manufacturer so I
don't know if you want to start on this
king or you want me to also lead it to
the second part of your topic what was
the second part so according to uh k n n
news affiliate news dot
italy24. press
Italy 24 news states that how many
PlayStation um plus subscribers are
there sodi has not communicated the
updated data so um it's a rousing
curiosity and a little bit of concern
that Sony's decision not to disclose the
number of PlayStation Plus subscribers
as of June 30th of 2023 for the first
time at the end of the fiscal quarter
the company has not disclosed the
updated number of PlayStation Plus
subscribers so there's some
what I said a mass Exodus
the reason the Bible goes the reasons
behind the decisions are not clear we do
not know if it's a moment it can't be
good
we don't know if it's a momentary or
perhaps definitive Choice moving forward
as far as Sony not no longer interested
in communicating this information to the
plot to the public
um as of uh April 30th I think the end
of the previous fiscal year the service
could count on maybe 47 Millions
enrolled in the combined essential extra
and premium plus so there's been a lack
of communication there so King this is
your these are your topics
um you know where do you want to start
as far as the USB port scenario
overheating and Xbox yeah stand up
I told you it was an unstable box
I told you it will overheat when it's
stressed I told you it will not perform
good in crowds
crowds I told you it gets stage fright
and the dude stop burning stuff up he's
a hothead
the boy don't work right
stupid he's stupid you got the affiliate
told you go to PC or go to Xbox just do
crazy
he cannot be trusted in the back point
in the front part he gets kind of wild
too
yo your boy was it a match he had one
move left in his a button stopped
working couldn't figure it out
she cost the dude to mess up so they're
the detriment of the Evo competition
this is what you're saying okay no they
they own Evo and they PlayStations is
messing it up imagine owning something
and you gotta had a competitor because
your product can't perform
I waited for this
all you frauds
and when he told you
just wouldn't start to you know the
power starts to consume we will take the
power from me and we'll raise it up and
then the performance will enhance so
when they don't need this we will use
this oh you needed both of these
ah in your castle with bananas it can't
hold it it's a captain
not the Star Trek come on
it's an illegal party
I said what would you want me to do
Captain burn them out
to him do not allow him to enter through
the rare pause it with you I cannot with
you bro yo your PlayStation this is the
part where you need a fire extinguisher
and everybody in the world got a chance
to see you everybody World got a chance
to see all right so let me give you a
let's continue down yeah
let me give you two tips on how to keep
your PlayStations cool rip the Wings off
the PlayStations perform better butt
naked
wow and as far as the breaker the
braggart known as Sony our numbers are
superior we have 44 million subscribers
we sold 40 million consoles we have 10
million active subscribers right now uh
Sonny what was the fiscal numbers for
your subscriber base no comment
are you implying that the numbers are
not increasing and that's why they're
not disclosing soon I believe everybody
left
and somebody said yo um are you gonna
send the numbers in hold on let me get
those oh hell no
this up the pipeline we have a problem
do you expect numbers to come back for
PlayStation stuff one star Phil hit
everybody left for something oh that's
what it is okay it's a it's a Starfield
show we know what we gonna do they left
who left the subscribers they didn't
Game Pass they got the 14-day trial the
dollar deal it's back baby
so we can't keep up with these dudes
we're burning up and we're leaving at
the same time
yo I waited for this
y'all was holding the wrong Line Paul
and none of y'all dudes is talking about
this y'all was hoping that they just
didn't hit the radar I watch podcasts
after the podcast nobody was talking
about the fiery
so you doing the noise you bringing the
truth to the people that's what you're
doing
y'all listen that dude over there is an
unstable entity
so so you're going back on your original
design I believe what we had will be
hood or you said it's a supercharged
Hugo and that it's unstable it's an
unstable box
Free Fighter pushed it to his limit so
this is the reason why you're hearing
about a pro yo oh so this is the reason
why okay this is the reason why they
talk about a pro baby
because they knew after evil they say yo
get that to Market
[Music]
it's back to you Jim
and there you have it okay that news is
reporting giving us the news that uh
most are afraid clearly to talk about
King doing the Lord's work in reference
to saudi's operations clearly so uh yeah
uh hard Geet um your your thoughts on
both the PS5 USB situation as well as
the lack of reporting of PlayStation
Plus subscribers I
King
I follow okay this is your bed man all
right so uh look we actually did talk
about it on uh risket's podcast on
Friday
um and look I had the same fear like
they look we know this is supposed to be
a 9.2 T flop box it was supposed to be
three gigahertz and they overclocked
let's just be honest they overclocked
right the second they did that I'm like
yeah there's a reason we don't like
recommend overclocking as a standard
it's uh it reduces longevity and the
other problem you run into is heat
dissipation which is why they have this
Behemoth ridiculous console with this
massive heatsink right and as you keep
doing this eventually your cooling
system will lose efficiency that's just
the way it is right we're back when um
was it Austin Evans is that the guy yeah
yes oh yeah you know he saw rev 2 or
whatever 1.0 whatever the heck it was
right he came up and said hey look they
reduced the the size of the heatsink and
that is probably not going to overall be
a good thing because it will be less
efficient at cooling right what was he
right look the problem with this is it
was always going to be this way right
after about three or four years these
consoles were going to come due to have
these problems right they've always had
them by the way maternal like caused the
console to shut down right they've had
games like this happen where like like
it pushed it too far and it just
couldn't handle it and snap it turned
off right in this case it's melting
freaking USB cable that's pretty nuts
but again it's not it's not something I
didn't expect I unfortunately was
looking for this to happen at about this
time we're in that time frame where it's
going to start showing hey you're
overclocking that has a negative impact
there's just no way around it now I
don't know how widespread it's going to
be it may work out it may be like 90 of
the consoles it works fine and 10 have
problems the major question is how much
of it is if it's like four percent point
one percent point oh one percent ten
percent like we don't know right
as games keep coming that keep pushing
the console up to now we've been playing
cross gen games right they don't push
the console now we will we will start
pushing the console what happens right
first like you're you're doing this
variable clock thing you're you're doing
smart shift all this fun stuff that you
were playing with how does that actually
work in the real world when you really
push the box to its limits what will
happen how will this play out will it be
consistent will it be inconsistent will
people have different experiences and
will your box based on how well your
cooling is working throttle you down or
just shut off right so these These are
headaches they're going to run into now
I'm not saying that the Xbox is bereft
of this there have been like little spot
issues here and there but it is lock
clocked it's locked at a certain amount
and that's The Thermals they've you know
they designed it for and it it seems to
be okay for the most part right so uh
this was just and like King was saying
this might be why they have a pro yeah
this is also probably why they're gonna
do a slim stuff
yeah like if you with the the reason and
slim may not be slim you know slim may
just be that it's it's better at cooling
right yeah they found a better way to
pull the thing uh so but I like this is
a disappointing part of what would
happen when you go down this path they
tried to you know up the uh the
performance a bit to kind of match what
Xbox was doing which they probably
didn't really need to do but they did
and you know up to now the performance
narrative has really not really worked
in Microsoft's favor anyway even though
the majority games do run better on Xbox
it's it's been pretty much a like it's
it's a wash for the most part so I you
know nobody seems to really care about
that part but so if they just left it at
nine and left it at three you know they
probably would have been okay but they
decided to do this so I don't know what
the end outcome of this is It's it's
it's obviously not a good look it's it's
perfect like King said it it's that evil
yeah it's happening
like yo I don't want to be on this
platform anymore uh that's not that's
not great for them but you know it is
what it is it was it was bound to happen
at some point this stuff does come and
bite you this is why overclocking just
isn't yeah yeah it's a little man
holding them back
for them to have decided to do the
overclock I think and look they come
back and say no we didn't overclock we
always designed if this really you
designed a console that looks like a
freaking house and it has freaking Wings
on it like seriously you did this
because you had to compete and Microsoft
came up with 12 T flops and you had to
say oh crap I can't have single digit
t-flopped in I have to do something
better I I to me that's exactly what
they did they redesigned it to make it
this massive monstrosity right liquid
cooling and all that crap whatever
liquid metal so
um and to me that's what it is I
hopefully they iron this out and it
doesn't cause a massive uh you know
failure if it is going to cause more
problems then you know you're looking at
a massive replacement it could be like
hopefully not to the level of our Rog
but something similar like that in most
consoles you know there's something in
that generation where some major you
know Annoying Hardware thing happens
right fair enough this could be this
one's and hopefully they aren't out and
go on but uh it does seem rather amusing
that it happened at Evo and it's melting
I mean USB cable that is pretty pretty
nice can you make sure he found that
brought that to the people um real
quickly you know Huggy um your thoughts
on King's uh talk about the PlayStation
subscriber the numbers this is um
you know it's the same Playbook that
anybody plays when you're going up
everybody likes to tout their numbers
see it's better it's better and when
they're going down you're like um
yeah no comments
so Microsoft stop doing it too right a
long time I love Microsoft and and now
it's the same here but uh it would be
nice if it was more open and we had to
get these numbers but to be fair we
don't have to get these numbers if
shareholders you know say we want them
they could respond ultimately they'll
all they owe to the shareholders is and
to the um to the federal Regulators is
you know the bottom line how much you
made how much you brought in how much
you have for net income right and if
that's all they're going to report
that's all they're going to report we
can guess based on those numbers though
they said yo this is how much we made in
Services yeah right we can guess if
they're going up and down
um but yeah they're probably like King
saying they're probably in Decline uh
you know if and I don't know if this is
a viable thing if people are seeing this
ABK thing and saying this is going to
happen
and my purchase my future purchase of a
console right because we're still at the
beginning of the Gen right yeah yeah is
that I'm a Call of Duty player it seems
and especially with the thing that just
happened weeks ago with a 360. the 360
numbers going up it's almost like you're
right like dice is happening where it
feels like no it's about to happen so
like there's a Resurgence so to speak on
the last box right you know 360 uh Xbox
platforms with Call of Duty and they're
like okay well you know what maybe my
ecosystem needs to go the other
direction and I want to go back to the
Heyday of Call of Duty and to me that's
that's when Call of Duty oh yeah that's
my cold 360 era was it and mostly the
Xbox One PS4 gen it's been on decline
yes right so and the best games we've
had of in the last five six seven years
have been the remakes of yeah yeah the
golden year was yeah right golden
everyone so it's like okay if that's
really the best and we have those here
in Game Pass the servers are going to be
up I can keep playing those I'll get the
new ones it may be a shift that's
happening right how much I don't know
yeah right but even you know Mike you
know Sony came out and said look this is
a big deal for us this is a big part of
our Revenue stream uh it could hurt us
Etc et cetera right maybe they're right
that maybe this will be a shift how much
again percentage could be five ten
percent I don't know but that is enough
to say we don't want to report the
numbers look if you went from 50 and
lose 10 percent 5 million like gone all
right so 45 million and that's 45 and
they're going to go down further down to
like 30 something you know low 40s they
don't want to report that that's fair
and so I don't know where this ends up
right we'll see the other things are as
people are going away from uh being
locked down right so we you know people
might have gone in in 2020 and said hey
I'll just buy three years of PS plus
because I'm locked at home and let's run
out and I can go outside now and I don't
want to play games as much okay fair
enough that's another thing that can
happen right so right so there's been a
decline in Revenue this could be a part
of that too
um but yeah it is interesting that
they're deciding not to report they may
see this as an ongoing Trend because
usually if it's a dip you'd say okay if
I will just talk about the dip and then
we expect to get it back right right so
I think this is going to continue to
decline and so if that's the case then
they need to ramp up like you notice
they said 4K for their Cloud right
they're trying yes yes they're doing
what is that projects they get they come
in the cloud right so they're going to
try to push more to see if they get so
ultimately and like we've all been
saying they're going to start doing day
and day you're going to have to compete
that you can thank us PlayStation
players you will be getting those
benefits that's gonna happen at some
point they will have to compete it feels
like they will have to bring the
customers back and that's how they're
going to do it so it is what it is right
like this this constant need to keep
like like you were saying like we're the
ones who make these companies do what
they're doing but keep buying right if
if we said no I'm not gonna pay you and
that's what's happening We're not gonna
pay you you got to give me what the
other people are giving me why why
should I expect less right that's when
that company has to come to the table
this is a good thing for everyone if
they decide to finally do what they
should do which is freaking at least put
half of your games day ending like if
they're gonna make all these games as a
service games and not put them in their
service they're doing a disservice time
oh for sure do I agree games is the
service do it like sea of Thieves exists
because it was in Game Pass yes right it
got horribly rated but because it was in
Game Pass people tried it they're like I
actually kind of like this right right
and they stuck around and then rare was
able to put in more content and it
worked out right so if that wasn't there
right that's what like Sony's gonna have
to learn that lesson do you really want
to say 70 bucks entry fee right and
you're trying a whole new genre on a
console that doesn't generally do this
okay good luck with that I would suggest
put it in a PS plus right let's see what
you get right but these are things that
so yes the decline is interesting it
does mean that that they're expecting
more of that that's why they didn't want
to report the numbers so I would expect
that to kind of dissipate they're not
going to tell us that but we can guess
from the amount of services Revenue if
it's increasing decreasing what's
happening with the subscriber numbers
but yeah so that's what I I think that's
where that is uh the hardware thing is
going to be very interesting to see what
happens you know very no very much so
now thank you brother that was well said
uh solve your thoughts k n seems to be a
little accurate this week I have to I
must
I thought it was hilarious that he found
an Italian website
I've never heard of press Italy 24
international business the international
which is just sourcing but yeah what
about this week's candidates
um what do you think USB ports uh
covered in hot and PlayStation Plus
number reported
only King could find out
I was like what the hell
yeah I mean
to hargit's point it's just a matter of
like this this is this is what you can't
when you think about when you think
about the sort of closed ecosystem of a
console
is only so far you can push that console
it's not like a PC that's built for a a
wide range of cooling and and sort of uh
differently specked sort of components
that will you know create a larger range
Xbox One a larger range of heat than you
would see on a console so a console and
SOC is built to deal with a certain
range of heat no more no less
so if that is the case where we are
looking and the thing is did they say
did they say what because you know you
could run and play tips and tricks no
the tips and tricks did they say what
mode they were running Street Fighter in
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's 120 hertz mode right
um and then there's just a more sort of
whatever uh Fidelity mode whatever so it
would be interesting to see what you
know the heat levels are at those
different modes and see what they were
doing and evil didn't immediately
respond to requests for comment on the
controllers melting it should that some
competitors were using unlicensed
converters for their old PS4 flight
sticks on PS5 due to the lack of cross
system compatibility it's possible that
issues could have Arisen from using
unlicensed Hardware it's also it's
uncertain if the affected USB ports were
from defective ps5s
the burn
oh they put it in was a bird he only got
10 minutes in this mode
it is kind of like I don't know they
they need to start just as an evil
conversation it's like well this is
their thing now right so you would think
they start sort of creating a baseline
for what they accept in the tournament
and not accepted the tournament so guys
is coming in with good fun with
Contraptions with Contraptions
um because again could things like this
happen and then it's a conversation that
you never wanted to have that you have
to have because you know a third-party
thing I I really don't it would be weird
to me that them knowing have having
tested the PlayStation 5 with their
components over all this time
put themselves in a situation where the
thing could flame up and burn in the
middle of a tournament
so it's just hilarious to me that these
things happen and yeah I mean fix it
like hargit was saying
what is this PS4 this Pro that's coming
what kind of what are the improvements
to that the heat dissipation thing is
always something you look to sort of
Rectify I don't know like if we if we
get an Xbox version of whatever a pro I
kind of it's going to be interesting to
see what they do with that because they
literally just built they just built a a
rectangular wind tunnel to to dissipate
heat right so and from what that leak
looks like it doesn't look like the form
factor is any different right if that is
the leak and that is you know a
prototype for what what's to come on the
PlayStation side whether it's a slim
which is I don't think it's a slim maybe
it's a pro it looks largely the same
somebody somebody said they're gonna
have to have half time at a time
yo
they got intermission
they said they gotta Implement halftime
in the evil tournament invisible you got
to relax you gotta relax bro it's
interesting it's interesting it's very
interesting
I want to see how they continue to
address this is what I would say I want
to see how they continue to address this
this video I'm putting Xboxes in there
so the PS plus subscribers yes yes so
the numbers what are we looking at the
numbers they talk about somewhere in the
50 million range something like that I
said
um
at the end of all right uh the latest
data on PlayStation Plus subscribers is
updated to April 30 of 2023 at the end
of the previous fiscal year the service
could count on 47.4 million users
enrolled in essential extra and premium
plans okay
and then the higher tiers are counting
for nearly 30 percent of the users right
um
which is weird to me right because again
to Hardee's Point hargit feels that at
some point look they're just gonna have
to be forced into giving you day to date
and I think maybe many of us that are in
those tears are just hopeful like yeah
they don't do it one day or whatever
um
I don't know like to be to be very Frank
it is
because they know to this point they
haven't shown any signs of wanting to do
that it's weird that that you have a lot
of people in those old in those top
tiers because the middle the middle tier
is the one that is quote unquote most
akin to Game Pass right yeah it's that
tier that's going to give you the third
party sort of more AAA games and whatnot
you'll get those in there you'll get the
Sony stuff after it's written out for a
year year and a half two years whatever
you'll get that in there the top tier is
just basically giving you the cloud
stuff and the old games and the old
games like to be honest it had there's
really no reason to be in that tier uh
unless you're just a bit an idiot like
me
um because you're not getting a whole
lot of them they've been a little bit
better the past couple of months but to
pay that extra it's not really worth it
I know for a fact it's not right it's
not really working well it may not be
worth it if so if you've already played
the games but let's say it's your
ecosystem yeah if you're new to
ecosystem for sure you know you get
access to all this stuff right it it
makes it worth it it makes it worth it
on the surface level right but when you
really break down a kid
and you say hey sit down here and play
Twisted Metal One
I threw on just the middle one I would
not want to play that
it's one of those things that in theory
it is great
PS1 games don't hold up well they just
don't it's more for the Nostalgia Factor
throw it on oh wow that's awesome it's a
little smoothed out frame rate is better
um now there are certain things though I
looked at some of the PSP offerings like
Pursuit force and stuff like that that
game still plays really well it's really
fun to play PS1 games not so much so
it's a matter of what they start to
focus their efforts on when it comes to
the back of that thing if this is really
going to be viable but again it just
kind of does feel like the PlayStation
subscribers are just
really like that middle tier and then
the smaller portion of that is to that
higher tier and the hopes that it will
continue to improve and and also just
for like the the older player that's
like you know what I don't have my PS1
anymore any chance to play these games
again and just kind of have them
nostalgically for a couple of bucks or
just pay whatever I have to pay in the
service to get access to them I will do
um they do you know they are smoothed
out they do play better A lot of them
have been added another the achievement
Hound the achievement Hound is one
that's going to be like hey I can play
Twisted better one now and get
achievements that's cool whatever but in
terms of the numbers being what they are
you got to understand they have these
three tiers
I
so King's Point is that the numbers are
fishy all right am I am I not right yeah
he's that he's dead well no he's saying
that they're fishing he's just saying
that that there's no more growth than
that that because like you only they
will stop reporting when you either
declining numbers
or if you've kind of stayed stagnant if
if their efforts in the multiplayer
space are fruitful and these games turn
out to be good or if they're based on
known franchises that excite the base
um you're gonna see people jump back in
where they're good or not right we'll
find that out afterwards but I do think
of those games and those efforts are are
good you're gonna see that plateauing
sort of start to elevate again so
definitely that
um but again it it comes down to the
consumer being smarter about the
decisions they make and not just blindly
putting money into stuff and when you
start seeing that oh I played this game
already or if you we have both consoles
right I have Game Pass already and a lot
of these games on Game Pass already I
don't need to do it again on the
PlayStation it is you know you're gonna
start having people be making that
decision like all right do I really play
multiplayer on Playstation if you're not
a PlayStation first guy
there really is no reason to pay for a
multiplayer access on a PlayStation
right there really isn't
especially if Call of Duty is your game
and you decide to do that on the other
side right yeah right
there's also a potential that people
just forego the new console right this
is a time where they would be on the PS4
saying do I want to go to PS5 or not
yeah that's another thing maybe they
just don't have one yet and they're like
I don't want to keep paying what's the
point yeah so this stuff is interesting
we'll really see we'll really see how
what happens with these numbers once we
you know we if we get a pro we get a
slim we'll see where those numbers go
and it's gonna all depend on what goes
into that service at some point again
unless you're a PlayStation first player
and there's plenty of them you don't
really have a need to play you know for
that bot that based here right for me I
like to have the stuff so whatever right
it's there but I've I'm playing any
multiplayer games on the PlayStation so
you know
it's it's uh it's just gonna depend on
what they do to that service to make it
uh something that people want to jump
into and again we'll we're going to
start seeing those games soon so we'll
see we'll see how it moves the needle uh
unless they do
unless they do the rake step of not
putting not putting them day and day
into that series I mean which would be
like a the stupidest move ever but you
just you just never know right you never
know no jump in this is funny I have to
give KN credit is some valid stuff here
we work hard
ah cool you're top-notch reported you're
you're no nose to the ground
his sweet team is crazy
we got something good yeah yeah he was
didn't even look it's a hilarious look
like a kid I mean they're overheating
this seems to be true there's multiple
accounts his Twitter accounts posting I
cannot deny Kings KN street team on this
yeah it's hilarious but you know it's a
bad look especially because of the fact
it's their tournament you know it looks
bad so yeah they the question is is it a
result of like what hockey says sorry
hockey stop laughing he keeps somebody's
making me laugh I can't look at her
because he's laughing but is it is it a
result of what I get said which is maybe
this is a preemptive thing as to why
they are looking to go to another sister
because we all felt it was like Not
Unusual because they went from PS4 to
PS4 Pro but this seems very aggressive
early in the Gen to go slim to go like
they're being really early and I'm
wondering if you know that had a factor
into it as well as the amount of sales
that they look to project so that's all
I got they got to clean it up it's it's
a it's a bad look as far as the fighting
game tournaments because these these
kids put their heart what happened okay
now I'm just saying God forbid yeah I
forbid the kid is in the house and you
can burn the child
I mean come on man these kids put their
heart and soul into these tournaments
and I love Evo I love it so yeah you
don't want faulty Hardware bigger factor
in your your loss
yo it's crazy when they they say yo man
using Xbox or a PC
dude ain't Built For War shout out to
cartereta King's Italian news division
we'll give up at 3am with that breaking
news yeah Camden was on the scene
so we got that it's a live from the
Vatican
literally so we got Pope John Paul or
whatever I'm reporting oh yeah how do
you feel about the PlayStation uh not
living up to Snuff with the subscribers
we'll be interested to see what happens
in ABK because obviously Call of Duty
Evo is huge I'll be evil but Call of
Duty's Esports are huge and most likely
we would assume Microsoft's going to
take the marketing and we'll move on
from that so that there's that but to
the other thing I think this other thing
is more relevant in the ref not more
relevant but it's also relevant which is
the subscribers you know uh I'm 100 with
heart geek you tend to not want to
reveal yeah when the numbers are not as
favorable yeah that's just generally how
corporations work and yeah I think that
you know whether or not they've
plateaued you know we do have to look
into the fact that kind of what
microphil in the Xbox was saying was
that the cons it's not a question yes
kid good
when Microsoft stopped reporting numbers
the other team was talking about
that is true that the talk for years is
Microsoft show the numbers show the
numbers
right so the irony of this from Canada
news is now they are no longer reporting
PlayStation Plus subscribers that is
something to raise an eyebrow I'm gonna
have to give King this this is something
we have to monitor moving forward is
this a one-off is this the new normal
that's it this is it
yo I remember God I remember it was
probably like March and um
we hope dudes just like I told you they
was moving funny they don't look the
same and it's like yo King you gotta
have a series of this events to happen
in order for your prophecy yes yeah
actually that is true that is true you
know yeah you're coming for me now no no
no no no no no no no what I'm just
saying I'm just putting down the
universe
news is going to bring you the best baby
that VR PlayStation VR2 was a passion
project they did get inside and you know
the dust is collected on top you get
your insurance Ryan McCaffrey agrees
with you you know um yeah I told you
passion project uh something was wrong
with the Gran Turismo didn't look good
they were talking about the sky yeah
what happens I told you it was an
unstable box it wasn't gonna happen
yeah I told you what they did was
juggling
and apparently they were juggling hot
balls pause
and this is what happens when you juggle
too much stuff you just sometimes
yeah yeah you can't put in the back USB
port why have it then
this is things that is going on here
that people I'm just asking to open your
eyes and then when your favorite console
says we just ain't gonna report that to
you no more
all right for this moment
look it definitely subscribers you know
it's not the so test soft point they're
gonna have to make this subscription
serve if they look to improve it they
look they're gonna have to do things to
make it more attractive and the reality
is I think that what Xbox is saying in
the in the reports of the trial holds
more weight which is the console Market
is kind of saturated you've reached that
that Peak so you're gonna have to do
other things and we know their their
lack of willingness to do day in day as
far as PC stuff right there they're
looking to move it later I don't know if
that shifts I don't know if it's you
know any other things a perceived value
we know the premium tier they're going
what is it a project Kronos and you know
yeah they're going extremely hard with
um you know Cloud features now you know
as far as Cloud streaming right this is
something that again PlayStation guys
were very resistant when they used to
hear Microsoft talk about this stuff and
this is not the future but this is like
hockey saying this is what Sony's
mimicking we have information now that's
showing the pivot right so yeah I think
that's the case I I want to see you know
how long this trend continues if it does
you know what I'm saying as far as the
lack of subscribe but yeah it's
definitely something to put an eye on
because I know they don't want to be
left out so they may have to Pivot and
sometimes with Sony historically they
move like a behind like kind of what
Target you would say when PS4 caught up
as far as features things that was going
on with Xbox one even though they got
vilified ended up being copied and ended
up being an industry standard and stuff
like that so yeah what you got about to
see what's going on but yes King I am
paying attention to your reporting or
this so 99 right all the time yes to add
to that I guess if you think about it
like so Microsoft like Phil said that
the console as far as Game Pass is kind
of at its level and that's kind of where
PlayStation is now the the beauty for
Xboxes they decided they're not going to
be on just console correct they've got
PC games yes which is growing which is
growing yeah and then they're doing the
streaming thing now Sony's saying hey
we'll do the streaming thing which I
don't know if that's a market or not
that's easy is absolutely a market yes
they could totally take PlayStation Plus
and say hey we'll give you you know a
premium here here and give you PC games
yeah and shout out to live Supremacy not
to you know he actually got a point he
said even judge courtly in the trial
said PlayStation should put their games
in day and date to make PlayStation Plus
service better because they were like
well why doesn't they were like why are
you so worried about Game Pass with Call
of Duty why don't you make your service
better that was the counter continue it
hard exactly yeah go ahead since since
the pla the console has plateaued and
what we've seen is the subscribers
I think 120 is is it um
you know I just want to bring this up
because somebody said something last
week and I just want to get this out
because
um they were saying the ads wasn't up
for Starfield and then when the ads did
come out for Starfield they said no
consoles necessary and I saw there was a
lot of uh you know ponies or Sony
whatever these guys are called These are
those terms yeah we don't use racial
Slanders here we won't be using those
things the blue teams
The Blue Team those guys those blue guys
they were talking about that's an L
because you don't need a console to play
this you guys got TCL televisions they
said Samsung bruh and those TVs is 2000
and better bruh like so you mean to tell
me instead of going to get a little man
you'll be worrying about going to get a
two thousand dollar television you know
this is a bonus for the two thousand
dollars
that's right those individuals that
decided I just wanted to do it on the
Samsung and if you would never gonna buy
a console all you have to do is pick up
a controller see I got that Samsung
television upstairs and it has Game Pass
built inside and I can stream games so
to reach a broader audience this is not
a clown situation this is not a flex you
talking about oh they they that's an L
for them no dummy no yeah because the
world turning on you you're talking to
uh uh Echo chamber of people who not
seeing the trends and Sony's moving yeah
Sony's movements are showing what you're
saying right they're joining us yeah
they're literally mimicking certain
things at least positioning themselves
to be in that space and they're not yeah
trying to stay stagnant that is a good
sign look but Cog yes it may have that
app that Sony Playstation app inside the
the Sony Vega uh uh console I mean uh
TVs forgive me if I was wrong
Sony uh app inside the televisions and
being that it wasn't used that much
because nobody was buying songs I
haven't bought a Sony TV in a while so I
don't know if they're using the
PlayStation remote feature I don't know
I'm not saying it's not I'm just saying
I'm not sure
k n news will be back to reporting this
thank you sir so yeah that's all I got
let's see how this plays out and uh yeah
let's get
at the poll we gotta get super chest
lined up
just get a party it's a long one
[Laughter]
oh let me see I get the poll if you want
to say yeah that's cool with the
extremely positive reviews of Baldur's
Gate 3 which feeling do you more closely
align with regarding developer success
Larry's success I should say Detroit saw
eight Debs should never be weaponized
against each other to mimic an outlier
like baldi's gate three Choice B balls
Gate 3 should be used as a shining
example for others devs to mimic its
Excellence see game we should Gamers
should demand more from Publishers and
the current state of AAA launches or D
all that sounds nice y'all still going
bend the knee and buy that Red Dead part
one when it's all said and done
Rock the vote when it goes up on Twitter
Village
vegetarian heart Geet should be doing
the full ILP gamut the marathon the man
put in work he had snacks he knew what
he was in for and he was here for the
smoke changing backgrounds feels like I
was talking to two kings today at some
point but we're gonna let that go
tremendous gaming history and for real
one of the most positive members of our
community always brings people and
please thank you thank you please games
y'all where can the fine people find you
what do you have got going on Sir yeah
so I'm not on social media but I am on
Discord if you want to catch me there
it's h Johnny that's my uh my Discord
handle and then uh age Chinese also my
gamertag on Xbox uh and this first
podcast uh you know check out uh game on
daily it's okay withdaily.com uh
youtube.com
yeah and then um uh RDX which is dealer
gaming channel uh we have our uh usual
Tuesday night podcast 8 PM us eastern
time and then uh Primetime gaming
[Music]
7 PM us eastern Time is on Wednesdays
nice so shout out to Boom shout out
there look man you're out there in these
streets fans good to see you finally we
got it first of all appreciate your
patience you know what I'm saying we've
been talking about this for a long time
and you've been so cool and it was
really cool to kind of we all we did
packs which was always dope when you
when you pull up and that's always fun
but it was really fun to like do some
games fast and just like talk to the
exact same you know just be as part of
the energy and I really I actually like
the the hotel lobby for we just talking
and it just yeah next time yeah
definitely come to my the hotel oh yeah
your hotel is lit oh and by the way me
and her geek bought our dinners yes just
for the record this pictures floating
around with uh yeah with Aaron Greenberg
yeah we paid we pay for it even I was
surprised at Eric
you're part of illuminati yeah we all
Illuminati we all well funded but that
particular hello breakfast was funded by
Laura Cognito and hargit we did our own
lifting
the microphone checks came later right
because you know how dudes running with
the narratives you got to make sure that
particular one was not funded but anyway
now salute to you brother we have fun
with those jokes we was laughing it was
always good to see you hopefully we see
you uh some more events maybe uh no pack
me taxis or whatever we'll see yeah
we'll definitely just catch up in fact
season of course shout out to risky for
the business he said damn straight we
paid
sir you're Illuminati you're bought and
paid for we have to check the receipts
on you you're well funded I heard Xbox
Australia checks are lit so we gotta
watch your how you moving now you blew
it up come on mate and what kick said
Colt come out cold come out
[Laughter]
that fateful day on breakfast all right
we got it all cleared now it's all clear
sorry
yes sir real quick uh let me see we got
Robert Kelly does Factor have the beef
Sunday and joystick
wow
yeah we'll have to see
Robert got it again PS5 is the next
George Foreman Grill cook that meat
he was funny
PS5 can't take it from the rear needs
protection
music please
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we have Elias with the five dollars
which happen Nintendo switch always
coming in hot PS5 hold my USB
oh yeah yeah risk it for the biscuits
we had Xbox infinite fear not the ire of
Sony fans they risk it you about the
smoke sir I will give you that you are
all about this vote you and King get on
Grapevine we can get you in the realm
eventually yes sir here we have Hector
the Macho Man ten dollars if we chat
General King operation fire starter with
the success at Evo
why are they acting like they report the
kid for successful dishes like he's
sending them out to do to do here
he seems like he got crash Debbie's
descendable Ambitions to do stuff to
sabotage Saudi news thank you Soldier
yeah they're going out they're creating
the news
I didn't notice why they got a city
reported successfully there
now me and Lord addicts wolf pack are
trying to locate Jim Ryan Source says he
is hiding out with fractions and free R
Kelly
watch your man out absolutely watch your
man for being absolutely messy
and we have the rubber knob five dollar
Super Chat I could just see Jim hiding
in the bushes out back toasting
marshmallows on PS5
operation Firestone it's crazy
right there wow that's different that's
different then we have sir duck member
for 37 months Lord bronze glad I got the
PS5 big block haven't had overheating
yet but when I do I'm going to make sure
I cook those beefy sticks well done
you play Wild today boy oh wow yeah we
have Stitch two dollars Super Chat those
ps5s we're doing the hot ship did the
hot ship challenge
then we have Michael Mooney with the
flat power Super Tank in the UK there's
deals for a PS5 plus 24 months of
premium for 32 a month 22 pounds a month
yeah okay okay
then we have S Cruz Eight dollar Super
Chat you know it's bad when a console
that sets itself on fire is still
whooping Xbox for sale two to one wow
yeah okay
just found out the fire and we just
started we just heard that they're not
reporting any more numbers so I think
you should just pump your bricks sir the
war has just begun
then we have a selfish burrito with a
six-pack with the six Euro two Super
Chat Wow
worth noting for the premium PS plus
tier the remasters are in there Yakuza
three four and five The Last of Us
remaster spring to my spring to mine oh
Last of Us remastered bring to mind so
not just PS1 PSP games so yes they are
at the top tier they they are some day
one things I believe straight was part
of that there are some that are in the
middle two tiers like the top tier and
whatever the middle tier is there are
some that have been just topped here so
absolute salute then we have Angry
hippie two dollars of a chat
Pope King Mass Exodus Emoji when
we have slobo back slap uh two dollars
Forte told me that playing games on a
TCL is a okay
yeah then we got let's put the crest in
the chat for the newest member of the
realm Lord bronze God Emperor Sofa King
okay God emperor okay that's it we're
caught up oh we caught up those guys
with everybody in the realm shoot the
Lord out of here at the dip Lord
software couldn't find people find you
what you got going on Sir uh running
running I gotta go see my family before
they uh head out to the airport before
they leave because they're leaving
tonight so I just gotta go bye and say
hi um you can find me trying to maybe
play some games we'll see we'll see how
that goes for that guy like with your
shout out to back for that in the chat
good to see you bro get the link up with
you at gcx that's my men's Lord King
where can find people find you what you
got going on sir before besides
reporting news no one else gets yeah we
working hard you working we working very
hard but I would like to give a shout
out to uh you know thank you so much for
coming through I wish you would be at
Pax West you know um didn't get a chance
to hang out with you and Cali this year
I mean the plan is that way but um you
know stuff happens but you know stuff
works out for how it works out but it's
always great seeing you that PAX East I
love hearing your game and knowledge and
your flex your Flex is incredible what's
up that's what we
[Laughter]
hey you can catch me on Twitter King
David otw's team gamer tag on Xbox on my
PlayStation
um uh Game Pass lover 360 something
something right it's pretty fast
and I could put that out
um look look to the realm you know shout
out to Ben again look to the realm of uh
you know Kickstarter we're about to do
some stuff some stuff is about to happen
it's about to come out and uh we're
gonna have people sign up for that and
get the newsletter and Trust and Believe
oh
it on oh yeah crazy stuff for everybody
that did get a Volari pillow Ferrari
pillows are still on sale it didn't stop
happening so you know go in and get a
Volari pillow a link in the description
also if you know you got that Focus oh
yeah yeah yeah you know sure
you know uh we ain't playing out here
remember the mobile read was dope check
that out remember uh cold uh uh
mintmobile.com forward slash Iron Lords
go check that out and um listen thank
you guys for hanging out we had a
thousand people watching I appreciate
each and every last one of you don't
even you know even if you super chat you
don't Super Chat the fact that you are
here spending time with us and having
fun we appreciate everything thank you
again no doubt again much love send love
to the room on again hug you should eat
much love to have you pull up finally
bro that was bad fun and again we got
cool we got some stuff I can't I don't
want to jinx it spoil it y'all don't
want to miss next week yeah I don't want
to miss next week next week could be
potentially special
um not like this was it was but we we
got some things that we've been trying
to work on for a while so stay tuned to
the realm you know we'll reveal it when
the time is right and uh yes let's get
uh let's get everybody enjoying this
Sunday oh you super chat again one more
Super Chat but I I didn't say anything
with the heart geek I apologize
from the moment we met the first time in
PAX East my apologies trying to rush out
of here love you man the fact you coming
you come out you you hang out with us
and and you show so much love it is
amazing amazing and then the fact that
you're now like part of the podcasting
Community as well everybody gets to see
your Acumen for the for the gaming space
I love it man so so thank you once again
for joining us it's long long over long
overdue yeah we've been talking about
this since PAX East at the top of the
Year yes so this may have been patient
he he never complained a lot of dudes be
complete what's going on I'm like bro
the list is crazy but now hoggy got you
bro I told you he said I don't worry
about it I know you good um stage 1X he
says are y'all coming to Seattle yes the
Lords will be at Pax West pull up if you
in the area salute that's all I gotta
get the Super Chat yes sir uh all right
shout out to Gene Park as well
G now the fact she was on fire today
yeah yeah Gene had to speak today I need
to get a list fast look and we got one
more Super Chat two dollars for chat
from Stitch I meant to say chip okay so
one chip challenge is PS5 look that's
all I got everybody enjoy your Sunday
thank y'all for rocking with us this was
a lot of fun tune in next week trust me
You Ain't Gonna Wanna Miss it I won
three thousand next week guys
thank you
[Music]
foreign